THIS BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE TO WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. AS
WE CONTINUE TO- TO. TAKE
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ON. AS WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE PRECAUTIONS TO
MANAGE ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN
RISK THE SENATE CONTINUES TO
WELCOME THE PUBLIC HAS PROVIDED
ACCESS TO BOTH IN PERSON THE
TELECONFERENCE PARTICIPATION
REPUBLICAN MEANT. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR VISIT THE
PARTICIPATION TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR
ZERO. I WILL. MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING WHICH IS
CUSTOMARY IN AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTED MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE ROW READING SERVICE OR
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED. WE ARE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING HERE. HERE
IN THE- STREET- BUILDING I HAVE
SAID ALL MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THE PRESIDENT ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED- AS WE CAN. BUT
WILL BEGIN OUR HEARING. ARE
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY THE
COMMITTEE- ALSO PURCHASE WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES AND COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I S. IT
EVERY TIME THAT YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED. THAT SHE USED TO
RAISE THE HAND FEATURE ON YOUR
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU WILL BE
RECOGNIZED. TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING YOU
TO. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND
MUTE PLEASE SELECT A MUTE-
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R. I.
T. STAFF WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK- PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU'RE SEEING ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND THEY
WERE RATE THAT YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC GASES WE'RE
MEETING MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING THE TELECONFERENCE ARVEST
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. PUBLIC WILL BE
HEARD. AFTER ALL OUR DISCUSSION
ITEMS- HAVE BEEN PRESENTED. OKAY
WE HAVE TO- BYNUM'S ON TODAY'S
AGENDA NOT SMALL ITEMS BUT TWO
ITEMS- SO LET'S START WITH ISSUE
NUMBER ONE IT'S AN INFORMATION-
ITEM ON CARBON CAPTURE AND ALL
NOTE THAT MULTIPLE SOURCES. AND
REPORTS IT SUGGESTS THAT THERE'S
A LACK OF COMMERCIALLY
DEPLOYABLE CARBON REMOVAL
TECHNOLOGIES- THAT MAY BAR
CALIFORNIA FROM REACHING OUR
CARBON NEUTRALITY GOAL OF TWENTY
FORTY FIVE WILL GO INTO A DEEP
DISCUSSION ON THAT IS CONTAINED
IN OUR STAFF REPORT AND THIS IS
EVEN ASSUMING THAT WE- IF WE
DON'T HAVE A SIGNIFICANT CARBON
CAPTURE PROGRAM AND WE HAVE A
WHOLESALE TRANSITION TO GREEN
ENERGY ACROSS MULTIPLE SECTORS
WE STILL WILL MEET OUR OUR
CARBON GOALS. SO I THINK WE HAVE
THE L. A. O. MISTER BROWN GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR ACROSS FROM AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF SAYS AFTER
OFFICE TO PRESENT THIS ISSUE
ITEM ON CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE- BEFORE I PROVIDE SOME
OF OUR COMMENTS AND THE BUTTON
BACKGROUND IF YOU LOOK THROUGH
HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS I DO WANT TO
NOTE THAT- THIS ISN'T AN ISSUE
THAT OUR OFFICE IS DONE ENOUGH
ANALYSIS UP AND SO. AS A RESULT
WE MIGHT NOT HAVE SOME IMMEDIATE
ANSWERS TO ALL THE KIND OF
TECHNICAL AND POLICY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE WE ARE OF
COURSE ALWAYS HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP
WITH ADDITIONAL INFORMATION IF
THAT'S HELPFUL I DO ALSO WANT TO
KNOW IT BELIEVES- ENERGY
COMMISSION HAVE STAFF ON THE
CALL. TO ALSO HOPEFULLY CAN HELP
ANSWER QUESTIONS AND PROVIDE
MORE DETAIL THAT'S AWFUL RIGHT
THEM OUR HOPE IS ALSO TO HAVE
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS PUT ON THE
RECORD TO THAT YOU KNOW WE CAN
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU OKAY GREAT
SO- THE GOAL MY INITIAL COMMENTS
ARE REALLY JUST TO KIND OF SET
THE STAGE FOR THE ISSUE AND
QUITE A BIT OF CONTACTS SO WITH
THAT IN MIND I'M GONNA FOCUS MY
COMMENTS IN JUST A FEW MAJOR
THINGS FIRST YOU KNOW IT JUST
HIGH LEVEL DESCRIPTION OF WHAT
IS THE C. S. SECOND WHAT'S THE
POTENTIAL ROLE FOR CCS AND QUIET
MEDITATION. ABSURD WATER SOME OF
THE AVAILABLE FUNDING SOURCES
AND AN EXISTING POLICIES THAT
PROMOTE CCS. THE FIRST- THE TERM
CARBON CAPTURE STORAGE OR CCS
CAN BE USED IN A VARIETY OF WAYS
TO CAPTURE A WIDE RANGE OF
POTENTIAL GREENHOUSE GAS
MITIGATION TECHNOLOGIES AND
STRATEGIES SO I WANT THROUGH
SORT OF A FEW OF THOSE BUT I
THINK YOU KNOW SOME OF THIS
ISSUE IS JUST A- SORT OF A
MATTER OF TERMINOLOGY AND
DIFFERENT PEOPLE USE DIFFERENT
TERMINOLOGY SOMETIMES. I THINK
MOST COMMONLY OF THE TERM CCS
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE IS
APPLIES TO NOT TECHNOLOGIES THAT
ARE REMOVING CARBON DIOXIDE TO
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE ADMITTED
AT A PARTICULAR FACILITY LIKE A
POWER PLANT SO BIOFUEL PLANT OR
INDUSTRIAL FACILITY IN SIR
CAPTURING THAT CARBON. IN THE
ATMOSPHERE. AND STORING SEPHORA
OR- IT IN SOME CASES MAKE IT OF
FOR. SOME PLANTS- ANOTHER
CATEGORY. KNOWN AS KIND OF
CARBON AND- ROOM. OR SOME CASES
KIND OF NEW EMISSIONS. AND THESE
ARE. TECHNOLOGIES THAT YOU KNOW
DIRECT TAKE- CARPENTER OUT OF.
ALSO NOT AT OF PUTS YOU FACILITY
BUT KIND OF GET OUT OF AIR- THE
IS SOMETIMES KNOWN AS- AFTER
CAPTURING SOME- AND THERE'S
OTHER- CUT NATURE. SOLUTIONS ARE
TECH THAT A COURSE ALSO OF- AND
STORE AND SUPPRESS CARBON- SUCH
AS KNOW FOR SPANISH CHANGES AND
WHAT WHAT ANOTHER LIKE THAT- SO
I THINK. MATTER IS GONNA THE
BOOK IS A THIS ISSUE THIS ITEM
IS NOT MORE ON THE KIND OF TECH.
BASED SIDES BUT I JUST WANT TO
KIND OF PROVIDE THAT CONTEXT IF
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF.
TECHNOLOGIES AND SOLUTIONS THAT
KIND OF STUFF SOMETIMES FALL
INTO THIS TERMINOLOGY. SECOND
JUST A COUPLE COMMENTS ON THE
ROLE FOR SOME THESE.
PARTICULARLY KIND OF TECH
FOCUSED ONES- THEY ARE AS A SURE
MENTION KIND OF A OFTENTIMES A
MAJOR PART OF MANY OF THE
PATHWAYS THAT ARE ANALYZED
MEETING. BOTH INTERNATIONAL AND
STATE LEVEL CLIMATE TARGETS- SO
FOR EXAMPLE MANY OF THE
SCENARIOS THAT ARE PART OF THE
IPCC REPORTS I'M TRYING TO SORT
OF NEED- VARIOUS CLIMATE TARGETS
INCLUDE CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL
AND CCS. SOME OF THE CARDS IN
AREAS THAT ARE ANALYZED AS PART
OF THE CURRENT SCOPING PLAN
PROCESS ASSUME SOME SIGNIFICANCE
OF CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL WOULD
BE NEEDED- IN TWENTY FORTY FIVE
AT LEAST. ARMS AND IN GENERAL
THE THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE.
INCLUDED IN THESE SCENARIOS- IN
PART TO SORT OF ADDRESS SOME OF
THE HARD TO DECARBONISE PARTS OF
THE ECONOMY SO FOR EXAMPLE- YOU
KNOW PROVIDING- OF- ZERO CARBON
ELECTRICITY- AND KIND OF HIGH
PERCENTAGE RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY
GRID. YOU KNOW SOMETIMES CCS IS
INCLUDED AS AS AN OPTION FOR-
NATURAL GAS POWER PLANTS TO TRY
TO HELP BALANCE TO GET THE GRADE
AND- PROVIDE RELIABLE
ELECTRICITY AT SOME OF THOSE
HIGH PERCENTAGE OF RENEWABLES
RIOS. OTHER TIMES JUST KIND OF
FOCUSED ON INDUSTRIAL SECTORS
WHICH ARE OFTEN HARD TO
DECARBONISE AND THERE AREN'T A
LOT OF KIND OF EXISTING
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE. SO CCS
IS ONE OF THE OPTIONS IS OFTEN
KIND OF HIGHLIGHTED AND IN THAT
CONTEXT AND THEN. THINGS LIKE
DIRECTOR CAPTURE AND KIND OF
OTHER TYPES OF CARBON RENEWABLE. REMOVAL ARE OFF. I DON'T IF I
DOES NOT. GETTING A THAT OTHER-
AREAS OF THE ECONOMY LIKE ABA.
FUEL USE RADIO ARE- ALSO VERY TO
BE. AND SO- THERE MIGHT BE A
ROLE FOR SOME OF THE SECT OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES KIND OF. TO- TO
TAKE CARBON OUT OF THE
ATMOSPHERE TO KIND OF OFFSET
SOME OF THOSE THOSE EMISSIONS
THAT MIGHT REMAIN FOR QUITE
AWHILE. SO SERVICE AND FINALLY I
REALLY JUST WANNA. PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND ON THE
BUDGET AND POLICY LANDSCAPE
HERE- BURSTS THERE WAS SOME
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FUNDING IN
THE FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
THAT WAS PASSED LAST YEAR OR SO
FOR EXAMPLE THERE WAS FUNDING
FOR- DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS-
BERMAN CAPTURE AND STORAGE- AT
NATIONAL LEVEL TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION FOR DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS ANOTHER NINE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR LARGE SCALE PILOTS.
ALSO SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF
MONEY FOR STORAGE TRANSPORTATION
OF CARBON- THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION FOR DIRECT AIR CAPTURE
REGIONAL HUBS- OTHERS ARE JUST
SOME OF THE EXAMPLES OF THE
FUNDING THAT WAS A NATURAL
PACKAGE- THERE ARE SOME ALSO
THEY'RE ALL ALSO IS A FEDERAL
TAX CREDIT FOR- CARBON CAPTURE
AND STORAGE I ALSO WANTED TO.
RECOGNIZE. THAT AS WELL AND
MENTION THAT. EIGHT LEVEL
THERE'RE IS FUNDING. RELATED TO
SOME OF THE NATURE BASED-
SEQUESTRATION SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
PROPOSED AS PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS. PACKAGING OF THE
LEGISLATURE- SET ASIDE FUNDING
FOR. THINGS LIKE WETLAND
RESTORATION AND THINGS LIKE
THAT- BUT NOT AS MUCH THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED FOR. A
TECHNOLOGY FOCUS KIND OF CAPTURE
AND STORAGE PROJECTS. IN CASE I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AND I THINK IS
HIGHLIGHTED IN YOUR AS WELL AS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S CLEAN
ENERGY PACKAGE INCLUDED. ALSO
FOR TO LEARN TEN NO. FOUR
INDUSTRIAL DECARBONISATION
PROJECTS- AT SOME OF THAT
FUNDING COULD BE USED FOR CARBON
CAPTURE AND- UTILIZATION
ACTIVITIES I DO WANT TO NOTE
THAT THAT PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY
EXCLUDED. ARE PROJECTS THAT
WOULD JUST- INCLUDE GEOLOGIC
STORAGE SO STORING THAT CARBON
CARBON ESSENTIALLY UNDERGROUND-
THAT IS AN ISSUE THAT WE
HIGHLIGHTED IN OUR ANALYSIS OF
THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO.
THINK ABOUT- POTENTIALLY SORT OF
EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY IN TRYING
TO- EXPLORE SORT OF YOU KNOW
WHATEVER THAT THE MOST. COST
EFFECTIVE AND- FEASIBLE OPTIONS
ARE FOR STORING CARBON AND- AS
TECHNOLOGIES FORWARD SO WANTED
LIKE THAT AS WELL THERE ARE
LASTLY THERE ARE SOME OTHER.
POLICIES FOR EXAMPLE THE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD AT THE
STATE LEVEL THAT'S- TO PROVIDE
INCENTIVES FOR SONS DCS
PROJECTS- MOSTLY FOCUSED ON-
PRODUCTION OF TRANSPORTATION
FUELS THERE'S ALSO IT ALSO
ALLOWS FOR. MONEY TO GO TO
EVENTUALLY FOR DIRECTOR CAPTURE
PROJECTS. SO FINALLY- I DO JUST
WANT TO KNOW THAT THERE'S A- BUT
THIS IS A TOPIC THAT THERE IS
PROPOSED LEGISLATION ON ABOUT
RIGHT IT GIVES THE PROPOSED
LEGISLATION AND HOUSE-
INDISCRETION OF. ARE THE SUBJECT
OF LEGISLATIVE DISCUSSIONS IN
RECENT YEARS- AND AS YOUR AGENDA
NOTES THE SENATE DEMOCRATIC
BUDGET PLAN. DOES INCLUDE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR- CCS
PROJECTS. SO I WILL IN MY
COMMENTS THERE HOPEFULLY THAT
PROVIDES A LITTLE BIT OF. LOCAL
CONTEXT AND BACKGROUND ON THE
ISSUE AND- ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE. YEAH I. ONE QUESTIONS
READ YOU WHEN YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT D. INDUSTRIAL SECTOR AND
THAT THE HARD TO- DECARBONIZING
WE'VE HAD HEARINGS HERE IN SUB
TO BEFORE WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
LET'S SEE FOOD PROCESSORS AND
IT'S YOU KNOW THEY'VE TESTIFIED
THAT THEY REALLY NEED THE PRICE
OF CARBON NEEDS TO GET TO BE
ABOUT NINETY DOLLARS A METRIC
TON BEFORE IT MAKES SENSE FOR
THEM TO DECARBONISE. AND I KNOW
THAT WILL HAVE SOME OPPOSITION
TO THE JUST TALKING ABOUT THIS
IDEA FROM FOLKS THAT DON'T HAVE
ANY CARBON CAPTURE DID DON'T
DISCUSS IT AND ALL THAT BUT WE
DO STILL NEED OUR FOOD WITH
PEOPLE STILL WANT THEIR BABY
LETTUCE IN THE BAG- WOULDN'T
THAT BE. AN IDEAL. SECTOR IF YOU
WERE GOING TO LOOK AT IF YOU'RE
GONNA LOOK AT CARBON CAPTURE
GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF. THE FEDERAL
MONEY STEER. AND THEN THEN I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS THAT. THAT
IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S A ROAD BLOCK
GIVEN THE- ADMINISTRATION'S
LANGUAGE THAT YOU CAN'T. YOU
CAN'T COME. PUT IT BACK HOUSTON
GEOLOGICAL STORAGE IS AN ANSWER
EVEN IF EVEN IF. THE LOCATION
WAS AYE DELIC. RIGHT FOR CARBON
STORAGE THIS IS THAT WERE YOU OR
IS IT WORTHY ALEJO. YES SO ON
YOUR FIRST QUESTION ON FOOD
PROCESSORS I MET I THINK IT- IT
SEEMS LIKE THAT COULD BE SORT OF
THE ONE OF THE SOLUTIONS IN THAT
PARTICULAR SECTOR I MEAN I DON'T
KNOW. ENOUGH ABOUT ALL THE
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES THERE
COULD BE OTHER INSTANCES WHERE
AND OTHER TYPES OF TECHNOLOGIES
COULD WORK BUT I THINK. THE
OVERALL POINT AROUND JUST KIND
OF INDUSTRIAL SOURCES AND THE
TYPES OF HEAT THAT THEY MIGHT
NEED TO PRODUCE THEIR PRODUCTS
AND THEIR MANUFACTURING. ALSO
SEES- YOU KNOW SOMETIMES SOME OF
THE OTHER STRATEGIES OF THE
STATE EMPLOYEES LIKE
ELECTRIFICATION THEY MIGHT NOT-
WORK IN SOME OF THOSE INSTANCES
AND SO LOOKING AT OTHER OPTIONS
LIKE. ARBEN CAPTURE SEEM LIKE
THERE- BUT YOU KNOW COULD BE
KIND OF ONE WAY TO. TO MOVE
FORWARD IN THAT PARTICULAR AREA-
IN TERMS OF THE KIND OF AN
ADMINISTRATION'S. PROPOSAL THAT
WAS PUT FORWARD THAT CAN SORT OF
EXCLUDES. GEOLOGIC STORAGE YEAH
I MEAN I THINK- GIVEN SORT OF
THE SCOPE OF THE CHALLENGE OF
MEETING CARBON NEWCREST
NEUTRALITY GOALS ANDS- THE KIND
OF AMOUNT OF WORK THAT'S NEEDED
TO SORT OF TO REACH THOSE GOALS
AND MOST LIKELY THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE NEEDED TO MEET THOSE
GOALS OVER TIME WE- HAVING A
GENERAL THINK THAT'S- TRYING TO
FOCUS RESOURCES AND EFFORTS IN A
WAY THAT IS- AS TECHNOLOGICALLY
NEUTRAL AS POSSIBLE WHERE THE
STATE CAN KIND OF EXPLORER- A
LOT OF DIFFERENT OPTIONS THAT
CAN KIND OF HELP IT MEET ITS
CLIMATE GOALS- SEEMS LIKE A
GOOD. HALF GOING FORWARD NOW
THERE MIGHT BE. SOME INSTANCES
WHERE- THE LEGISLATURE THE
STATE'S SORT OF DETERMINES THAT
YOUR PARTICULAR APPROACH GOING
FORWARD HAS OTHER TRADE OFFS
THAT IT- YOU KNOW WHAT THE IT
DOESN'T WANT TO KIND OF
SACRIFICE OR OTHER IMPACTS THAT
IT AND YOU KNOW IT CONCERNS
IT'S- CARES MORE ABOUT SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF THERE ARE. OTHER
POTENTIAL IMPACTS ON THE LOCAL
AIR POLLUTION OR OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS THIS. KIND
OF OUR WAY- SOME OF THOSE OTHER
FACTORS THAT I TALK ABOUT IN
TERMS OF KIND OF TECHNOLOGICAL
NEUTRALITY THE NIGHT COULD PLAY
A ROLE BUT- OVERALL FROM A AT
LEAST FROM A PURELY ECONOMIC
PERSPECTIVE TRYING TO. EXPLORE
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES THAT
COULD. HELP THE STATE COST
EFFECTIVELY MEET SOME OF THE
SOME OF THESE AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
GOALS WE THINK IS A IT IS A GOOD
STRATEGY GOING FORWARD. AND THAT
WOULD GIVE US SOME GUIDANCE HERE
ON YOU KNOW THE FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL HAS THREE
POINT FIVE BILLION FOR DIRECT
CARBON. DIRECT AIR CAPTURE AND
WE KNOW THAT- AS WE GO. I LOOK
FOR TO. THIS WERE GOING TO HAVE
A CAP TRADE THE WE LOOK AT WHAT
THE- IS FOR THAT. THAT REDUCTION
AND OUR STAFF REPORT INDICATES
IT'S IN THE FIVE OR SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR. LEVEL WHICH IS YOU KNOW
IT'S ALMOST THAT'S- ALMOST THE
SIZE ROOFTOP SOLAR. NOW ROOFTOP
SOLAR IS MORE EXPENSIVE BUT JUST
KIDDING ALL KIDDING ASIDE- WITH
WITH THE- WITH THE NON
ATTAINMENT AREAS THAT WE HAVE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN. THE THREE
POINT FIVE. BILLION THAT'S
SITTING OUT THERE FOR THE- WHAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT EVEN
THOUGH IT'S EXPENSIVE GIVEN
GIVEN SORT OF YOU KNOW.
CALIFORNIA'S ALLEGED OUR
REPUTATION IS BEING A LEADER IN
TECHNOLOGY WOULDN'T THIS MAKES
SENSE THAT WE WOULD WANT TO
DIRECT SOME OF THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. TOWARDS MAKING THAT A
REALITY AT LEAST IN ONE OF THESE
NON ATTAINMENT AREAS I DON'T
KNOW WHO'S THE LUCKY LOTTO
WINNER WHETHER IT'S LA AND SOUTH
COASTERS SAN JOAQUIN OR WHOEVER
GETS THE DIRECT CAPTURE BIRD.
ISN'T DOESN'T IT MAKE SENSE JUST
A THEORETICAL LEVEL THAT WE
WOULD PUT MONEY IN TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET ONE OF THESE
PROJECTS IN THE WORST OF THE
WORST PLACES THAT HAVE- YOU
KNOW- CO TWO PROBLEM. I THINK
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT WAYS TO
LEVERAGE- FEDERAL FUNDING IS- IS
ONE OF A KIND OF- THANK A
TRACTIVE GOT AWAY DISPLACING
THINK ABOUT HOW TO ALLOCATE
STATE RESOURCES GIVEN SORT OF
THE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT'S
AVAILABLE. OUT THERE AND SO AS
YOU MENTIONED THIS SORT OF
DIRECT AIR CAPTURE HOMES CULD
BE ONE OF THOSE- EXAMPLES I MEAN
I DO WANT TO LET YOU KNOW I
DON'T KNOW SORT OF ENOUGH ABOUT.
EXACTLY WHAT THE DIRECTOR
CAPTURE HOMES WOULD LOOK LIKE-
BUT YEAH MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THEY WOULD FOCUS YOU KNOW
THAT THAT THE KIND OF TECHNOLOGY
FOCUSES. ON A CARBON I THINK I'M
TAKING CARBON OUT OF THE AIR-
AND SO THAT THAT'S REALLY THE-
GOAL LESS I'M GONNA BE- LOCAL
AIRPORT. SIDE OF THINGS AND SO.
NOW WITH WITH HIS LEGISLATIVE
DECISIONS AROUND HOW HOW TO
ALLOCATE RESOURCES THERE ARE
ALWAYS KIND OF A VARIETY OF
COMPETING PRIORITIES AND THINGS
TO THINK ABOUT AND WHERE TO.
WHERE TO ALLOCATE THE FUNDS BUT
CERTAINLY. THINKING ABOUT WAYS
TO USE STATE FUNDING TO THE KIND
OF LEVERAGE FEDERAL FUNDING TO
HELP ACHIEVE ITS ITS CLIMATE
GOALS AS ONE WOULD THINK
IMPORTANT. FACTOR TO CONSIDER
WHEN MAKING THOSE DECISIONS I
THINK YOU MAKE A GOOD POINT TO
BECAUSE SOMETIMES THE AIR
QUALITY DISCUSSIONS ROUNDS OUT.
THE THAT THE CARBON DISCUSSION
PEOPLE COME IN AND THEY WANT TO
HAVE THEIR AIR QUALITY WHICH IS
IT'S AN IMPORTANT THING BUT- AS
THE- AS THE- STAFF ANALYSIS IN
THE STEP ANALYSIS IN THE IN. THE
THAT THE NEXT. ISSUE NUMBER TO
TALK ABOUT IS THAT THAT. THAT
CARBON GOES. IS AROUND THE
WORLD- AND IN YOUR IN OUR LOCAL
NEIGHBORHOOD. ALL RIGHT. DON'T
GO AWAY WE HAVE SOME. HINTS HERE
AND I'M- SURE MY COLLEAGUES
WITH- HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ALSO
LET'S GO TO- SIEVERT. GUNDA THE
VICE CHAI OF THE- CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION. I BELIEVE
YOU'RE ON THE LINE FOR. A OF
YOUR MANAGER'S. YES- GOOD
MORNING AS CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I'M STILL GOING
TO VICE CHAIR OF THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND IF WE ARE
VIRGINIA LOU- MANAGER CONNECTING
THE COMMISSION TAUGHT IN THE
DIVISION AND A CLIENT MANAGER OF
THE COMMISSION EXCITING AND
ELEVEN O'CLOCK. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE YOU
WITH PUTTING THE INFORMATION
TODAY I'M GOING TO PROVIDE A FEW
COMMENTS ON THE CLEAN ENERGY
TRANSITION AND WILL PASS IT ON
TO BUT YOU NEED TO PROVIDE.
OPENING COMMENTS ON PCS. TWO BIG
WITH- CAL HAS. AN INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF PAIN YOU WILL. IN TOP
OF OUR PROGRAM INTO THE TWO. TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW. ACCOMPLISHMENTS
IN TWENTY TWENTY THE STATEMENT
THIRTY FOUR POINT 5% RBS TARGET.
AHEAD OF THE 33% PLAN TARGET.
HONEST A TOTAL APPROXIMATELY 60%
ZERO CARBON- CAN IN TWENTY
TWENTY- THAT ZERO CARBON NUMBER
FLUCTUATES A LITTLE BIT
DEPENDING ON HOW MUCH- HYDRO AND
A LEADING WE HAVE. IT IF YOU
THESE INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLANNING SYSTEM PLAN IS
ACTUALIZED WILL BE APPROXIMATELY
THAT SEVENTY THREE PERCENT- THE
NEW WILL AND EIGHTY SIX PERCENT.
GHG FREE RESOURCE THAT'S BY
TWENTY THIRTY TO. CALIFORNIA WAS
ALSO THE NATIONAL LEADER IN THE
INSTALLATION OF BATTERY STORAGE
LAST YEAR OVER TWO THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS OF NEW BATTERY STORAGE
INSTALLED IN CASE THE TERRITORY
. EXPECTED TO REACH NEARLY FORTY
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF STORAGE BY
THE END OF THIS SUMMER- AND THIS
IS FROM NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS TWO AND HALF YEARS AGO
SO COULD HAVE BEEN INCREMENTAL-
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF DEPLOYMENT
OF STORAGE OVER THE LAST TWO AND
HALF. YEARS WELL THE PROGRESS
TOWARD CLEAN ENERGY HAS BEEN
UNPRECEDENTED OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS THE IMPACT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE FUND. TICKER LIABILITY
HAS COME TO PORTLAND. I THINK
THE OTHER JUST IN TWENTY TWENTY
. AS CLIMATE CHANGE HAS LED TO
MORE EXTREME HEAT DROUGHT AND
WILDFIRES AT THE SAME TIME WE
BEGIN TRANSITIONING AWAY. FROM
THE AGING WANTS TO CLEAN UNITS
AND BRINGING UNPRECEDENTED
LEVELS OF CLEAN ENERGY SOURCES.
INSURANCE LIABILITY HAS BEEN
VERY CHALLENGING IS EXPECTED TO
BE SELF. IN ADDITION WHILE WE'RE
MAKING PROGRESS ON AUTHORIZING
CLEAN ENERGY PROCUREMENT. THE
CHALLENGES ARE CURRENTLY WITH IT
SO IF YOU DEPLOYMENT OF THE
COMMUNITY RESOURCES. SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES INCLUDE APPLY CHANGE
PERMITTING AND INTERCONNECTION
DELAYS TO NAME A FEW. THE SHEER
SCALE OF DEPLOYMENT- THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT OVER THE NEXT
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. WE MOVED TO
ADDRESS THE ONE HUNDRED TARGETS-
THE 100% RETAIL SALES APPLIED BY
THE NEW POLITICAL RESOURCES BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. THERE ARE A
FEW CRITICAL TEAMS THAT WE ARE
WORKING TOWARDS. ALL THE
AGENCIES COORDINATED KERR AT
CPUC CC ALONG WITH- COORDINATION
AND CONSULTATION HI SO AS WELL
AS OTHER BALANCING AUTHORITIES
AND- IN THE STATE AND THOSE ARE.
THE SCALE OF THE RESOURCE BUILD
AND DEPLETED WHICH WE MUST
EQUALITY SOCIAL A CRITICAL THING
TO PAY ATTENTION TO. ALONG WITH
THAT IS AFFORDABILITY
RELIABILITY. AND ENSURING AN
EQUITABLE TRANSITION. ONE OF THE
CRITICAL TO CONTINUE TO BE ITEM
WILL CONDUCT THE NEXT STUDY.
HAVE A ACTS TO THE CARD. FORM
AND DISPATCH RESOURCES. WE'RE
ALREADY WORKING ON DEPLOYING
BATTERY STORAGE- WHICH IDEALLY
FITS THE BILL I'VE BEEN
MENTIONED WE HAVE A LARGE AMOUNT
OF STORAGE DEPLOYMENT THAT
HAPPENED RECENTLY. THE CBSE
SPECIFICALLY ORDERED- ONE
GIGAWATT OF LONG DURATION
STORAGE AND ONE GIGAWATT OF.
ZERO CARBON FORM RESOURCE
BOOKLET JIM CARMEL TO COME
ONLINE BY TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
EVEN WHILE DEPLOYING ON THE
SCALE OF EIGHT GIGAWATT THAT
YEAR TO TWENTY FORTY FIVE. GIVEN
THE CURRENT LANDSCAPE AND STATE
OF TECHNOLOGIES ALL OF OUR GREAT
COUNTRY INDICATED THAT THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE OPTIONS. TO
MAINTAIN THE LIABILITIES TO
RETAIN OPTIONALITY ALL TOOLS
AVAILABLE INCLUDING PROMOTED
PASSED THE- ALL. OUR ECONOMY
LIKE DECARBONISATION REQUIRED
LIKE ELECTRIFICATION AND USE
THIS MEETING TO INCREASE
CAPACITY NEEDS BUT IF AN OBVIOUS
AGAINST THE OTHER TO COMMAND
COULD NEARLY DOUBLE BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
UNCERTAINTIES SO- IN NDT CAPTAIN
FUTURE DEMAND I'M JUST ON HOW
MUCH ARE WE GOING TO SEE WHEN.
AND WHERE ARE WE GOING TO SEE
THE OTHER CONDITIONS. WELL WE
BELIEVE POWER PLANTS WITH
CRITICAL GRANTING ABOUT THE
EUCLID. OF THOSE PLANS WILL
CONTINUE TO DECLINE. AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT TIME THE COMBUSTION
OF THE PART OF THE ENERGY MAKES
IT IMPORTANT TO ME TO GET THE
EMISSIONS FROM THOSE DOUBLE
CLICKED. I WANT TO TOUCH ON
EQUITY BECAUSE IT HAD BEEN THE
PRINCIPAL. FOCUS FOR ALL THE
AGENCIES. OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. WE HOLDING WORKSHOPS WITH
DJ COMMUNITIES- WE ARE HEARING
LOUD AND CLEAR THAT WE NEED TO
ACCOUNT FOR. NON ENERGY BENEFITS
IN A MODELING. AND CC IN THE-
INTEGRATED ENERGY POLICY RECORD
WILL CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
THE FEAR. I WILL CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION THE NEXT. DAY HE
WANTED REPORT. WHAT IT ON TO
VIRGINIA I JUST WANT. MENTION
THERE ARE- AGENCIES ARE WORKING
ON ENSURING THE CLEAN ENERGY
TRANSITION. AS WELL AS THINKING
THROUGH THESE VARIOUS OPTIONS
FOR- DECARBONISING THE ENERGY
SECTOR. AND THOSE INCLUDE
OBVIOUSLY THE CARD SCOPING PLAN-
AND THEN WORKING ON IT THIS YEAR
I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING THAT
INFORMATION PUBLIC. I AGREE
PROCESS AS WELL AS THE SB ONE
HUNDRED IMPLEMENTATION BUT THE
AGENCIES ARE DOING ALONG WITH
THE NEXT AT A PORT. IN
CONSULTATION AND COORDINATION OF
HIGH SO IT BALANCES MCCARTY IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT THAT'S A PATH
DOWN TO VIRGINIA FOR OPENING
COMMENTS AND WE'LL TAKE YOUR
QUESTIONS MISS LOU WELCOME TO
OF. THE SENATE. SUBCOMMITTEE TO
ON RESOURCES. YEAH GOOD MORNING
SENATOR. OF MY NAME IS RICHIE
LOU AND I WILL AN- OF THE
COMMISSION CARBON CAPTURE
ACTIVITIES. AND PROVIDE COMMENTS
ON THE STATE OF THE CURRENT
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA. AS PART
OF THE ENERGY COMMISSION
INDUSTRIAL DECARBONISATION
EFFORTS WE ARE FOCUSED ON PROFIT
THE MISSION. PROCESS HE
ACCOUNTED 485% OF THE BOTTLE GAS
USE. ACTIVITIES THE FOCUS ON
INCREASING ENERGY EFFICIENCY TO
REDUCE GASOLINE BUDGET INCREASE
COOPER OFFICIAL CREE AND WITH
PEOPLE COUNTRY. WE ARE STARTING
TO LAUNCH AREN'T THE ACTIVITY IN
THE CARBON CAPTURE UTILIZATION.
OFFICIALLY FOR HARD TO
DECARBONISE INDUSTRIES. WE HAVE
PLANNED RESEARCH THROUGH OUR
ELECTRIC PROGRAM INVESTMENT
CHARGE PROGRAM IN OUR GAS R. AND
B. PROGRAM THAT WILL FOCUS ON
ADVANCING DEMONSTRATING AND
TESTING TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN
BE. THE ENERGY AND COST OF
CARBON CAPTURE. INDUSTRIAL
PLANTS. WELL WE ARE ALSO ON
GETTING INTO DEL TECH. THAT CAN
BE THE KEY CARD DIOXIDE TO MAKE
VALUABLE COMMODITIES AND CRUDE
THE ECONOMICS OF CARBON CAPTURE
. OTHER POTENTIAL CARBON CAPTURE
ACTIVITY IN THE FUTURE. INCLUDES
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TWENTY
TWO- TWENTY THREE BUDGET AND AS
MR BROWN MENTION IT INCLUDES TWO
HUNDRED TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
INDUSTRIAL DECARBONISATION AND
ONE OF THE POTENTIAL TECHNOLOGY
AREAS COULD BE CARBON CAPTURE
UTILIZATION. AND THEN IN
ADDITION- THERE'S ALSO POTENTIAL
WITH THE FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE
AND INVESTMENT JOBS ACT. MORE
THAN EIGHTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
NEW CARPETING MANAGEMENT FUNDING
IN OUR GOAL IS TO TRY TO BRING
AS MUCH OF THAT FEDERAL MONEY TO
CALIFORNIA POSSIBLE BY USING OUR
RESEARCH GRANTS PROVIDE KOSHER
FUNDING. APPLICANTS WITH
PROJECTS THAT ARE ALIGNED WITH
OUR RESEARCH PROGRAM GOAL. AS
FAR AS CURRENCY TO BE IN. THERE
ARE OVER TWO LARGE MOBILE
PROJECT. IN OPERATIONS IN THE
WORLD. BUT THERE ARE NO LARGE
SCALE CARBON REMOVAL PROJECT IN
CALIFORNIA- THREE PROJECTS ARE
AWAITING APPROVAL OF THEIR
STORAGE WELCOME THIS WITH THE US
. MIDDLE PROTECTION AGENCY. AND
THEN THERE ARE EXAMPLES OF SMALL
SCALE PROJECTS MOSTLY FUNDED BY
DOE RICHARD CRIME WORK IN THE
PHARMACY AND THE LAWS MCDONALD'S
ENERGY CENTER IN PITTSBURGH.
CALIFORNIA'S LAW HOME SEVERAL
CARBON CAPTURE UTILIZATION START
UPS THAT HAVE RECEIVED CRIED
INDENTURE CAPITAL FUNDING WHICH
IS YOUR LOAN TWELVE CARBON BUILD
CARBON CAPTURE. THERE IS
INTEREST ALSO INFORMING CARBON
CAPTURE EDUCATIONAL AND RESEARCH
CENTERS. COLLABORATION WITH
INDUSTRIES DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND OTHERS ON CARBON
CAPTURE AND STORAGE
DEMONSTRATION. LAST WEEK KRUESI
CARBON CAPTURE SEQUESTRATION
ECONOMIC ENTERED THE CHURCH FROM
THE STATE LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD- IMPLEMENTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AND THE FEDERAL FORTY FIVE Q.
CARBON CREDITS ARE NEEDED. THAT
CONCLUDES MY- OPENING COMMENTS
HERE COULD YOU TOUCH FOR A
MINUTE ON THE BENEFITS OR THE OR
THE CHALLENGES WITH ENHANCED OIL
RECOVERY FOR WHAT FROM CARBON
CAPTURE IT SEVEN IT SAID- WELL
USE TECHNOLOGY. RIGHT YES IT IS
THE WILL USE TECHNOLOGY AND- IT
IT ALLOWS SEQUESTRATION OF THE
CARBON DIOXIDE IN THE USE OF
PUBLIC MORE OIL- OUT OF GAS WELL
. AND AND SO THAT'S A TECHNOLOGY
THAT WILL BE USED BUT YOU KNOW
IT. WE ARE TRYING TO GET TO
CARBON NEUTRALITY AND TO.
MINIMIZE OF FOSSIL FUEL USAGE IN
THE FUTURE SO YOU KNOW THAT THAT
THEY WILL USE TECHNOLOGY BUT IT
RIGHT NOW IS NOT ALIGNED WITH
OUR OUR PROGRAM GOALS AND
BEATING YOU KNOW CARDINALITY BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE AND- YOU KNOW
ALSO- YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING. TO
MINIMIZE- YOU KNOW SCRIPT
STRANDED ASSETS IN THE FUTURE AS
WELL. I THINK AS FAR AS THE
STATED TECHNOLOGY I KNOW- OUR
STAFF REPORT TALKED ABOUT YOU
KNOW NOTHING REALLY HAPPENING-
SINCE TWENTY TEN- DO YOU KNOW OF
HOW THAT TECHNOLOGY HAS IMPROVED
I KNOW THERE'S A CHALLENGE A
CONCERNED ABOUT EMISSIONS THAT
MAY OCCUR WHAT THE ENHANCED OIL
RECOVERY WORSE IS STATED THAT
TECHNOLOGY IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
FROM. THAT AT ENERGY COMMISSION
IS PERSPECTIVE. I MEAN I THINK
THAT THERE ARE- PROJECTS BETTER
BEEN FUNDED BY DEAL WE- IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE UNITED STATES THAT
FOCUS ON- ENHANCED OIL RECOVERY.
UNITS WHICH IS THE BOX THAT WILL
PROBABLY END. BUT YOU KNOW AND
YOU IN CALIFORNIA SINCE YOU KNOW
OUR GOAL IS TO- YOU KNOW.
DECARBONISE ARE THE TRILLION
INDUSTRY IT'S NOT IN AN AREA OF
FOCUS HERE RIGHT. AND I THINK
YOU KNOW IN ADDITION YOU KNOW
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT SOME OF
THESE PROJECTS WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT THE COMMUNITY IMPACT
WELL TO. AND AS THE VICE CHAIR-
MENTIONED YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
AREAS IS MAKING SURE THAT YOU
KNOW WE LISTEN TO OUR- UNITY- IN
MANY- NO MORE PROJECTS OR LOOK
IN LOW INCOME AND COMMUNITIES
AND- PENSION WAITING THEY'LL
CONTINUE TO USE. OF COLIN AND
THERE IS COULD CAUSE- YOU KNOW
IN OUR MIDDLE. IF AND HEART TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES. YES MEAN I
KNOW THAT WE HAVE TWENTY FIVE
TARGET AND YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS OUR STAFF REPORT TALKS
ABOUT IS THE PERMIT PERMITTING
THAT TAKES FIVE TO SIX YEARS SO
WE'LL GET TO THAT. BUT
CONCEIVABLY- IF YOU IF THERE WAS
ENHANCE OIL RECOVERY AND THERE
WAS AN IMMEDIATE REMOVAL OF THE
CARPET IN THOSE AEAS THAT WERE.
THAT WERE ADVERSELY AFFECTED
THEY CAN OPERATE FOR. TWENTY
YEARS AND PROVIDE ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS I MEAN IT'S CERTAINLY I
GET THE CRITICISM THAT LOOK
MIGHT PROLONG. THE ASSETS OF THE
OF THE- REFINERY ORDER I MEAN OF
EXTRACTION BUT FROM A SCIENCE
POINT OF VIEW YOU DON'T DISPUTE
THAT THERE WOULD BE LESS CARBON
THAT WILL BE MADE AT. FROM THOSE
FACILITIES RIGHT I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S NOT. WE AGREE ON THAT
RIGHT. WELL I MEAN I THINK IF
YOU REQUESTED THE CARBON- THEN
THERE WOULD BE- YOU KNOW LET
THE- TO BEING PUT OUT INTO THE-
THE ATMOSPHERE BUT I THINK HE
REALLY. NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE ENVIRONMENTAL YOU KNOW
IMPACTS ON THE LOCAL YOU KNOW
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AS WELL TO.
SURE OKAY SO LET'S THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS COME UP WITH
A PROPOSAL THAT WOULD. ELIMINATE
OR TAKE OUT THE IDEA OF A
SEQUESTERING THE CARBON IN A IN
A GEOLOGICAL STORAGE CAN YOU
HIGHLIGHT TEST THE AND THIS
WOULD INCLUDE INDUSTRIAL OR BIO
GAS OR ANY OTHER ANY OTHER
APPLICATION EVEN WHEN IT WAS. S.
C. LIVERMORE LAB REPORT POINTS
OUT CONVENIENTLY LOCATED RIGHT
NEXT TO WHERE THE FACILITY YES
CAN YOU EXPLAIN OR AT EDUCATE ME
ON THAT. WELL I THINK THE MAIN
REASON WHY WE ARE FOCUSED ON
UTILIZATION. BECAUSE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT- YOU MENTIONED- IS
THE LONG PERMITTING HI TO GET
THESE PROJECTS- SIDE. AND SO ARE
FUNDING HAS A LIMITED-
ENCUMBRANCES LIQUIDATION DATE.
AND NO WE DIDN'T WANT TO BE IN A
SITUATION WHERE YOU KNOW WE
WOULD BE STARTING A PROJECT AND
NOT BEING ABLE TO COMPLETE THAT
PROJECT WITHIN OUR- LIQUIDATION
PERIOD. AND SO- YOU KNOW IT IS
THE PROJECT OF THE PERMITTING
PROCESS TAKES FIVE TO TEN YEARS.
THERE ARE FUNDS LIQUIDATE AND
YOU KNOW FIGURE FOR WE NEVER GET
TO THAT SECOND POINT AND THAT'S
THAT'S ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS
WHY YOU KNOW WE WERE FOCUSING ON
UTILIZATION. BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE THE ENDPOINT OF THE LOCK
CULTURALLY BE ABLE CAN'T
CONSULT. WITH THE TIME FRAME
THAT ARE FUNDING YEAH YEAH IT'S
SOME IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
THAT CALIFORNIA'S PRETTY PROUD
OF THAT IT TAKES FIVE TO SIX
YEARS SAID TO- SITE ANYTHING AND
WE'VE GOT AN ALPHABET SOUP OF.
OF PEOPLE THAT OUR AGENCIES THAT
HAVE JURISDICTION I MEAN IT'S
OUR STAFF REPORT POINTS OUT THAT
THE ENERGY COMMISSION IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ACTIVITIES
RELATING TO THE STATE'S ENERGY
POLICY AND PLANNING. INCLUDING
CITING OF LARGE THERMAL POWER
PLANTS THIRTY THESE POWER PLANTS
ARE ANY THERMAL ELECTRICAL
GENERATING FACILITY WITH A
CAPACITY OF FIFTY MEGAWATTS OR
MORE. SO WHAT HAPPENS IF WE HAVE
A- A THERMAL POWER PLANT THAT'S
NOT FIFTY MEGAWATTS WHAT IS IT
WHAT IS. THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION'S. JURISDICTION THERE
. COOPER ANY PROJECT LEFT IN
FIFTY MEGAWATTS ENERGY DOESN'T
HAVE JURISDICTION. AND ERIC
GREITENS ALSO THE LINE FROM OUR
CITING CONDITIONS THAT SHOULD
TALK ABOUT THAT OR ABOUT. THE
UPSIDE IN CONDITION ACTIVITY ON
FIGHTING PLANTS MISTER KNIGHT
GOOD GOOD MORNING WHY DON'T YOU
WANT HELP US OUT. GOOD MORNING
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU- YES
EVERYTHING IS CORRECT SO- THAT
THERMAL POWER PLANT FIFTY
MEGAWATTS AND- LYFT LESSON FIFTY
MEGABYTES WOULD BE NOT WITHIN
THE ENERGY COMMISSION'S
JURISDICTION- THE- SAKE IT'S
PERMITS FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THERE DISTRICTS UNDER ITS OTHER
AGENCIES. OF THE WORLD POWER
PLANTS FIFTY MEGAWATTS AND
LARGER FOLLOW THE- ENERGY
COMMISSION EXCLUSIVE
JURISDICTION SO A PERMIT FROM
THE ENERGY COMMISSION IS IN LIEU
OF- THE AT ANY OTHER PERMIT THAT
WOULD NORMALLY BE REQUIRED BY.
LOCAL OR STATE AGENCY- IT
SOFTENS REFERRED TO AS A ONE
STOP SHOP- PERMITTING PROCESS
IT'S SET IN STATUTE THAT TWELVE
MONTHS- AND SO AT THE END OF
THE- PRECEDING. AS CERTIFICATE
IS GREAT THE HAS THE PER SYDNEY
TO- AND THE- THAT THAT PROCESS
OFTENTIMES TAKES- CONSIDERING
LONGER THAN TWELVE MONTHS- THERE
IS OFTEN TIMES- PROJECT CHANGES.
TO THE FACILITY TO- AVOID
ENVIRONMENTAL HARM ADDRESS
COMMUNITY CONCERNS AND SO THERE
IS KIND OF A KIND OF RESTARTING
THE CLOCK. AS IT NOW I'M
SOMEWHAT FOR ADDITIONAL
DISCOVERY BY THE STAFF TO
UNDERSTAND- YOU KNOW THE CHANGE
THE PROJECT IN ITS TOMORROW
CONSEQUENCES SELF- FOR- THERE.
THERE HAS BEEN- THERE'S THE
VIRGINIA OF REFERENCE THE LOS
SURPRISE- THAT'S AN EXIST- POWER
PLANT THAT WAS LICENSED BY THE
ENERGY COMMISSION I BELIEVE IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE- THAT IS
OWNED BY CALPINE CORPORATION.
THEY FILED TO POST CERT
PETITIONS- THE WITH THE ENERGY
SET TO ADD DEMONSTRATION TO
CARBON CAPTURE- AND STORAGE ONE
OF THOSE HAS BEEN APPROVED BY
THE ENERGY COMMISSION- IN MARCH
OF THIS YEAR. THE OTHER ONE IS
STILL MAKING ITS WAY THROUGH
THE- THE PROCESS- IT- THEN WE'RE
WAITING ON INFORMATION FROM
THEIR DISTRICT ON THE HEALTH
RISK ASSESSMENTS ON. YOU ALSO
THAT ENERGY COMMISSION ALSO HAS
JURISDICTION ON CITING BIOMASS
FACILITIES AND NATURAL GAS
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S CORRECT. K.
ANY POWER PLANT USES ABOUT SOME
FORM OF HEAT- THE GENERATOR
ELECTRICITY- THERMAL AND
ELECTRIC GENERATION FACILITY-
FIFTY MEG WATCHING GREATER FALLS
IN THE MAN'S QUESTIONS OF OUR
EXCEL SOLAR THERMAL GEOTHERMAL
BIOMASS. NATURAL GAS YES. SO
OF- THAT THAT WE LIKE TO REVISIT
OFTEN WHEN WE HAVE HEARINGS HERE
ON- IN STEP TWO ANDWE HAVE A
LOT OF BIOMASS THAT'S NOW USED
IN AGRICULTURE THAT'S BEING
BURNED WE NOW KNOW WE'VE TAKEN
STEPS TO LIMIT THAT. WE HAVE A
BOATLOAD OF BIOMASS THAT SITTING
IN OUR FORESTS. THAT HAS TO BE
REMOVED FROM THE FORCE IS PART
OF YOU KNOW OUR FOREST
MANAGEMENT PLAN WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING WITH THAT WE HAVE TO
WE HAVE TO. YOU KNOW EITHER MAKE
FUEL WITH IT OR SHIP IT OR MAKE
pOPTIONS BUT BUT- CITING THE
BIOMASS FACILITIES IS AN
IMPORTANT. ELEMENT FOR US
FIGHTING THIS OTHER CLIMATE
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE OF THESE
ENORMOUS FIRES THAT WE HAVE- SO
WHAT ARE THE RESTRICTIONS THAT
YOU HAVE ON CITING BIOMASS IS IT
THE SAME FIFTY. MEGAWATTS YEAH
THE COMMISSION'S EXCLUSIVE
JURISDICTION FOR ANY THURMOND
OUR PLAN STARTS AT FIFTY
MEGAWATTS OKAY NOW IS THERE
ANYTHING MAGIC ABOUT FIFTY
MEGABYTES IF WE IF WE CHANGE
THAT TO A HUNDRED MEGAWATTS WE
ARE THE LEGISLATURE OR HUNDRED
FIFTY MEGAWATTS ARE WE GOING TO
. NOT ALLOW I GUESS THAT WOULD
TAKE THE ENERGY COMMISSION OUT
YOU STILL HAVE THE LOCAL AIR
BOARD AND- THIRD THE REGIONAL-
THE FOLKS THERE WHAT BENEFIT
WOULD THAT. IN YOUR MIND WITH
THAT CREATE. IF YOU WERE TO
RAISE THE LIMIT SO THAT THAT TWO
HUNDRED I ALSO THAT WHILE
THEY'RE THERE ALREADY IS AN EXAM
THERE'S A SMALL POWER PLANT
EXTENSION- WHICH IS- ANY POWER
PLANT UP TO NOT EXCEEDING A
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS- NOT EXCEEDING
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS CAN APPLY FOR
A SMALL POWER PLANT EXEMPTION
AND THE ENERGY COMMISSION IN
THAT CASE IT WOULD GET AS
PERMITS FROM- THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SO THAT. THE ENERGY
COMMISSION WOULD DO THE SEQUOIA-
ANALYSIS CALIFORNIA POLY ACT
ANALYSIS- AND THEN IT IF IT WERE
EXEMPTED- THE FINE IS GOING TO
MANDATE WOULD BE HANDED BACK TO
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT FOR
PERMITTING. I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
MAKES IT ANY QUICKER- BECAUSE
THEN THEY HAVE TO GO GET THEIR
PERMITS FROM ANY OTHER AGENCIES
AS THEY STUCK WITH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THE ENERGY COMMISSION
CERTIFICATE WOULD HAVE BEEN IN
LIEU OF THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FROM THAT. SO MAY YOU CAN HELP
ME ON THAT THIS SITE. SET SO
LET'S SEE YOU HAVE A HIGH
MEGAWATTS. BIOMASS AND IT IS
LOCATED NEXT DOOR TO A
GEOLOGICAL. GOD CAVITY OR
STORAGE FACILITY THAT EVERYBODY
IN THE WORLD AGREES IS AYE DELEK
FOR STORING CARBON. AND UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IT SAYS
WE CAN'T DO THAT THAT THAT'S NOT
AN ELIGIBLE SO THAT MEANS THAT
THAT AND LET'S SEE THE OPERATOR
WANTS TO DO IT THEY WANT TO PUT
IN THEIR OWN MONEY THEY WANT TO.
TAKE SOME OF THE FEDERAL MONEY.
WHY IS THAT A BAD IDEA. WHAT'S
THE WHAT'S THE POLICY REASON
FROM THE FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
. THAT'S REALLY NOT A QUESTION
FOR ME TO ANSWER- I DON'T KNOW
OF ANYBODY ELSE THE COMMISSION.
FOR THE REST OF US THAT'S REALLY
OUTSIDE MY AREA OF EXPERTISE
OKAY THANK IS BECAUSE YOUR SITE
YOUR THE SITE THIS IS WHERE IT
CITED RIGHT NOW AND THIS IS WHAT
THEY WANTED TO. YEAH I WOULD
JUST I WOULD GUESS A FROM A
CITING PERSPECTIVE I MEAN FROM A
LICENSING PERSPECTIVE IT'S
INFOPRINT EVAN APPLICANT
PROPOSED SUCH A- A PROJECT WITH
CARBON CAPTURE IS A PART OF THE
PROJECT IT WOULD LIKELY BE-
WHAT'S CALLED A RELATED
DISABILITY AND FALL INTO THE
INTERVIEW QUESTIONS AUTHORITY.
TO PERMIT IT- IT'S IT SOUNDS
LIKE IT WOULD BE SOMETHING ES
DE- AN ELEMENT OF THE PROJECT IS
DEDICATED TO AN ESSENTIAL TO THE
FUNCTION OF THE POWER PLANTS
THAT WOULD FALL UNDER THE ENERGY
COMMISSION IS EXCLUSIVE
JURISDICTION THE SITE THE
ENTIRETY OF THE FACILITY
ALLENTOWN IS. SENATE ALL YOU
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU FOR SHARING-
SO. I GUESS HE WAS REGION IT WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE- CAPTURE THE
FACILITIES THEN AND WE BASICALLY
OF EXCLUDED. OIL AND GAS FOR
CAPTURE IS WHAT WHAT- I HEARD
YOU SAY AND THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S
A GOAL OF THE- INSPIRATIONS I
BELIEVE- SO I WANT TO JUST GIVE
SENSE OF. ADDICTIVE THE
FRUSTRATION FOR MOST OF. THE
MEMBERS HERE IS THAT. THERE IS
NO LONG TERM GOAL OF- BUT PUTS A
LOT WHAT'S THE PLAN WHAT'S THE
REAL PLAN HERE WE WERE FOCUSING
ON. CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE
AND IF WE CAN'T. THE CARBON IF
WE CAN'T CAPTURE THE CARBON AND
GENERATE ELECTRICITY AT THE SAME
TIME- BUT MAKING THE
ENVIRONMENT. OF BEING PROPER IN
THAT IN THAT ONE LOCATION WHAT
IS A LONG TERM GOAL I MEAN I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE- PUT ANY
GASOLINE IN YOUR CAR OR PAGE
ELECTRIC BILL LATELY BUT IT'S-
IS EXTREMELY HIGH IN CALIFORNIA.
EXTREMELY HIGH. SIX FORTY FIVE A
GALLON OF GAS THIS MORNING. AND
ARE WE PAY 60% HIGHER ELECTRIC
RATES. THAN THE AVERAGE IN THE
NATON. AND CALIFORNIANS ARE
LEADING THE LEAGUE IN THE STATE.
AND WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE LEADING
IN THE AREA OF THE ENVIRONMENT
AND- I'M NOT SURE WE'RE REALLY
DOING THAT I THINK WE'RE JUST
pI GUESS THAT REDUCES YOUR CARBON
FOOTPRINT IF THEY GO SOMEWHERE
ELSE. BUT WHAT IS THE LONG TERM
PLAN FOR NOT GOING TO FOCUS ON
CAPTURING CARBON IN A SAFE
MANNER IN THE COMMUNITIES WHERE
THESE PLANTS ARE SITED-
INTRODUCE- YOU KNOW OIL AND GAS
FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE USING
THAT IN THE IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS BEFORE WE GET TO. A SYSTEM
WHERE WE HAVE ELECT EVEY CARS
ARE- INTERGRADES MARKETS ALREADY
SHE WITH THAT WAS ARTICLE
YESTERDAY THEY CAME OUT THEY
SAID WE COULD HAVE ROLLING
BLACKOUTS THIS SUMMER. NOW IF
WE'RE GONNA HAVE ROLLING
BLACKOUTS THIS SUMMER MAY WE
OUGHT TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE CAN AVOID THAT SO
CALIFORNIANS ARE LEFT IN THE
DARK. SO COULD YOU EXPLAIN WHAT
IS THE LONG TERM PLAN. YOU'RE
JUST FOCUSING ON GASOLINE IN
YOUR FOCUS ON NOT ALLOWING US TO
CAPTURE CAPTURE CARBON. AT THE
SITE. WERE PRODUCING ELECTRICITY. THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THE
QUESTION AND- I JUST WANTED A
BIGGER- DISCUSSION ON THIS ONE
AND PASS IT TO MY COLLEAGUES TO
GET ONE I NEED ANYMORE
INFORMATION. I JUST AT A HIGH
LEVEL I THINK THE POINT YOU
JUST. MADE AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER. THANK YOU
AS YOU MENTIONED AT A LIABILITY
THAT IMPORTANT FOCUS AND I THINK
YOU JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE COMMITMENTS EACH AND THAT
AS WE LOOK THROUGH THE ENERGY
TRANSITION. AND MOVING FORWARD
OVER THE NEXT TWENTY FIVE YEARS
WE THE COOKING NICE AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF ALL OPTIONS ON THE
TABLE AND AS WE- INDICATED
EARLIER. AND WE SEE THAT LITTLE
DOG TURMEL- GENERATION IS THE
CHOIR BASED ON THE CURRENT
MODELING TODAY AND THE STATE OF
TECHNOLOGY FROM THE COST. AS
LONG AS WE ARE GOING TO USE THAT
THERMAL ENERGY FOR OUR PERSONAL.
GENERATIONS WE WOULD BENEFIT
FROM YES. I THINK THAT THE
EXACT- THAT KIND OF POINT OF
SOME OF YOUR QUESTIONS WHICH WE
ARE STILL THINKING THROUGH IS TO
THE EXTENT THAT CCS IS AN
IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF THE ENERGY
TRANSITION. WHERE AND HOW WE
CITED AND IT'S- IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE TACKLING- IN OUR
HYPER THIS YAR WITH BEGINNING
TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS BUT
I THINK AND THE PRINCIPLE
LEVELS- WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT
OPTIONS THAT IMPORTANT. AS. WE
MOVE FORWARD IN THE ENERGY
TRANSITION. SO- A UP QUESTION
THAT WOULD BE- YOU KNOW IT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. CARBON IN THAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE DON'T
TALK ABOUT THE EMISSIONS OF
FORCE BY WHICH I KNOW YOU'RE NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO CAPTURE- WHEN
IT'S ON FIRE BUT WE CAN CAPTURE
IT- JUST AS THE CHAIRMAN- TALKED
ABOUT IN BIOMASS BEFORE- IT GOES
UP IN IN FLAMES AND IT'S
ACTUALLY WHILE PART IN IN LAST
YEAR. THE DIXIE FIRE WHICH WAS
ALL IN MY DISTRICT. AND ALSO THE
CALDOR BAR WHICH WAS ALL IN MY
DISTRICT- DESTROYED ALMOST A
MILLION ACRES ONE FIRE. AND IF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE OUTPUT
OF CARBON FOR CALIFORNIANS
WHICH- WE NEED TO COUNT WE DON'T
COUNT THAT AS OUR AS OUR
EMISSIONS EVEN THOUGH WE COULD.
CAPTURE THAT CARBON CREATE GREEN
ENERGY AND PUT IT IN A BIOMASS
PLANT INSIDE AND THROUGHOUT THIS
YEAR IS TO HELP ALLEVIATE THE
AND THE TRINITY'S WE'RE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SECOND
DISTRICT IS THAT- TO ALLEVIATE
THOSE EMISSIONS PRIOR TO A
CATASTROPHIC FIRE SO WHAT'S THE
WHAT'S THE PLAN FOR THAT. YEAH-
SO TO THE EXTENT THE SB ONE
HUNDRED MODELING AND I JUST WANT
TO TAKE IT. AGAIN JUST AT A HIGH
LEVEL FIRST AND THEN TRY TO SEE
IF WE COULD. ADD ANY MORE
DETAILS. SO WHEN WE STARTED
DOING THAT AT THE ONE HUNDRED
AND OUT OF SAYS. SB ONE ANALYSIS
I DO THINK ABOUT THE- ENERGY
TRANSITION. EVERYTHING THAT IS
ELIGIBLE IN THE R. P. S. IS
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FOR THE FUTURE.
ALONG WITH. ON SITE RESOURCES
ARE DUE TO CARMEN SO BETWEEN
THAT CONTEXT- WE DID MODEL AND
IN THE BYE BY MASS. AND BY
BUDGET. IN THE CONTEXT OF OUR PS
AND IT'S STILL. A PART OF OUR
MODELING. AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND
I THINK THAT THAT SHOULD THE
CHAIR I MENTION THIS THIS COMMON
I THINK THERE ARE A BAD IDEA A
PRICE HAVE PULLING TOGETHER. IN
TERMS OF BOTH THE CLIMATE
CHALLENGES. BUT A LIABILITY THE
AFFORDABILITY- AND DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF THE OVERALL ECONOMY
DECARBONISATION CLIMATE GOALS
AND I THINK AS WE LOOK THROUGH
THAT WE WILL BE LOOKING AT ABOUT
IDEA SCENARIOS. AND ARRIVING AT
SOLUTIONS THAT- THAT KIND OF
CONNECT THE DOTS ON WE JUST
ABOUT IT BEING MENTIONED TODAY
AND EXPECT. TO ADDRESS MOST OF
THE THINGS THAT YOU MENTIONED
TODAY. TRY LAST. DOES THAT THE
COMMISSION OR THE
ADMINISTRATION. LOOK INTO THE
FOR THAT. WE IMPORT ENERGY FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES. SUCH AS ECUADOR
WHERE WE'RE BRINGING IN 24% OF
OUR CRUDE OIL RIGHT NOW FROM
ECUADOR WHICH HAS NO REGULATIONS
AND IS DESTROYING THE AMAZON
RAINFOREST AT THE SAME TIME
PUTTING. OIL IN A SHIP AND IN.
BRINGING HERE WHICH IS IT
ADMISSION. WORKING IN OUR PORTS
WHICH IS A MISSION FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO LIVE IN IN SAN
DIEGO AREA FOR SURE WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S- WHAT IS THE PLAN TO
LIKE. REALLY TAKE A GOOD LOOK AT
AT THE OVERALL CARBON OUTPUT.
WHEN WE IMPORT VERSUS WHETHER
PRODUCING THOSE- THAT ENERGY FOR
CALIFORNIANS RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SENATOR
NIGHT AND WHEN IT CAME TO GET MY
IS THE IMPORTANCE OF YOUR
QUESTION. THANK YOU YOU MADE AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT POINT THAT
THIS HAS TO BE A COMPREHENSIVE-
DECARBONISING LOOK AT AN ECONOMY
LEVEL AND IN A CARD HAS BEEN
WORKING ON THAT LATE FEES AND
SCOPING PLAN. AND HAD BEEN
WORKING IN COORDINATION WITH A
BUNCH OF STATE AGENCIES THAT
WILL BETTER EXPANDABLE IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SIDE AS WELL AS
THE ENERGY SIDE AND WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO. ABOUT I WILL
A BLUEPRINT. COMING TOGETHER
THROUGH THIS BEING PLANNED. AND
THEN WE LOOK FOR TO. HAVING
THOSE. AT SOON AND THEN HAVING
FOR THE DISCUSS. WHAT WHEN WILL
THAT BE AVAILABLE. I'VE BEEN
WAITING TEN YEARS I'VE BEEN
WAITING TEN YEARS FOR A PLANT.
TEN YEARS WHERE MY OR LONGER.
WHEN WITHOUT AND WHEN WILL THERE
BE A PLAN AVAILABLE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO LOOK AT THE OF
THE LONG TERM EFFECTS AND THE
SHORT TERM EFFECTS OF IMPORTING
VERSES CREATING- OUR ENERGY HERE
AT HOME. IN CALIFORNIA. AT THE
FIRST ON THAT- HIGH LEVEL AND
ISSUE OF THE CARDS REPORT I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE COMING
OUT WITHIN THIS MONTH AS PART OF
THE UNDERSTAND. I'M AS FAR AS
THEIR SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THAT
YOU SPOKE ABOUT IN TERMS OF THE
GLOBAL IMPORTANCE SUCH. YOU KNOW
WE WILL CIRCLE BACK. WITH THE
CARD THAT'S THE ONE THEY HAVE
AND WE WILL AND IT COME BACK TO
YOU WITH MORE THAN SIX SO I HAVE
ONE SO WHY IS THE ADMINISTRATION
NOT PERMITTING WELLS IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW THERE'S A
THOUSAND WELLS AT CAL JIM. AND
THEY'RE NOT GETTING PERMITTED
AND WE'RE IMPORTING OIL FROM. WE
WORK FROM RUSSIA. WE WERE WE ARE
FROM ECUADOR WHY WOULD WE NOT
MAKE CALIFORNIA IN IT WHERE WE
DO IT CLEANER MORE EFFICIENT AND
WE PUT CALIFORNIA PEOPLE TO WORK
ON OF COMMODITY THAT WE KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO USE WE USE ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION BARRELS OF
OIL A DAY. I LOOK I'M FORGETTING
IS TO ELECT DOCTORATE EV'S BUT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET THEIR
PERCENT ANYTIME SOON BECAUSE OUR
GRIT IS NOT EVEN AND SHAPE. TO
PUT OUT THE ELECTRICITY THAT WE
NEED SO. SO WHAT WHERE IS IT
WHERE IS THAT. KNOWLEDGE IS.
WHAT ARE WE NOT WHY ARE WE NOT
PRODUCING OIL IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S MY QUESTION AND WHY ARE
WE DESTROYING THE RAINFOREST.
ANTS IN DOING A VICTORY LAP IN
CALIFORNIA SAYING WE'RE HELPING
THE ENVIRONMENT WE'RE NOT. I
THANK YOU FOR UNDERSTOOD.
SOMETHING THAT AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. DOESN'T DIRECTLY
WORK IN- YOU KNOW WE'RE HAPPY TO
COORDINATING IT SPONSORS TO YOU
ABOUT THIS IS NOT SOMETHING.
THAT FIFTY. PEOPLE TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON. WHAT WE COULD
CAPTURE THIS IS ABOUT CARBON
CAPTURE WE COULD BE CAPTURING
OIL. ARE WE COULD BE CATCHING
CARBON AT OIL WELLS AND
PRODUCING WELL CALIFORNIA CLEAN
IN A CLEANER MORE EFFICIENT
MANNER THAT'S THE QUESTION. WHY
WHY. I BELIEVE IT THERE IS A
RHETORICAL QUESTION- I'VE A
COUPLE OF FOLLOW UPS BECAUSE WE
DID HEAR TESTIMONY THAT THERE
ARE CURRENTLY NO OPERATIONAL-
CCS PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA
HOWEVER THERE'S A NUMBER OF
PROJECTS IN DEVELOPMENT AND THAT
FOR- THEY ENERGY COMMISSION HOW
MANY FACILITIES HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THIS THE ENERGY
COMMISSION'S SEQUENCE CERTIFIED
PERMITTING PROCESS. AND HAVE YOU
NOTICED A CHANGE IN THE NUMBER
OF APPLICANTS- THERE ARE
PRESENTLY THERE'S SEVENTY SIX-
POWER PLANTS THAT ARE OPERATE IN
AND CALIFORNIA DATE EVER LICENSE
BY THE ENERGY COMMISSION. ONE
ONE FACILITY LOOKS MADONNA'S
ENERGY CENTER- WHICH IS OWNED BY
COMPANY CORPORATION HAS FILED-
POST CERT PETITIONS ON OUR
REGULATIONS TO- DEMONSTRATE
CARBON CAPTURE. AND STORAGE AND
TWO DIFFERENT TYPES OF. PROJECTS
ONE WAS APPROVED BY THE ENERGY
COMMISSION IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR
THAT SOUND. TO SEND- PROBABLY 1%
OF THE FLUE GAS FROM THE LOOKS
WITH US AND ENERGY CENTER ACROSS
THE STREET- ACROSS THIRD STREET
IN PITTSBURGH CALIFORNIA TO SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AGGREGATES- WILL
PLANET- FOR PRODUCING- ROCK YES
IN IRAQ PRODUCTS RIGHT AND THEN-
SUPPOSED SECOND PROJECT THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH AYE AND CLEAN
ENERGY OF BLAMES THE NAME- IT
WOULD BE ON SITE THERE ARE
MULTIPLE DONNA'S ENERGY CENTER
IT'S- PRESENTLY MAKING ITS WAY
THROUGH THE COMMISSION'S-
PROCESS AND RECORDING WITH LOOK
WHAT THE BAY AREA A KID ON THE-
ON THE PERMITTING FOR THE- FOR
THE ACTIVITIES. SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS THIS WHAT POINT
SOURCES IN THE ENERGY SECTOR OF
THE GREATEST GREENHOUSE GAS
EMITTERS AND IS IT CURRENTLY
COST EFFECTIVE- FOR THESE
FACILITIES TO ADAPT AT CCS.
RIGHT IS IT. YEP THE BIGGEST
CENTIMETERS. THAT WE HAVE OUR-
GENERALLY IN THE OF THE OIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY. REFINING FOSSIL
FUEL ELECTRIC GENERATION
BUSINESS MANUFACTURING- NATURAL
GAS DISTRIBUTION AND OPTIONAL
COMBINING. AND THE COST OF
CARBON CAPTURE TECHNOLOGIES-
RANGE BETWEEN TWENTY AND THIRTY
DOLLARS A METRIC TON DEPENDING
ON THE TYPE OF FACILITY YOU KNOW
SOME FACILITIES HAVE RELATIVELY-
NOT CONTAMINATED FIELDS WHO LIKE
A SMALL PRODUCTION SO THOSE
WOULD BE EASIER TO CAPTURE THE
FEEL TO THAN OTHERS THAT HAVE
OTHER CONTAMINANTS. AND SO MANY
OF THE CCS- ARE PLANNED IN
CALIFORNIA AND THERE ARE A LOT
OF THEM ARE DOING- STUDIES AT
THIS POINT TO ANALYZE. YOU KNOW
THE TECHNOLOGY REQUIREMENTS GO
GET JONES STUDIES AND FINANCIAL
DECISIONS SOME OF THEM HAVE HAD
AN INITIAL STUDY AND THEN
THEY'RE DOING ADDITIONAL
FLOODING. YOUR BID FOR THE MAKE
THEIR- DECISION. AND SO I'M LIKE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY WHERE THERE'S
A FREEZING STREAM.
THE FEDERAL CHIU FORTY FIVE
INCENTIVE PAYMENT. RIGHT I GUESS
I GUESS I THINK RIGHT NOW I'M
YEAH NO GO AHEAD I JUST I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND TO MAXIMIZE
CARBON CAPTURE IN THE COUNTRY IS
IT NECESSARY THAT. WE FACILITATE
THE ADOPTION AT THESE LARGE
POLLUTERS OR ARE THE SMALL
POINT- SOURCES OF VIABLE AND
COST EFFECTIVE TARGET FOR
CAPTURE. WELL I THINK IT'S CAN
ON THE LOCATION OF THE- AND THE
DISTANCE TO THE WORKSITE- AND
THE- OVERALL POTENTIAL IMPACT
THAT IT COULD HAPPEN ENVIRONMENT
BOTH. SHE I THINK LOCAL
COMMUNITY YOU KNOW NEED TO.
GREAT DAY ARE ALSO VERY CHEAP IN
TO TURN THAT THE OF THE- THESE
SYSTEM. OKAY ONE LAST QUESTION
AND THIS IS I MAY ASK THE ALEJO
THE STANFORD ENERGY FUTURES
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY IN
THAILAND ACTION PLAN FOR CARBON
CAPTURE AND STORAGE IN
CALIFORNIA OPPORTUNITIES
CHALLENGES THE SOLUTIONS REPORT
STATES THAT CCS IS CURRENTLY NOT
INELIGIBLE PATHWAY UNDER THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM WERE
RECOGNIZED IN THE MANDATORY
GREEN GAS REPORTING REGULATIONS
AS A RESULT COVERED ENTITIES
CANNOT UCCS TO REDUCE THE
COMPLIANCE OBLIGATIONS THAT'S
THE YEAR THEIR ANNUAL EMISSIONS
CAP. EVEN IF THEY CAPTURE AND
STORE THEIR EMISSIONS IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE CCS PROTOCOL
SO IS THAT MISTER BROWN IS THAT
YOUR UNDERSTANDING- OF A OF THAT
AND HAVE YOU. IS THAT YOUR OF
THAT BIG CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
IN CCS. YES THAT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING AND I GUESS- SOME
HAS FOR THE ENERGY COMMISSION
HAVE YOU'VE NOTED THISBEING A
BARRIER TO THE ADOPTION THE CCS
AT THERMAL POP UP POWER PLANTS I
MEAN IF THEY'RE NOT COVERED
UNDER. A I COULD GET A REDUCTION
IS THAT A BARRIER ON THE FOR
THEM. BUT WHAT YOU KNOW WE ARE
BE ABLE TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION
CAN YOU COME BACK. YEAH WELL
ALIGHT I THINK- MAYBE ERIC ALSO
HELP ON THIS I THINK IS ERICA.
THAT YOU KNOW THE CDC HAS
JURISDICTION ON OUR POWER PLANTS
OVER FIFTY MEGAWATT. AND IF THAT
PROJECT CAME IN AND HAD A CCS
COMPONENTS WITH THAT. THAT IT
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT THE
ENERGY COMMISSION- TAKE A LOOK
AT AS WELL- BUT AT THIS POINT I
DON'T BELIEVE THERE HAD BEEN
ANY- PEARL HARBOR SENT OVER
FIFTY MEGAWATTS THAT HAVE COME
IN BUT- PCS. IN A DIFFERENT
LANGUAGE. I MEAN YOU COULD YOU
COULD SEE THE THREE MEN THERE
GOING TO GET ANY CREDIT FOR THAT
AND TRADE. AND THEY STILL TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE Q. PROGRAM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS WITH
FEDERAL MONEY THAT'S OUT THERE
OR PERHAPS- ADVANCES THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HOUSE. AND
IT JUST SEEMS THAT FOR THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD BE A GOOD DEAL
. I HOPE THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
LESS CARBON IN THE ATMOSPHERE AT
THESE POWER PLANTS THESE IN
THESE MATTERS. SO I'D LIKE FOR
YOU GUYS TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT-
THIS IS AN INFORMATION HEARING
SO I APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S UP
EVERYBODY'S- PARTICIPATION. WE
HAVE ONE FINAL QUESTION FROM
CENTER DOLLY WHY DOES IT TAKE
TEN YEARS TO PERMIT WHAT WHAT'S
THE WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE
BOTTLENECK OR WHAT WHAT THAT
SEEMS LIKE AN AWFUL LONG TIME
TO. DO THE RIGHT THING. I THINK
THAT- THERE'S ALSO DISCOUNTS
DEPARTMENT QUALITY ACT AS WELL
AS LOCAL PERMITTING. AND-
ANNABEL YOU OFFICES MY
IMPRESSION IS THAT- YOU KNOW
GOING THROUGH THE PERMITTING
THERE'S MULTIPLE WHICH ALSO
GETTING THE WELL PERMITS FROM
THE EPA ON JAN YOU KNOW THERE'S
NO AGENTS THAT YOU HAVE TO GO
THROUGH AND SHOW GOING THROUGH
THAT WHOLE PROCESS- TAKES TIME
NO I THINK ERIC TALKED ABOUT THE
CITING PROCESS AND YOU KNOW KIND
OF LIKE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
YOU KNOW THE PROJECTS THAT ARE
LESS THAN FIFTY MEGAWATTS VERSUS
THOSE THAT ARE OLDER FIFTY
MEGAWATTS AND- YOU KNOW WHEN AND
IF HE HAS TO GO THROUGH MULTIPLE
AGENCIES TO GET APPROVAL. EACH
ONE OF THOSE COULD PAINT- HELLO
. AT WOULD SEEM TO ME THE IF.
THIS IS ACTUALLY DOING THE RIGHT
THING FOR THE ENVIRONMENT BY
CAPTURING CARBON. AND
SEQUESTERING IT THERE WOULD BE.
VERY LITTLE IMPACT. BECAUSE IT'S
ACTUALLY MOVING IN THE DIRECTION
OF DECARBONISATION. GOALS SO IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE THAT WOULD
TAKE TEN YEARS. IF IT IF THERE
IS NO NEGATIVE IMPACT IS
ACTUALLY A POSITIVE TO GETTING
TO OUR- CLIMATE GOALS. M. ANIMAL
I BELIEVE IT THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ENERGY COMMISSION AND ALEJO
FOR HELPING US ON- ISSUE NUMBER
ONE FAN THIS IS NO ACTION NEEDS
TO BE- TAKEN THIS INFORMATION.
ITEM LET'S MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO WHICH IS THE SENATE OF THE
CITY CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE BUDGET
PLAN EIGHT TEAM POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN DROUGHT AND
WATER SUPPLY RELIABILITY
WILDFIRE RESILIENCY LEVEL RISE
AND EXTREME HEAT MISTER BROWN
WELCOME BACK. I THINK IT WILL
ACTUALLY BE ON THE RETAILER'S
FROM. SO NICE TO HEAR YOUR VOICE
AND I UNDERSTAND THIS KIRSTEN'S
ON ALSO. THAT'S RIGHT WE GOT THE
WHOLE TEAM HERE READY FOR YOU-
HOPEFULLY TO HELP YOU ANSWER
SOME QUESTIONS SO STAFF HAS
ASKED US TO HELP PRESENT- THE
SENATE DEMOCRATS AS CLIMATE
BUDGET PLAN- JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION PURPOSES THIS WE
ARE HAPPY TO PRESENT IS YOUR
STAFF BUT THIS IS NOT IN LA-
DEVELOPED. RECOMMENDED OR
ENDORSED UP PLAN I'M JUST HERE
TO HELP YOU- SO AS AS NOTE. THAT
PLAN INCLUDES EIGHTEEN POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS FIVE. AND
HAS FIVE COMPONENTS WHICH I'LL
WALK THROUGH BRIEFLY THEY'RE
DESCRIBING YOUR AGENDA SO THE
FIRST IS OUT FOR WATER IN
DROUGHT ACTIVITIES THAT INCLUDE
SEVEN POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
IN STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDS OVER
THREE YEARS. ON THE MAJOR
COMPONENTS OF THAT PIECE OUR TWO
BILLION DOLLARS TO RE BALANCE
STATE WATER SUPPLY AND WATER
RIGHTS. ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS TO ENSURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE SAFE DRINKING
WATER. ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS TO IMPROVE WATERSHED
CLIMATE RESILIENCE REGIONALLY.
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR A DROUGHT RESILIENT WATER
SUPPLY GRANTS. AND ONE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR FLOOD MANAGEMENT AND
DAM SAFETY. THERE IS ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION IN DETAIL ON THE
SPECIFIC COMPONENTS IN YOUR
AGENDA. NEXT COMPONENT IS FOR
WILDFIRE. SO THE SENATE PACKAGE
SENATE DEMOCRATS PACKAGE ME SIX
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS OVER
FIVE YEARS OR ONE POINT. THREE
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY I TO
BUILD ON GOVERNOR'S WILD
PROPOSALS COMPONENTS OF THAT
INCLUDES ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR FUEL REDUCTION
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
BIOMASS ACCUMULATION THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND TRAINING SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR STATE CONSERVANCY'S
AND TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS I'M GOING TO
EXPAND STAFFING RATIOS CHU THREE
FOR CALIFORNIA FIRE ENGINES. THE
THIRD COMPONENT OF THE PACKAGES
RELATED TO SEA LEVEL RISE THE
PACKAGE INCLUDES THREE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS SPREAD
OVER MULTIPLE YEARS TO IMPROVE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE TO SEA
LEVEL RISE. THAT INCLUDES ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
TO FUND SB ONE OR- AND MADAM TO
MATCH AVAILABLE FEDERAL FUNDS.
THE FOURTH COMPONENT OF THE
PACKAGE IS SPECIFIC FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS ON DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. ARE THAT INCLUDES A
TOTAL OF ONE BILLION DOLLARS
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR
FIVE YEARS- SPECIFICALLY TO
ADDRESS THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AND THEN THE FIFTH
COMPONENT OF THE PACKAGE IS
RELATED TO BIODIVERSITY AND
OUTDOOR ACCESS FOR ALL THAT
WOULD BE ONE BILLION DOLLARS
OVER MULTIPLE YEARS FOR NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS THOSE COMPONENTS
INCLUDE. FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO ACHIEVE THE THIRTY BY
GOAL OR CONSERVING PERCENT OF
STATE LAW AND CO WATERS BY
THIRTY. TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR FOR URBAN GREEN AND URBAN
FORESTRY. TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR OUTDOOR ACCESS. AND
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE EQUITY ACTS GRANT. IN
ADDITION THE PACKAGE BEFORE YOU
INCLUDES- OUR LANGUAGE AND
AROUND THE CLIMATE EQUITY TRUST
FUND THE PACKAGE WOULD ESTO A
EQUITY TRUST FUND FOR THE BAY.
OF THE CONSUMED CUSTOMERS AND TO
AFFORDABLE ELECTRICITY. THE
PACKAGE ALSO IS INTENDED TO
ACHIEVE SB ONE HUNDRED AND FROM
GOALS ARE SPECIFICALLY 90% OF
ELECTRICITY SALES TO END USE
CUSTOMERS FROM RENEWABLE ENERGY
AND ZERO CARBON RESOURCES BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. AND 95% BY
TWENTY FORTY. AND THE PACKAGE
ALSO INCLUDES HIGH ROAD LABOR
AGREEMENTS FOR CLEAN ENERGY
PROJECTS- SO WITH THAT GIVEN THE
SAYS NOT A PACKAGE WERE INVOLVED
IN THAT YOU KNOW IT'S NOT ONLY A
PACKAGE WE CAN'T OFFER ANY.
SPECIFIC RESPONSES TO SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE THOSE
PROBABLY ARE BEST ADDRESSED
THROUGH THE CHAIR ON BUT IF YOU
HAVE ANY HIGH LEVEL QUESTIONS
ARE BACKGROUND QUESTION I AM
HERE AS OUR MY COLLEAGUES- MR
BROWN AND MISS CHRISTINE CANCER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
EXCELLENT WHAT'S- TURN TO-
MEMBERS MAY HAVE QUESTIONS
SENATOR. CHOIR YOU RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
HONEST MAKES A VERY QUICK
COMMENTS WILL BE TWO MINUTES OR
LESS. NUMBER ONE I JUST WANNA
TAKE A MOMENT SAY THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR. THE CHAIR HAS. MANY
OF OURS AND IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT. THE WORKING ON
THE PACKAGE. AND IT FOCUSES ON
SOME OF THE BIGGEST ON THE- THAT
WE HAPPENED CITY CALIFORNIA.
FOCUS ON THE WORST DROUGHT AT
STATE IS SEEN IN TWELFTH CENTURY
. EIGHT FOUR. ON MAKE. THE STATE
MORE FIRE SAFE. THROUGH HISTORIC
EVENT INVESTMENT. IN WILDFIRE-
PREPARATION. PREVENTION IS WELLS
FINALLY FIXING THE COW FIRE CHAU
. WHICH BY THE WAY THERE ARE
TWENTY THREE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE A THE SENATE.
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS ALIKE
THAT ARE FOCUSED ON THIS
INVESTMENT IT ALSO MAKES HIS
INVESTMENTS IN COMBATING CLIMATE
CHANGE THIS WOULD REPRESENT THE
LARGEST INVESTMENT OF ANY STATE
IN AMERICAN HISTORY ON THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. AND THE LAST
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE IS TO TONI ATKINS THE
LEADER OF THE SENATE BUT SHE HAS
MADE CLIMATE THAT ONE OF THE
SENATE'S TOP PRIORITIES SHE'S
FALL THROUGH A STEP OF THE WAY
AND THIS IS A GROUND. BUDGET
INVESTMENT THAT WILL HELP SOME
OF THE MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
STATE IN THE TACKLE SOME OF THE
LARGEST CHALLENGES THAT WERE
SEEN IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH SECURE FREE
WORK ON THIS. THANK YOU FOR
THOSE KIND WORDS SENATE ALI YOU
RECOGNIZE. WELL I SINCE THIS-
WAS LAID OUT AS THE DEMOCRATS.
THE PROPOSAL AND I AM THE ONLY
REPUBLICANS SITTING ON THIS
COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
SOMEBODY EXPLAIN TO ME HOW THIS
ONE AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS
THAT IS GOING TO. BY WATER
RIGHTS AND RETIRED LANDING
CALIFORNIA- WHAT WHAT'S IT LOOK
LIKE AN THIS IS THE IS SOME THAT
RIGHTS IN CALIFORNIA. HAVE BEEN
ARE YOU OVER- WATER RIGHTS FOR A
LONG TIME AND- AND I'VE I'VE
ACTUALLY CAME FROM COMMUNITIES
WHERE WE'VE LOST OUR WATER- LAST
YEAR WE WORKED ON- THE TO THE
LAKE BASIN WHERE. THEY THEY HAD
A ZERO ALLOCATION OF WATER BUT
NOT ONLY DOES IT IMPACT THE
FARMER IN. THE FOOD SUPPLY FOR
CALIFORNIA IN THE NATION- BUT
ALSOIMPACTS COMMUNITIES IN A
WAY THAT YOU. NEVER RECOUP FROM
. IF YOU LOSE THE- AGRICULTURE
COMMUNITY- YOU YOU LOSE. ALL THE
SUPPLIERS OF THOSE FOLKS IN THE
WORK FORCE FOR THOSE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES MOST
OF MOST OF WHICH ARE JUST ADMIT
PAGE MUSED THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
SO I'D LIKE TO HAVE. SOMEONE
EXPLAIN WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE.
WITH THE L. A. O. I'M JUST A
MECHANICAL- A LEVEL ONE AT
TARGET RESP OR I CAN RESPOND
OBVIOUSLY ALSO. I CAN JUST NOTE
SENATOR THAT THE STATE HAS HAD
SOME EXAMPLES OF PROGRAMS WHERE-
THAT KIND OF PERCH WATER RIGHTS
IT'S BEEN PRETTY LIMITED- THERE
WAS SOME FUNDING IN LAST YEAR'S
BUT- AT TWO KIND OF BUILD ON A
PROGRAM THAT THAT WHILE I'M-
WELL IF. BOARD RUNS ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL FLOWS PURCHASING
WATER SO AS IS OUTLINED IN YOUR
AGENDA- IT STATES THAT THIS
WOULD BE A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM TO
PURCHASE WATER ALONG PRIORITIZE
STREAM SEGMENTS AND OUTLINED
SOME- PORTIONS OF THE STATE
WHERE FUNDING WOULD BE DEDICATED
FOR THIS- AS IT WOULD BE A ABOUT
A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM. RIGHT AND I
THINK THE- THIRTY WE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
RECONCILIATION TO OCCUR WITH THE
AMOUNT OF RIGHTS THAT ARE HELD
BY PEOPLE IN THE AMOUNT OF WATER
THAT'S AVAILABLE AND THE THEORY
IS THAT SOME PEOPLE WOULD WANT
TO SELL THOSE RIGHTS NOT
EVERYBODY BUT THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE THAT ARE DONE DONE DONE
THEY DALY THERE OKAY FOR A PRICE
AND WE DON'T KNOW I DON'T I'M
NOT SPECULATING WITH THE PRICES
BUT THERE. THEY'RE WILLING TO
GIVE UP THEIR WATER RIGHTS WHICH
YOU CREATE AND THE STATE WITH
THE STATE WOULD PURCHASE THEM
AND BASICALLY BACK LIKE A BANK
WOULD HOLD ON TO THESE RIGHTS
THE STATE WOULD WOULD WOULD HOLD
THAT AS A AS A KID AS A
COMMODITY RIGHT AND WHAT PLEASE
WOULD LOOK FOR AT FIRST HIS
THOSE HIGH STRESS AREAS WHERE
PEOPLE ARE ALREADY HAVING
PROBLEMS GETTING ALLOCATIONS
RIGHT- AT THAT WE WOULD LOOK AT
THOSE AREAS TO SEE IF THERE WERE
ANY SELLERS. WOULD HAVE THAT AND
WE WOULD PURCHASE THE RIGHTS OR
REPORTS AN EASEMENT OUT LEGALLY
HOW WHAT WHAT WAS AVAIL AND
ALLOW THAT WATER TO EITHER BE
FLOODED ON THE ON THE PROPERTY
AND- ARE FOR GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT OR- YEAH IT JUST FROM
THERE'S IT'S THERE'S AN OVER OF
DEMAND OF WATER ANYWAY- BUT THE
PRIORITY WOULD BE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL NEEDS AND SORT OF
MAXIMIZING. THAT THE BENEFITS.
WELL IF I MAY HELP- THE OUTLOOK
ON IDEA AND THE IDEA IS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A RELIABLE
QUANTIFICATION OF WHAT THE WATER
RIGHTS ARE WE KNOW THAT THE
RIGHT TO HEAR I OF SENIOR WATER
RIGHTS HAVE GREAT BUT OUR RIGHTS
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
AT LEAST TO GET THE STATE WATER
RESOURCE BOARD TO DO SOME
QUANTIFICATION OF. OF THOSE-
RIGHTS- IN YOU KNOW HELP HELP
WITH THE YOU KNOW- THE OTHER
PEOPLE THAT WHEN THEY CONTINUE
TO EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS AND GET
THEIR WATER WELL I WANT TO JUST
GO ON RECORD BECAUSE THIS IS
GOING TO BECOME A GREAT DEBATE.
THIS YEAR. I WANNA GO ON RECORD
TO STATE THE FACT I AM THE ONLY
FARMER I BELIEVE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE. AND WHEN IT COMES
TO WATER RIGHTS YOU'RE NO A
WILLING SELLER UNTIL YOU CAN'T
FARM ANYMORE. AND WHY YOU CAN'T
FARMS BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST. INERGY COST WE HAVE WE
HAVE MORE REGULATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA THAN WE DO ANYWHERE
IN THE WORLD SO. I OWN ALL MY
LAND I OWN ALL MY EQUIPMENT. AND
MY FAMILY'S BEEN FARMING
CALIFORNIA FOR NINETY TWO YEARS.
AND I AM HAVING A HARD TIME MY
MARGINS ARE REALLY THIN IT'S NOT
BECAUSE- I'M I DON'T KNOW WHAT
I'M DOING IS BECAUSE I'M
COMPETING IT'S THE GUY IN OREGON
THE GUY NEVADA AND THE GUY IN
CHINA. OR UKRAINE TO PRODUCE A
PRODUCT OF CALIFORNIANS NEED TO
I'M NOT A WILLING SELLER OF MY
WATER RIGHTS OR MY LAND OR
CONSERVATION EASEMENT UNTIL I'M
FORCED TO WHERE THERE'S NO WAY I
CAN MAKE A LIVING ON MY PROPERTY
AND I WILL TELL YOU. THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF FARMERS. IN
CALIFORNIA THERE IN THAT
POSITION BECAUSE THIS
LEGISLATURE PUT IN THAT POSITION
THERE'S NOT ONE DIME. IN THIS
PROPOSAL FOR STORAGE. WHERE IS
IT. WHERE IS THAT WHERE'S THE
WHERE'S THE MONEY TO BUILD SITES
RESERVOIR WILL ACTUALLY HELP THE
ENVIRONMENT HELP FARMERS AND
HELP PEOPLE THAT WOULDN'T SAFE
DRINKING WATER IN THE CITIES
IT'S NOT IN HERE. THIS IS THE
BUDGET THIS IS THE SENATE'S PLAN
I'M SORRY MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS
RIGHT THIS MAKES MY BLOOD BOIL
IT'S RIDICULOUS. AND WE TALK
ABOUT YEAH YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A
LOT OF WILLING SELLERS WHEN
THERE'S NO OTHER OPTION BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T MAKE A LIVING
ANYMORE. THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
DOING YOU'RE FORCING THEM INTO A
CORNER WHERE THEY HAVE NO OTHER
OPTION BECAUSE THEY CAN'T MAKE A
LIVING ON THE PROPERTY AND SO WE
AND I WANT TO JUST SAY THIS I'VE
WORKED WITH THE FOLKS IN
SISKIYOU COUNTY. TO DO SAFE
HARBOR AGREEMENTS. WITH WATER
RIGHT HOLDERS. WE ARE TRYING TO
GET A SAFE ARE WE CAN WE CAN.
WITH THEIR THEY'RE DIVERTING.
30% OF THEIR WATER. FOR FISH
ACTUALLY GIVING IT UP AT NO COST
. TO ALLOW A SAFE HARBOR
AGREEMENT WHICH CHUCK BONHAM
HASN'T SIGNED YET AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCE WE WILL
WORK ON TEN YEARS AND THEY'VE
SPENT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
THEIR OWN MONEY. NOW THEY'RE
PROBABLY GONNA BE WILLING
SELLERS WHEN THEY CAN'T MAKE A
LIVING ANYMORE. YOU'RE GONNA
FORCE THEM TO BE WILLING SELLERS
SELLERS THAT'S WHAT'S WRONG WITH
THIS POLICIES COME OUT OF THIS
PLACE. IF YOU THINK THAT YOUR
I'M SORRY. IF YOU THINK THAT
COMMUNITIES AND FARMERS ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO FEED
CALIFORNIA IN THE WORLD WITHOUT.
CREATING MORE WATER WE HAVE. TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WAS A WHAT IS
YOURS ON HISTORY. AND WE DIDN'T
SAY THAT WATER LETTING IT OUT
AND IS GOING TO THE OCEAN. THE
PLANET HAS 75% OF THE PLANET IS
WATER. FOR GOD'S SAKE YOU THINK
WE COULD GET SOME MORE AND STORE
IT. TO THE WE HAVE IT IN DROUGHT
YEARS. WE TALK ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE IN THIS BUILDING ALL THE
TIME CLIMATE CHANGE IS NOT THE
SOLUTION. IS THE PROBLEM. WHY
DON'T WE TALK ABOUT. IT FOR.
ABOUT STORING MORE WATER
CATCHING IT BECAUSE IT'S COMING
UP EARLIER WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
THAT WE JUST TALK ABOUT
PENALIZING PEOPLE OR PAYING
BECAUSE WE HAVE ALL KINDS OF
MONEY IN CALIFORNIA JUST BUY
STUFF BUT IT DOESN'T HELP THE
ECONOMY DOESN'T HELP TO
COMMUNITIES AS DESTROYING
AGRICULTURE IN THE WAY OF LIFE
IN CALIFORNIA I'D LIKE TO SEE
SOME MONEY PUT IN THIS BUDGET TO
BUILD SITES RESERVOIR. NOBODY
DISPUTES THAT IT'S NOT. A GREAT
PROJECT. ENVIRONMENTALISTS LIKE
IT. LABOUR LIKES IT AG LIKES IT
THIS APOLOGIES LIKE IT AND WHAT
WE GETTING NOTHING NOT ONE RED
PENNY GOING TOWARDS RIDICULOUS
WHAT PERHAPS SENATOR IF YOU READ
THROUGH THE REST OF THE SENATE
PROPOSAL YOU WOULD NOTE THAT WE
HAVE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION TO
IMPROVE THE WATERSHED CLIMATE
RESILIENCY REGIONALLY THIS WOULD
IMPROVE THE WATERSHEDS THAT
WOULD ALLOW MORE WATER TO END UP
IN THE EXISTING DAMAGE THAT WE
HAVE DOESN'T INCREASE CAPACITY
BUT INCREASES THE AMOUNT OF
WATER IN THE IS PARTICULARLY IN
THE UPPER WATERSHED. THAT WILL
IMPROVE IT IN THE IN THE WHAT
YEARS THAT WOULD IMPROVE YOU YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT SOME SOURCE. THE
SOURCE OF WHERE THE WATER'S
COMING FROM AS WELL AS THE ONE
POINT FIVE. BILLION TO IMPROVE
THAT SAFE DRINKING WATER SOME OF
THAT MONEY IS GOING TO BE
WATERSHED WORK BECAUSE THAT THAT
WATER DOESN'T GET TO THE PEOPLE
AND LESS IT'S CLEAN FROM THE
REMNANTS OF THE FIRE OR THE
DESTRUCTION THIS OCCURRED. IN IN
YOUR DISTRICT AND SENATE MCGUIRE
SISTER WE RECOGNIZE THAT THAT
THAT NEEDS TO BE REPAIRED SO
THAT'S THREE BILLION DOLLARS IS
NECESSARY WORK THAT'S BEING DONE
IN YOURS IN SENATOR MCGUIRE'S
DISTRICTS LARGELY TO IMPROVE.
THE DAMS THE OPERATION OF THE
DAMS IN THE WATER THAT'S
AVAILABLE AT THAT THOSE AT THOSE
FACILITIES TO SAY NOTHING ABOUT
THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION FOR
THE DROUGHT THE DROUGHT
RESILIENT- GRANTS. TO ASSIST
WITH RESPECT WHICH IS DOWNSTREAM
WHICH MIGHT BE IN MY DISTRICT
WORK WHERE PEOPLE USE IT SO THAT
WE REDUCE THE STRESSORS ON ON.
ON THE- FACILITIES. SO THERE
IT'S NOT LIKE THERE'S NOTHING IN
THERE ARE THERE'S THINGS IN
THERE AND- WE'LL SEE WHO'S RIGHT
I MEAN IF THIS GETS APPROVED.
WE'LL SEE WHO COMES FOR BECAUSE
I THINK YOUR OBSERVATIONS ARE
THAT THERE'S SOME. THE DAMAGE
HAS ALREADY OCCURRED TO MEMBERS
AND THE AGRICULTURE COMMISSION.
OR COMMUNITY THEY THEY THEY THE
PICTURE THAT YOU'VE PAINTED IS
ALREADY IT OCURRED OCCURRED
PEOPLE DON'T FEEL THAT THEY CAN
THEY CAN- RENDER BUSINESS HERE
BUT- IT COULD DO NOTHING. INTO
JUICE WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE
MORE WATER I GUESS IS FOR
CREATING IS BUYING SOMEBODY'S
RIGHTS SO THAT THERE'S MORE
AVAILABLE FOR THE REST OF THE
PEOPLE THAT. IT I DON'T WILL
RIGHTS YOU DO YOU DO SO IF WE
VICE OF THESE THERE'S MORE WATER
. LEVEL IS LITTLE IS IT HE IT
HELPS. THE REMAINING PEOPLE IN
THE SECTOR THAT'S THE THEORY
RIGHT WELL IT'S GOOD TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION WHETHER IT'S NOT IT'S
GOOD OF AFFECTED NOT BUT THERE
ARE WE BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE.
PEOPLE NOW THAT. WOULD BE
WILLING TO SELL THE RIGHT IT'S
WHICH WOULD. A BANK OF ONE
RIGHTS THAT THE LITTLE WATER
AVAILABLE COULD GO TO THE
REMAINING ENTITIES THAT USE IT.
HOW ABOUT US DISCRETES MORE
WATER WE HAVEN'T CREATED NEW
WATER IN CALIFORNIA. SINCE FOR
THE LAST FORTY YEARS AND WE WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THERE'S NOBODY
THAT'S NOT TALKED ABOUT THE
WATERSHED AND I AND I WILL I
WILL GIVE YOU THE FACT THAT. YES
THEY DO THE STRUCTURE HOLDS THE
WATER BUT THERE'S A WATERSHED.
ABOVE THOSE STRUCTURES THAT IS
THE REAL THE REAL. RESERVOIRS
AND IS BURNING UP AND I AND LAST
YEAR WE PUT EARLY ACTION MONEY
IN. AND WE WERE GOING TO GET ON
THE GROUND WE'RE GONNA PROTECT
OUR WATER. BECAUSE WE'RE SO FAR
BEHIND THE CURVE BECAUSE WE HAVE
NOT DONE GOOD FORCE MANAGEMENT
FOR THE LAST. FORTY YEARS- LOOK
I'M ALL FOR THAT BUT THIS THIS
THIS RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT
LAST YEAR. I CAME TO THE SENATE
FLOOR WITH THE- WHOLE STACK FULL
OF ABOUT. A HUNDRED AND FIFTY.
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
PROJECTS THAT WE DIDN'T FUND
BECAUSE WE GAVE THE MONEY TO
CALIFORNIA WE DIDN'T GIVE IT TO
THE R. C. D.'S. AND THE FIRE SAY
KILL. AND THE CAN. SO LOOK I'M
ON I'M ON OF THAT BILL IN TOTAL
CREATE WATER INSTEAD OF JUST
TAKING WATER FROM OTHER PEOPLE
AND PUTTING THEM OUT OF BUSINESS
AND PAYING THEM FOR BECAUSE
THEY'RE IN A POSITION WHERE THEY
CAN'T MAKE A LIVING MORE. FINE I
JUST WANT TO WRECK THAT THERE IS
NO MONEY IN YOUR STORAGE. LIKE A
STRUCTURAL STE. YEAH I GUESS
MAYBE I'LL GET TO AND MAKE TO
PAY. THE L. A. THIS. THESE RIGHT
IN THE WATER. IN THAT SAFE ONE
OF THESE PER- ON A TIME. IN
ORDER TO DO IT DAM ORCHARD BUILD
SITES THEM ISN'T THAT YEARS IN
THE YEAR IN THE MAKE. WELL
RATHER THE FOR POLLS THAT ARE
BEFORE US THIS THIS PACK FAR
THAT WE CAN TAKE BACK ON THE
MEDIA. I MEAN JUST THE JUST FROM
A TECH POINT OF THIS IN IS IN.
ISN'T THAT THE- ANY THAT WE WILL
TO BUILD TAKE YEARS BUILD VERSUS
THE- YOU KNOW THE INVESTMENTS ON
WATERSHED. REESE FOR. A
PURCHASING WATER RIGHTS FLOOD
MAN. CAN HAVE IMMEDIATELY OR-
NOT TO MEET BUT- IN A MUCH
SHORTER LINE. IDEA TYPICALLY
LARGE INFRASTRUCTURE PRO
PROJECTS TAKE MANY YEARS TO
COMPLETE PARTICULARLY IF THERE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL PERMITTING AND-
AND FUND RAISING- AND MULTIPLE
PARTIES INVOLVED THOSE CAN TAKE
MANY YEARS OBVIOUSLY SMALLER
PROJECTS MORE DISCREET EASIER
PROJECTS OFTEN CAN BE DONE MORE
QUICKLY. THE SENATE REQUIRE. IT
IS FOR TO MENTION SITES IT IS
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
FULLY ACCURATE ON SITES STAYS
INVESTED ONE POINT ONE
PROXIMALLY BILLION DOLLARS. JOE
BIDEN. DEMOCRATS HAS JUST
INVESTED TWO POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. INCISORS WAS JUST
ANNOUNCED- ABOUT SIXTY DAYS AGO
ZERO DOLLARS DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION JUST ONE MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE BEING SUPER
CLEAR ABOUT SITES. PSYTRANCE ARE
RECEIVED IN THE LAST ROUND THE
STATE FUNDING THE LARGEST
FUNDING ALLOCATION OUT OF ANY
OTHER WATER STORAGE PROJECT.
THERE IS GONNA NEED TO BE
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS WILL NEED TO
BE ALLOCATED FROM THE STATE BUT
I JUST WANNA BE SUPER CLEAR. SO
WE'RE NOT POSTURING JUST BEING
CANDID ABOUT IT THIRTY TWO POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS JUST CAME
FROM A DEMOCRATIC
ADMINISTRATION. ON WHAT WILL BE.
THE LARGEST WATER STORAGE
PROJECT THIS STATE IS SEEN. IN
DECADES JUST WANT TO BE SUPER
CLEAR ABOUT THAT- AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE FACTS LET'S BE SUPER CLEAR
WHAT'S IN THIS BUDGET THOUGH.
WHAT IS WHAT IS IN THIS BUDGET
HERE WE HAVE. FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS OR MORE LAYING AROUND
THAT WE COULD PUT INTO IT SO AS
WHERE IT'S GOING TO TAKE ABOUT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS TO BUILD
ANYTHING OUGHT NOT TO HAVE
MILLION ONE BILLION I TOTALLY
AGREE. AND THAT'S WHY THE STATE
IN THIS LAST ROUND. SECURE OVER
BILLION DOLLARS SHORT THAT'S WHY
THAT THE PRESIDENT'S MOVE
FORWARD WITH TWO BILLION. BUT I
ALSO HAVE TO MENTION WITHIN
THIS. BILL SEVEN MEDIA NEEDS.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IMMEDIATE
NEEDS FOR COMMUNITIES CROSS THE
STATE WHEN IT COMES EMERGENCY
WATER STORAGE. ANTI PROJECTS
ADDITIONAL WELLS. IN CELL HI I'M
NOT ARGUING HERE- MR SENATOR
WHATSOEVER WE NEED TO DO BOTH
BUT I ALSO WANT TO BE CLEAR.
THAT WE'RE MOVING FORWARD ON
ADDITIONAL ALLOCATIONS REGARDS
TO THE REST OF OUR. OKAY WE'LL
AGREE TO DISAGREE THAT DID THAT
PERHAPS PERHAPS THE SAVINGS THAT
SPRING PUT AND UNDER THE SAFE
TRAIN BY ARE SAFE DRINKING WATER
TO MAKE MORE EFFICIENT USE OF
THE WATER THAT THEY DID THAT
CONSUMER ISSUES AND THE OTHERS
SOME MIGHT NOT BE A DIRECT
INVESTMENT- IN STORAGE BUT WE
THE IDEA HERE AND I'LL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM A
- LASSEN COUNTY. AND TO CREATE
MORE AVAILABLE WATER- BECAUSE I
CAN'T MAKE IT RAIN. I WOULD LIKE
TO GO TO THE- PROPOSAL ON
WILDFIRES WHICH IS THE SIX YEAR
OR- A MULTI YEAR SIX POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLAR FIVE YEAR PROGRAM
- IN. NOTWITHSTANDING THAT- TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION FOR- THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKS ALL THE ITEMS
THAT ARE HIGHLIGHTED THE SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION FOR-
CONSERVANCIES THE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT THE NINETY FIVE
MILLION FOR BIO MASS
COMMUNICATION AND THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION FOR- READ FUEL
REDUCTION PER YEAR. NONE OF THAT
AT THIS MOMENT IS ALLOCATED TO
CAL FIRE ALL OF THAT IS OPEN
OBVIOUSLY THE CONSERVANCY
SURCHARGE DIRECT AND THE BIOMASS
CAL FIVE DOESN'T DO. MUCH AND
BIOMASS BUT NONE OF THAT MONEY
IS ALLOCATED TO THE TRADITIONAL-
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE FOR THE
GRANT PROGRAM WITH CAL FIRE IT
HASN'T BEEN ALLOCATED YET BUT
JUST SO AS WE SIT HERE TODAY. WE
SIT HERE TODAY THIS IS NOT A-
THIS IS THIS IS NOT THE MONEY
THAT'S ALLOCATED TO CAL FIRE
DIRECTLY SO WE'RE OPEN TO
DISCUSSIONS AS WE'VE HAD IT
DIFFERENT TIMES THROUGHOUT THE
LAST FIVE YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN
CHAIRING THIS COMMITTEE ON WHERE
THAT MONEY WHICH IS HIS BEST TO
GO BUT WE'VE CALLED. THE
CONSERVANCY'S ON A YEARLY BASIS
THIS IS SPEECH HERE IN THE VADA
THE TAHOE CONSERVANCIES AND ALL
THE OTHER CONSERVANCY CCC YEARLY
BASIS THE D. INVESTMENT THAT
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE
TOWARDS- IN A MULTI YEAR. A
SCHEME SO WE'RE WE'RE FIGURING
THAT THAT'S THE TYPE OF LONG
TERM PLANNING THAT ARE FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS ARE COUNTIES ARE. TRUST
OUR EMAIL AND THE AND THE
CONSERVANCY'S AND ALL THE OTHER-
ORGANIZATIONS THEIR CAN ALLOW
FOR AS A- SERIOUS INVESTMENT
INTO FUELS REDUCTION ON THE- ON
THE FLOOR. OF THE OF THE FORCE
SO THAT'S STILL HASN'T BEEN JUST
SO WE KNOW. WHAT'S WHERE WE SIT
RIGHT NOW- I GUESS I WANTED TO
ASK FOR COMMENT FROM THE ALEJO
IS EIGHT IF. WE SORT OF CREATED
A MOSAIC HERE WE'RE- AN AGENCY
OR REALIZADO COASTAL CONSERVANCY
COULD LOOK AT YOU KNOW. SOME
BIODIVERSITY MONEY FOR- OUTDOOR
ACCESS THAT MIGHT MAY ACTUALLY
DO SOME WETLAND. RESTORATION AND
SOME WILDFIRE- REMEDIATION BY
BIOMASS SECURE MAIL
ACCUMULATIONS AS WELL AS HELP
OUT THE SEAL. SEALABLE IS THAT
HOW YOU GUYS READ. THE INITIAL-
THE PROPOSAL. MISTER CAN YOU
CLARIFY IS ARE YOU FROM
QUESTIONING WHETHER A PROJECT
THAT DID ALL OF THOSE THINGS
WHERE THAT WOULD QUALIFY FOR
THIS FUNDING OR RIGHT I MEAN I
GUESS WE'RE WE'RE YOU KNOW A LOT
OF TIMES WE'RE WE SILO- WE SILO
- PROPOSALS THAT MUST DO ONE
THING OR IF YOU ONLY GET MONEY
IF YOU DO THIS AND THIS PROPOSAL
AT LEAST THIS IS SITTING RIGHT
NOW IT'S SUBJECT TO THE CHANGES
ALLOWS FOR- ACTORS. IN WHETHER
THEY'RE RURAL CALIFORNIA
MOUNTAINOUS CALIFORNIA THAT THEY
CAN LOOK AT THESE PROPOSALS.
DROUGHT AND WILDFIRE SEALEVEL
RISE. IN BIODIVERSITY AND WEB
TOGETHER THEIR PROPOSALS TO
HOPEFULLY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ALL
THE DIFFERENT. PARTS OF TO- THAT
ARE THERE. DID YOU DID YOU WHEN
YOU READ IT DID YOU SEE THAT OR
IF NOT I GUESS I'M TRYING TO
MAKE IT CLEAR. YEAH I MEAN IN A
I THINK ONE POINT E WOULD JUST
MAKE IS THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE
DETAILS DO MATTER SO AS THE
PACKAGE BECOMES STRUCTURES
DURING NEGOTIATIONS IF THE
INTENT IS THAT. APPLICANTS MAY
BE ABLE TO HAVE A MULTI BENEFIT
PROJECT OR- ACHIEVE MULTIPLE
GOALS. THINKING ABOUT WHICH
ADMINISTERING AGENCIES YOU HAVE
HOW GRANTS ARE SET UP- WHAT THE
APPLICATION PROCESS WILL BE.
OFTEN WE DO HEAR FROM A LOCAL
ENTITIES THAT IT CAN BE
DIFFICULT THAT THEY HAVE TO
APPLY FOR MULTIPLE DIFFERENT.
GRANT PROGRAMS JUST TO FINISH
ONE SPECIFIC PROJECT- SO AS
YOU'RE PUTTING YOUR PACKAGE
TOGETHER THAT IS SOMETHING TO
THINK ABOUT IS HOW CAN YOU MAKE
IT EASY- AND REMOVED. AND TRY
AND ADDRESS MULTIPLE CLIMATE
CHANGE THAT PRICING DAY. MAY BE
FACING YOU KNOW THEY MAY HAVE
THE OCEAN COMING IN THE FRONT
DOOR AND WILDFIRE COMING IN THE
BACK DOOR SO- THINKING THINKING
ABOUT HOW TO STRUCTURE THAT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS FUNDING
WILL BE AN IMPORTANT DETAIL TO
WORK OUT. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
HAS SEVEN EARNED SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION FOUR- THE- MEETING THE
GOAL OF CONSERVING 30% OF THE
STATE'S LANDS IN COASTAL WATERS
BY THE YEAR TWENTY. THIRTY TWO
ADVANCED BIO DIVERSITY- AND
ELEVATE THE ROLE OF NATURE THE
FIGHT AGAINST. CLIMATE CHANGE
WHAT TYPE OF IMPACT IF YOU'VE
THOUGHT ABOUT IT WOULDN'T
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
IN THIS PROPOSAL HAVE FOR.
ACHIEVING THAT BIO DIVERSITY
GOALS. SO I THINK. THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS I THINK AGAIN WOULD
BE REALLY IMPORTANT TO THINK
ABOUT IN TERMS OF HOW YOU'RE
STRUCTURING THIS PACKAGE TO BE
COMPLEMENTARY- WHEN I THINK ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES AND I KNOW WE
DISCUSSING THIS PACK YOU KNOW
THE NATURE BASE PACKAGE-
ANTISEPTIC. HEARING WITHIN ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE
HIGHLIGHTED I'M ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN IS THAT IT'S
DIFFICULT TO SEE WHAT. WHERE
EXACTLY THAT WILL GET US- IN
TERMS OF MEETING THOSE THE
PERSON WITH A THIRTY BY THIRTY
GOALS- IN SOME OF THE SOME OF
THE COMPONENTS OF THE PACKAGE
THAT IT'S SOMETIMES DIFFICULT TO
SEE OKAY WELL. IS THAT WE KNOW
WE KNOW KIND OF WHERE WE ARE
PERCENTAGE WISE IN TERMS OF- AND
CONCERT COMPANY TO CONSERVATION
WE KNOW WE WANT TO GET THE
THIRTY PERCENT. BACK HOW FAR
WILL THE MANY THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING GAS AND I
THINK ONE OF THE KEY THINGS TO
THINK ABOUT IS TRYING TO
QUANTIFY THE EXTENT POSSIBLE.
WHAT THAT WILL GET US AND THEN
HOW MUCH THIS CAN YOU CAN SORT
OF COMPLEMENT THAT AND I THINK
AND THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE LEGISLATURE CAN PROBABLY
YOU KNOW THINK ABOUT WHAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS YOU KNOW. THINK
ABOUT WAYS TO MODIFY THAT AND
HOW IT IS TO FILL IN THOSE GAPS
AND REALLY MAYBE EVEN CONSIDER
TARGETING THAT DEFINES THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE IN AREAS THAT
YOU HAVE THESE SORT OF
MEASURABLE BENEFITS AND HELP US
GET THIS GOAL TO EXTENT THOSE
ARE THE GOALS REALLY THE
LEGISLATURE HAS- AND IF THEY'RE
CONSISTENT WITH THE- WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. CALLS I DON'T.
HAVE AN EXACT NUMBER IN TERMS.
OF WHAT. YEAH YEAH GET. THAT THE
CHALLENGE WE HAVE IS YOU KNOW
YOU. YOU TAKE THIRTY PER. OF THE
LAN MASS THAT'S A NUMBER THAT'S
JUST. ACREAGE RIGHT. OUR HOW
MAY. SQUARE MILES AND THEN YOU
LOOK AT SOME OF THESE. BY
PROJECTS THAT THAT REALLY YOU
KNOW. THE DAYS THERE'S THE
SCIENCE BASED. BIODIVERSITY
ELEMENT OF IT IS GIGANTIC IT'S A
BUT IT'S NOT THAT BIG IT'S NOT
THAT BIG IT'S CRITICAL. FOR THAT
AREA AND IT MIGHT EVEN LINK. TO
OTHER AREAS ARE ON IT ADJACENT
SITE SO YOU BE A WONDERFUL. SPOT
BUT IT'S- IN THE AIR- AT AS FAR
AS BEING. REACHING A THIRTY
PERCENT- ELEMENT IN THE HOLES ON
THE LINE MASSES THEY BECOME.
IT'S A LOT SO. OTHER OTHERS MAY
BE SOME BIG SWAT SIMPLE. THAT
ARE SORT OF YOU KNOW IT'S GOT
BIODIVERSITY IT IT IT MEETS ALL
THE REQUIREMENTS BUT IT DOESN'T
IT'S NOT THE- CREME DE LA CREME
AS FAR AS- DID THEN THE DESIRED
THE NEED TO PROTECT IT RIGHT BUT
IT MAY HELP US ON THIS GOAL SO.
THAT'S IT THE STRUGGLE THAT I
HAVE SO I. GLAD TO SEE THAT YOU
GUYS ARE THINKING ABOUT THE SAME
THING BECAUSE WILL BE LOOKING
FOR- INPUT THERE- ON THE CLIMATE
EQUITY TRUST WE KNOW IT'S A
CONTINUING PROBLEM THAT THE
PRICE OF UTILITIES ENERGY AND
PRICE OF WATER- THAT THAT FOLKS
HAVE- DO YOU HAVE ANY INITIAL
THOUGHTS. I MEAN WE TALKED ABOUT
IT IN DIFFERENT AVENUES IS WE'VE
WE'VE INCLUDING ASPECT OF THIS
HERE. RESEARCHER THIS IS ROSS
BROWN- YEAH I MEAN I THINK ON
THE ELECTRICITY SIDE AT LEAST
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY KIND OF
YOU KNOW. DETAILS COMMENTS ON
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL BUT
CERTAINLY AT A HIGH LEVEL. HIGH
ELECTRICITY RATES IS AN ISSUE
THAT WE HAVE RAISED AS A PROBLEM
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO BE
THINKING ABOUT TRYING TO ADDRESS
ON A GOING FORWARD AMOUNTS FOR.
A VARIETY OF REASONS YOU KNOW
INCLUDING SWORDS WE CANNOT MAKE
REASONS- YOU KNOW POTENTIALLY
EQUITY REASONS YOU KNOW LIKE
TRICITY- RATES ARE EXPECTS THAT
THEY'RE HIGHER THAN YOUR LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND OF THEIR
GREATER SHARE OF THEIR- INCOME
ON ELECTRICITY AND ENERGY USAGE
AND- BUT FINALLY YOU KNOW I MEAN
FAR FROM ENVIRONMENTAL
PERSPECTIVES- WITH HIGH
ELECTRICITY RATES ARE GOING TO.
HAVE AN ADVERSE EFFECT ON KIND
OF FUEL CONSUMERS DECISIONS TO
ADOPT- THINGS LIKE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES OR A LEFT SEARCHING OUT
NATURAL GAS APPLIANCES OR
ELECTRICAL APPLIANCES SO. ON THE
OTHER COULD BE SORT OF ADVERSE-
EFFECTS OR AT LEAST MAKE IT MORE
CHALLENGING TO MEET SOME OF THE
STATE'S CHRONICLES WITH THOSE
HIGH ELECTRICITY RATES AND SO.
ON YOU KNOW FINDING WAYS TO TRY
TO ADDRESS THAT WHETHER WHETHER
THAT BE THROUGH STATE KIND OF
THE STATE BUDGET IN STATE
SPENDING OR OTHER REGULATORY
CHANGES ARE CHANGES TO KIND OF
THE RATE STRUCTURE- THAT
UTILITIES USED TO. COLLECT THE
REVENUE- YOU KNOW LOOKING AT
KIND OF ALL DIFFERENT WAYS TO IT
TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE SEEMS LIKE
AN ISSUE GOING FORWARD. YEAH I
KNOW WE A- A AUCTION THE CAP AND
TRADE NEXT WEEK ON THE
EIGHTEENTH ON ON WEDNESDAY AND-
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THREE POINT
FOUR BILLION THAT OPINION HAS
BEEN REYES- SO FAR AND I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE DIFFERENCES WITH
FINANCE- AT FINANCES- NUMBERS
SOMEWHAT WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING- YOU KNOW
I PERSONALLY THINK THAT THERE
WILL BE. OVER BILLION DOLLARS IN
THE IN THE AUCTION NEXT WEEK SO
WE'RE GOING TO BE IN THE FOUR
POINT FIVE. BILLION DOLLAR-
RANGE WHICH I THINK IS A JUST.
OF DISCRETION. FIGURE OF ONE
SEVEN BILL IS THIS SOME. SHE WE
BE LOOKING THAT. THE GIVEN THE-
APPARENT INCREASE IN THE- THE
AUCTION PROCEEDS. YEAH I MEAN I
THINK G. R. F. IS GONNA ONE FUN
SOURCE TO BE LOOKING AT- FOR YOU
KNOW KIND OF ANY OF THE
POTENTIAL KIND OF LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES- WE HAVE DONE SOME
RECENT- ANALYSIS ON AUCTION
REVENUES IN THE- THE FEBRUARY
AUCTION KIND OF CAME IN HIGHER
THAN WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
WAS. A SPECIMEN AND IT'S JANUARY
BUDGET SO WE ALREADY HAVE HAD A
LITTLE BIT. OF ADDITIONAL
REVENUE COMING ABOUT THOSE
EXPECTATIONS I THINK OF THAT. BY
MARKET PRICES MAINSTAYS SORT OF
WHERE THEY HAVE BEEN OVER THE
LAST FEW MONTHS AND WE CANNOT
CONTINUE EXTRA. THEIR REVENUES
TO EXCEED THE EXPECTATIONS OF
THE- ASSUMPTION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION. THE JANUARY I
THINK ARE MOST RECENT- SUGGESTED
WE THOUGHT THERE COULD BE A
REFUND ABOUT ONE POINT SIX SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IN
DISCRETIONARY. REVENUE AVAILABLE
AS PART OF THIS YEAR'S GENERAL
CLICK SUBMIT YOUR PACKAGE OF
COURSE KIND OF WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE ULTIMATELY ALL GETS
DEPENDS ON YOU KNOW WHAT IT.
ATTENTION BUT RISKED IT HAS- YOU
KNOW KIND OF THE PROJECT FOR
REVENUE TO TAKE- TAKE A DOWNTURN
IN THE NEXT YEAR OR SO BUT
THAT'S KIND OF NUMBER THAT WE
HIGHLIGHTED AS- IF THE
LEGISLATURE TO THINK ABOUT FOR
STARTING IT'S JUST. ABOUT HOW
MUCH- HOW MUCH MONEY WOULD BE
AVAILABLE THIS YEAR AND SO JUST
FOR COMPARISON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S. PROPOSAL
INCLUDE ABOUT A ONE BILLION
DOLLAR G. G. R. PACKAGE SO WE
THERE WOULD BE SOMETHING AND
THERE'S LIKELY TO BE SEVERAL
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS MORE
AVAILABLE TO THE LEGISLATURE AS
PART OF THIS. THIS YEAR'S
PACKAGE HOW RELIABLE ARE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES NUMBERS I
MEAN THIS IS THE SIXTH YEARS
THAT I'VE CHAIRED THIS THIS
COMMITTEE EVERY YEAR WE HAVE
THIS. ON CAP AND TRADE ON WHAT
THE EXPECTED OPTIONS WERE IN
THERE- FOR SIX COMPARED TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE ARE
PREDICTING WHAT THE BAILABLE
MONEY WOULD BE MEAN EACH YEAR.
THEY LOW BALL THE AMOUNT AN N.
HOLD BACK THE LEGISLATURE
ABILITY TO INVEST IN. THE
CLIMATE- AND- THE- CHALLENGES
THAT WE YEAH WE TALK THAT WE
HAVE TO ACTION WE TALK ABOUT THE
MEDIA'S SEE- IN IN IN THAT I
THINK IS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID
PEOPLE ARE HURT AND WHEN IT
COMES SAID THE AREN'T YOU BILLS
IN THE WATER BILLS GAS PRICES IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE MAYBE WILL I
KNOW WE'RE GOING TO BE
REVISITING THIS SO- I'M GLAD TO
HEAR THAT THAT'S A- AS-
POTENTIAL SOURCE ANYTHING ELSE-
THE SELLER. HOURS ON THE PACKAGE
. DOES YOUR ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
IF WE CAN BE HELPFUL THINK WE'LL
LEAVE IT AT THAT- IT'S THERE'S A
LOT TO READ TO THE PUBLIC IS
DIGESTING IT- OUR VISITS I THERE
IS A FIFTY TWO PAGE STAFF REPORT
THAT'S AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE
FOR PEOPLE LIKE TO LOOK AT IT-
YES SENATE DAHLE YOU RECKON I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT- I
APPRECIATE CENTER REQUIRE COMING
OVER AND VISITING WITH ME ABOUT.
THAT WE AGREE WE JUST WE'VE GOT
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET MORE
MONEY IN THE BUDGET FOR SOME OF
THESE PROJECTS BUT I WHAT DID
WANT TO MAKE NOTE THAT I DO I
JUST GOT A TEXT FROM I'M
ASSUMING MONEY FROM FOLKS THAT
WORK FOR FIRE SAFE COUNCILS AND
WORK WITH CAL FIRE THERE WAS A
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS ALLOCATED- FOR. TO BE
AWARDED- FOR FOREST HEALTH. AND
ONLY NINETY EIGHT MILLION OF IT
WAS- ACTUALLY. ALLOCATED OUT SO
THERE WAS AND THEN THERE WAS A
TOTAL REQUEST FOR A HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE. MILLION DOLLARS-
AND I KNOW FOR A FACT WE HAVE
THE DIXIE. HIGHWAY THE DIXIE
FIRE LAST YEAR. THERE'S A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR AWARD FOR RICK
REFORESTATION- ON. THE
INDUSTRIAL LANDS- BUT WE ASK FOR
ANOTHER FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
COME IN- FOR NON INDUSTRIAL
LANDOWNERS AND SO I WANTED TO
NOTE THAT- THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING FOR- TO HELP THOSE NON
INDUSTRIAL LAND OWNERS AS WELL-
WHERE WE SAW THE DEVASTATION THE
DIXIE FIRE. AND THEN THE LAST
THING I WANTED TO MENTION WAS-
THAT- YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL- OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS WE'VE HAD SEVERAL- THAT OF
ONE OUT AND WE'RE DOING. TRYING
TO MEET OUR- FOR- FITTING OR
FORCED NOT THAT IS THE- OUR-
ACCOUNT. TO KALIFORNIA THE
CONSERVANCY'S- BUT SINCE AND
SOME OF THESE PROJECTS ARE- OVER
MANY YEARS WELL. THE CONTRACTORS
BID THOSE JOBS- TWO OR THREE
YEARS AGO AT AND THE- COST OF.
OFF HIGHWAY DIESEL AT THE TIME
WAS LIKE. THREE DOLLARS AND
TWENTY CENTS WELL IT'S SIX IT'S
DOUBLED ALMOST DOUBLED IN THE
TIME. TO THOSE CONTRACTORS.
LITERALLY. ARE USING. FOR EVERY
PIECE OF A- IS IT'S THEIR
DRUMMING MONEY THEY'RE THEY'RE
STILL BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD
THE COST OF THE INCREASE IN
DIESEL- AND SOLD BECAUSE THEIR
BID WAS SET AT A COST WERE
DIESEL SO MUCH LOWER SO. I
WANTED TO I'VE I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE- BEEN CHATTING WITH
SENATOR REQUIRE- BUT I WANT TO
JUST LET THE COMMITTEE KNOW THAT
I THINK WE NEED TO IN THE
BUDGET- ACROSS THE STATE.
ALLOCATE FUNDS FOR THOSE
CONTRACTORS WHO HAVE ALREADY BID
THE JOBS BECAUSE THE COST IS
INCREASED WE WANT TO KEEP THEM
WORKING. AND THEY'RE SHUT DOWN
UNTIL THE FUEL COMES DOWN
BECAUSE THEY JUST THEY'RE LOSING
MONEY EVERY DAY THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO THEY'RE NOT JUST A
BUSINESS IF THEY'RE LOSING MONEY
SO. MAYBE MAYBE THE ALEJO CAN
REMEMBER I THOUGHT THAT THE
SENATE PROPOSAL LAST YEAR WAS
FOR. TWENTY MILLION IN TRANSFER
. COSTS OR NO YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
DIFFERENT BOTTOM I'M TALKING.
THAT WAS FOR MOVING CHIPS TO THE
BIOMASS PLANT YES WE PUT THAT
IN. I'M TALKING ABOUT. EXISTING
WHO A BIT TO DO. THINGS AND-
CONSERVATION WERE IN THE FOR. IN
A WILDLY. WHO HAVE BUILT A
PROJECT AT SAY LET'S SAY FIFTY
TO UP TO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS AN
ACRE. AND THEIR COST OF DIESEL
WAS AT THE TIME TO RUN THEIR
QUICKNESS. RIGHT WAS. THREE
DOLLARS AND TWENTY CENTS A
GALLON AND NOW IT'S SIX TWENTY
FIVE IT'S DOUBLED SO. THEY'RE
THERE THEY CAN'T. BROWN AT A
LOSS AND SO THEY'RE JUST SITTING
IDLE BECAUSE FEW SO EITHER
LOSING MONEY. SO WE NEEDED.
ALLOW IN THE CONTRACTS TO
SUBSIDIZE THEM FOR THE COST OF
DIESEL GOING UP OR WE'RE NOT
GOING TO MEET OUR GOALS. VERY
GOOD SO. SO EVERYBODY KNOWS
WHAT'S IN FRONT OF US AT LEAST
WITH THE WILD. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS TO TAKE THE TWO
MILLION THAT'S IN THE CAPTURE
PROGRAM ON A NAY. PAY PLUS
ADDING FOUR HUNDRED MILLION FOR
A TOTAL OF SIX HUNDRED MILLION
THIS YEAR. AND THEN THE SAME
THING NEXT YEAR TAKE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION AND ADD FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION TO MAKE SIX MILLION.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD TAKE THAT
SIX HUNDRED MILLION AND DOUBLE
IT. MORE THAN DOUBLE IT TO ONE
POINT THREE TWO. BILLION A YEAR
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY ON THE OUT
YEARS ON THE THIRD YEAR IN THE
FOURTH YEAR AND THE FIFTH YEAR.
ALL WE HAVE IS THE CAP AND TRADE
MONEY WHICH- WAS OUR IDEA HERE
IN SEPT TWO BUT WHO CARES. BUT
THAT THAT MONEY A TWO HUNDRED
MILLION AND- VERSUS. THE
GOVERNOR HAS TWO HUNDRED MILLION
AND WE HAVE ONE POINT THREE
MILLION AND YEARS THREE. FOUR
AND FIVE SETS A SIGNIFICANT.
HORIZON THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PAINT AT LEAST. IT MIGHT NOT BE
ENOUGH BUT AT LEAST THIS IS
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN WHAT.
THE NEW SEMESTER. HAS PROPOSED
TO THIS LEGISLATURE. OKAY MAKE
SURE THAT WE PUT TO THEIR ACOSTA
THE INFLATIONARY. FOR DIESEL.
AND ALL UNTIL WE CAN MAKE THAT
DEALT UP THEY CAN KEEP NOT THE
GOAL AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
NUMBER. I HAVE NO IDEA TO GIVES
PRAGYA YOU. BUT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THOSE CONTRACTORS CAN STAY
IN BUSINESS. AND TREAT THE LAND
WHEN YOU TREATED ALRIGHT LET'S
OPEN IT UP FOR PER. HEARING
THERE MAY. OF THE HERE- THAT
WOULD LIKE- ADDRESSED THE
COMMITTEE EITHER ON ISSUE NUMBER
ONE RUSSIAN NUMBER TWO WERE BOTH
OF THEM PLEASE COME FORWARD
THERE'S A MICROPHONE. HI
MODERATOR YOU CAN- STAR. QUEUING
THE- TELEK. SERVICE IN THE
PARTICIPANTS AND I WILL.
REPEATED PARTITION NUMBER IS OUR
IT MIGHT JUST GAVE THE AND- THEN
AND THEN IN THE MEAN. SO THEY'RE
QUEUING UP YOUR THE YEAH. AND I
TO READ. I REPEAT THE- THE PARTY
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 AND
ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE ONE
ONE. FOUR ZERO BUT LET'S TURN TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
ROOM. ONE TWO ZERO ZERO ON AT
THE- STREET FACILITY PLEASE. A
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ORTIZ- ON BEHALF OF SEVERAL
CLIENTS VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
SENATE BUDGET PLAN- MOST NOTABLY
NATURE FOR ALL COMMUNITY NATURE
CONNECTION. ELLIE NEIGHBORHOOD
LAND TRUST AND ESCONDIDO CREEK
CONSERVANCY- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE SENATE'S BUDGET PLAN AND WE
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
INVESTMENTS AND WILDFIRE
RESILIENCY SPECIFICALLY THE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FUNDING
FOR STATE CONSERVANCIES. AND
THEN ALSO FOR URBAN GREENING AND
URBAN FORESTRY AND THE COMMUNITY
ACCESS INVESTMENTS- AN
ALTOGETHER YOU KNOW THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL HELP US EXPAND
ACCESS TO PARKS AND GREEN SPACES
FOR URBAN RESIDENTS. AND BUILD
MORE CLIMATE URBAN COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS ERICA ROMERO ON BEHALF
OF VALLEY CLEAN AIR NOW WHICH IS
A FIVE OH ONE SEE THREE PUBLIC
CHARITY COMMITTED TO QUANTIFY
BELIEVE REDUCING AIR EMISSIONS
IN CALIFORNIA'S AN JOAQUIN
VALLEY WHICH IS THE REGION WITH
THE WORST AIR QUALITY IN THE
UNITED STATES. WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE SENATE BUDGET
PLAN SPECIFICALLY THE PROPOSAL
TO APPROPRIATE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ANNUALLY FOR FIVE YEARS
TO COMBAT. THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND WE HOPE THAT THE
FINAL BUDGET PACKAGE WILL
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON THESE
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO FINDING CLIMB EQUITY
PROGRAMS- AS DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE MOST AFFECTED BY
AIR POLLUTION AND STAND TO GAIN
THE MOST FROM THESE INVESTMENTS.
THANK YOU. HELLO GOOD MORNING-
TERRA CAL SKIN MEMBER STEVEN
MYERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS- FOUNDED
. REGARDING THE SENATE BUDGET
PROPOSAL- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE PROPOSED INVESTMENTS IN
OUTDOOR ACCESS PROGRAMMING
PARTICULARLY THE ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN THE
OUTDOOR EQUITY GRANTS PROGRAM A
STATE PARKS. WE WOULD ALSO ASK
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
GREATER FUNDING FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS AT THOSE
PARKS. TO SUPPORT THE INCREASED
ACCESS THAT WE HOPE THAT THOSE
GRANT PROGRAMS WILL PROVIDE AND
FINALLY WE APPRECIATE AND
SUPPORT THE OTHER INVESTMENTS IN
THE PACKAGE INCLUDING- WILDFIRE
SEALEVEL RISE AND REACHING THE
STATE'S THIRTY BY THIRTY
INITIATIVE- THESE INVESTMENTS
ARE CRUCIAL TO BUILDING.
RESILIENCE ACROSS THE STATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRED. MY NAME IS
MICHAEL I'M THE TWO WITH LEADERS
COUNCIL TO. MCKENNA ADAM TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT DRINKING
PACKAGE PROPOSE THAT SENATE.
WHERE PER- THIS ON THE PROPOSED
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
TWIST A FIRST IN THE NATION LOW
INCOME RATE ASSISTANCE. FOR
WATER WASTE SERVICE. AND THE
MILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND THE
LOW IN HOUSEHOLD WHAT SYSTEM
PROGRAM TO UNDER. HOW THE
INVESTMENTS AND WATER FOR
BILLION. OUR CREW AS WHEN PAIRED
WITH THE PROPOSED IN IN DROUGHT
RESPONSE FR. AND SUSTAINABLE.
MANAGEMENT REGARDING MULTI BY
LAND REPURPOSE WE MY ENSURE THE
FUNDING GO TO PROUD THAT BEN TO
SEE. AND COMMUNITIES A COME. IN
FARMER. WE ALSO SO. THE- PER ONE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR. OVER FIVE
YEARS REC USING THIS PHONE FOR
RESULT CENTERS. WE SHOULD THE
NINE AND TWENTY TWO MILLION FOR
ADEQUATE BUILDING D. CARBON. AT
BE. DIRECT TO LOW INCOME INSTALL
PROGRAM. AND INCLUDE A LITTLE A
STICK UP GRADE FOR HOW. WITHOUT
ESSENTIAL PLANTS AT ALL. AND WE
FOR ADDITIONAL ONE DOLLARS FOR
THE COMMUNITY RESULT. SO PROBE.
REGARDING THE CLAIM AND EQUITY
TRY FUND SUPPORTIVE THE CON BUT
WANT BETTER I. HOW WILL BE. TO
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE CAN. AND
THEIR NEW. AND THEN FOR WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE INTENT. TO SET AN
FROM MY STONES CALIFORNIA'S
ENERGY. HOWEVER WE DO NOT SEE
DOUBLE DOWN ON. THE TRANS THAT
INCLUDE TERRY DIED OR WITH IN
THE DEFINITION OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY- ENERGY SOURCE THAT
IMPACTS THE AIR AND WATER
QUALITY AND DISADVANTAGED.
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU FOR. THE
MORNING CARE AND MEMBERS DANIEL
BLASTED HIDING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION WHEN IT EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE SENATE.
THOUGHT PACKAGE. TIME THINK BIG
WERE AFFECTED BY DROUGHT AND
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WE JUST
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS A MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR AND PROPOSED
INVESTMENT THAT THE SENATE HAS
PUT ON THE TABLE WE PARTICULARLY
- I. THOUGH FUNDING FOR WHY IS.
STORM CAPTURE- TO SENATOR
DOLLIES POINT ABOUT CREATING NEW
WATER THAT'S WHAT THAT DOES AND
SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT%
ALSO DAM SAFETY- THE FUNDING
FIRST- POTENTIAL FUNDING FOR
THAT CATEGORY AND THEN ALSO THE-
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR SAFE
DRINKING WATER TO ENSURE.
EVERYONE IN THE STATE HAS ACCESS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AT BEST A
LAWSUIT ON BEHALF OF WATER RE
USE CALIFORNIA ALL THE WATER
RECYCLERS IN THE STATE. AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN AND PROPOSAL IN IN
WATER- VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR A WATER RECYCLING STORMWATER
CAPTURE AND GROUNDWATER CLEANUP.
STRONGLY URGE- THE BODY TO
SEGREGATE THOSE THREE POTS-
WORLD FRIENDS AND THOSE ARE
GREAT PROJECTS WE DON'T NEED TO
DO GET OUT OF THE STATE BOARD
FOR THAT FUNDING- WE THINK YOU
SHOULD PRIORITIZE- THOSE. WHEN
THE WHOLE PACKAGE COMES OUT- AND
TO THAT END WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR WATER
RECYCLING SPECIFICALLY AS STATED
IN A LETTER FROM SENATOR LAYERED
AND- SEVENTEEN OF YOUR OTHER
COLLEAGUES- AS SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD NOTED THERE'S A ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR NEED
FOR WATER RECYCLING JUST IN THE
NEXT THREE YEARS. IF YOU IF YOU.
PUSH THAT OUT FOR IT TO THE NEXT
TO TEN YEAR PERIOD JUSTIN LOS
ANGELES ALONE THERE'S A TWELVE
BILLION DOLLAR NEED. US SO THERE
IS NO SHORTAGE THERE IS A
WAITING LIST AT THE STATE BOARD
FOR WATER RECYCLING WE GET THOSE
PROJECTS- UP AND MOVING VERY
VERY QUICKLY AND READY TO A
REUSE WATER IN AND STORED FOR
THE NEXT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS
ABIGAIL MILE ON BEHALF OF SAVE
THE REDWOODS LEAGUE AND MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT. ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS FULL SENATE BUDGET PLAN
PARTICULARLY FOR THREE. ONE THE
SIGNAL. SIX POINT SIX BILLION
PROPOSAL FOR WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
IS SPECIFICALLY THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT AND- CONSERVANCIES
AND FUEL REDUCTION. SECONDLY
SEALEVEL RISE BUILDING
RESILIENCE TO THAT ACROSS THE
STATE. VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT
INCLUSION ESPECIALLY. FOR
PROPOSAL THE PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE
MONEY FOR ECOSYSTEM- PROTECTION
. AND FINALLY FOR THE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR BIODIVERSITY
AND AFTER ACCESS INCLUDING THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION TO ACHIEVE
THE STATE'S THIRTY BY THIRTY
GOAL. AS WELL AS INVESTMENT IN
OUTDOOR- ACCESS FOR ALL SO THANK
YOU. BOB GOOD MORNING TERM
MEMBERS WITH US TODAY BUT WITH
COMMITTEE WATER CENTER- WE
STRONG SUPPORT ITEM NUMBER TWO
OF THE SENATE'S PROPOSED BUDGET
PLAN IN PARTICULAR IF WE REALLY.
I THANK THE LEADERSHIP- FROM THE
SENATE ON THE PROPOSED ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION. FOR HISTORIC SAFE
WATER. SAFE DRINKING WATER
INVESTMENTS TO ESTABLISH. A
FUNDING FOR A STATEWIDE LOW
INCOME RATE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM-
AND ENHANCEMENT OF THE LIE WHAT
PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT
UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES ARE
INCLUDED DROUGHT RESILIENCY
INVESTMENTS AND DIRECTORS. FOR
LOWING HOUSEHOLDS. THESE AMONG
MANY OTHER PROVISIONS WILL
ENSURE THAT WE GET CLOSER TO FOR
FILLING CALIFORNIANS HE RIGHT TO
WATER TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIAN HAS ACCESS TO SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
THANK YOU.
KYLE JONES ON BEHALF OF SPUR-
THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS SELF HELP ENTERPRISES
RURAL COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION WHICH ALIGN THE
COMMENTS WITH MANY WATER CENTER
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
BRIDGE THE COMMITTEE LOUIS
BROWN- HERE TODAY ON A VARIETY
OF AGRICULTURAL CLIENTS- TO
FIRST WE'LL ALL START WITH THE
POSITIVE. THANK YOU FOR THE
ADDITIONAL MONEY FOR SAFE
DRINKING WATER HI THAT HAS BEEN
AN ISSUE THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON- WITH THE PRO TEM IN THIS
COMMITTEE- FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
pINVESTMENT. IN THAT AREA. ON
OTHER ISSUES EXPRESSED CONCERN-
EXPRESSED CONCERN WITH WELL WE
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE THE
VOLUNTARY NATURE. OF THE LAND
RETIREMENT MONIES. WE SEE THAT.
COMBINED WITH THE REPURPOSED
SCENE MONIES. OF ALL JUST
REALLY. REDUCING FOOD ACREAGE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AT A
TIME WHEN WE THINK WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT FOOD SECURITY. AND
ACTUALLY HOW DO WE KEEP MORE
ACRES IN PRODUCTION. AND HOW DO
WE KEEP. MORE ACRES PRODUCING
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMICAL
ENVIRONMENTALLY BENEFICIAL
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES WHICH WE
DO BETTER THAN ANYBODY IN THE
NATION. OR SUFFERING A
SIGNIFICANT DROUGHT RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE MAJOR ISSUES WITH GROUND
WATER. AT THE SAME TIME WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
DISPLACING PRODUCTIVE
AGRICULTURAL ACRES THAT PROVIDE
A SECURITY MEASURE FOR OUR STATE
AND OUR COUNTRY. WE THINK THOSE
NEED TO BE. DISCUSSED IN IN
GREATER- DEPTH- WE SEE AND FROM
THE RICE COMMISSION IN
PARTICULAR WE SEE CONCERNS WITH
THE ACREAGE IN THE DISCUSSION OF
FOCUSING ON AREAS LIKE RICE
WHICH WE BELIEVE WE'VE DONE
BETTER THAN GOVERNMENT CAN EVER
DO. AND UTILIZING THAT PROPERTY
WE CREATE FOOD WE CREATE JOBS WE
CREATE MORE WETLANDS ACREAGE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS. AND
YET WE CONTINUE TO SEE THIS
FOCUS OF COMING AFTER IN TRYING
TO PURCHASE THESE PROPERTIES.
LET'S TRY TO DEVELOP A
PARTNERSHIP IN THIS AREA SO THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO WHAT E
DO. WE DID A STUDY JUST A FEW
YEARS AGO IT WOULD COST ELEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AN ACRE. TO
CONVERT THE RICE PLANTS THAT WE
HAVE INTO WETLANDS NO ONE WOULD
EVER MAKE THAT INVESTMENT IF
THERE'S NO RETURN ON THAT
INVESTMENT GET THE RICE INDUSTRY
PUTS MONEY INTO THAT EVERY YEAR
AND NOT ONLY DO WE MAKE IT
ENVIRONMENTALLY BENEFICIAL WE
CREATE A SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
ADVANTAGE FOR THOSE AREAS IN THE
STATE. LASTLY WE LIKE TO SEE AT
LEAST SOME MONIES. PUT TOGETHER
THIS YEAR FOR DROUGHT RELIEF IN
THESE COMMUNITIES IN PARTICULAR
IN THE RICE INDUSTRY WE'RE GOING
TO FOLLOW A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF ACRES WITH THAT COMES THE
IMPACT TO BUSINESSES. SCHOOLS
COMMUNITIES WE SAW BUSINESSES
AND COMMUNITY SHUT DOWN DUE TO
COPE IT WE'RE GOING TO SEE
SIMILAR IMPACTS IN A LOT OF
AREAS IN THE STATE THAT'LL SEE.
ACREAGE THIS BEING FOLLOWED TO
THE DROUGHT BUSINESS WILL BE
IMPACTED THEY NEED ASSISTANCE TO
GET THROUGH THIS SO THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES CAN SURVIVE AND
CONTINUE TO EXIST SO WHEN WE
COME OUT THE BACKSIDE OF THIS
DROUGHT. THEY'LL STILL BE THERE
AND OUR COMMUNITIES WILL STILL
EXIST SO WE ASKED FOR SOME
ATTENTION ON A VERY SHORT BASIS
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON SMALL
BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITIES IN
OUR AGRICULTURAL AREAS THAT NEED
TO GET THROUGH THIS DROUGHT.
THANK YOU. SORRY ME AGAIN ELENA
ORTIZ ON BEHALF OF NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ACTION
FUND AND WE WOULD JUST LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
SENATE BUDGET PLAN. AS WELL AS
THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN AND
PROPOSALS TO INVEST SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES AND COMBATING CLIMATE
CHANGE AND MITIGATING ITS
IMPACTS. WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SENATE'S PROPOSAL
TO INVEST ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN SAFE AND CLEAN
DRINKING WATER. INCLUDING TWO
HUNDRED MILLION TO SAVE WATER
AND LOWER BILLS AND LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS AND WOULD LIKE TO SEE
AT LEAST FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
ALLOCATED FOR LARGE SCALE WATER
RECYCLING. WE APPRECIATE THE
STATE'S ACTIONS TO DATE ON THE
THIRTY BY THIRTY INITIATIVE AND
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCREASE INVESTMENTS AND THIRTY
BY THIRTY IMPLEMENTATION.
ESPECIALLY SUPPORT THE A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS DOWN PAYMENT FOR
TRIBAL SUPPORT FOR NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS AND THIRTY BY THIRTY.
IN ADDITION WE URGE AT LEAST ONE
BILLION IN FUNDING TO
DECARBONISE CALIFORNIA'S
BUILDINGS AND ADDITIONAL MONEY
FOR COMMUNITY RESILIENCE CENTERS
TO HELP PEOPLE COPE WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE. FINALLY ENERGY C.
OPPOSES THE SO CALLED VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT FOR THE BAY DELTA
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
WE APPRECIATE THE SENATE DOES
NOT PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THIS
EXCLUSIONARY ANTI ENVIRONMENTAL
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THAT EXHAUSTED MEMBERS HERE IN
ROOM- TWELVE HUNDRED. MODERATOR
WE PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND
CALL THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN LADIES ON THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO-
TESTIFY ON THIS BILL- PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE
FALL BY ZERO AT THIS TIME NOT
GREATER QUICKLY GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE THEN PLACE IT
BACK INTO THE QUEUE WILL BEGIN
TODAY WITH WIND SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DRINK SO MUCH COFFEE
SIXTEEN YEAR OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SORRY ABOUT THAT I THOUGHT YOU
SAID SIXTY THIS IS LAURIE KIM
CALLING THE LOS ANGELES ALLIANCE
FOR A NEW ECONOMY AND I WILL
CALLING TO THANK THE SENATE ON
BEHALF. OF FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON CLIMATE AS DEMONSTRATED WITH
THIS BUDGET. WE ASK LANE ALONG
WITH FIFTY OF OUR ALLIES ARE
ESPECIALLY EXCITED TO SEE THE
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
INVESTED FOR DROUGHT RESILIENCE
PROJECTS LIKE WASTEWATER
RECYCLING STORMWATER CAPTURING
GROUNDWATER CLEANUP. ANY HOPE TO
SEE THESE FUNDS COVERED BY LABOR
STANDARDS THE CREEK THAT UNION
WATER JOBS. IN THE CITY SPENDS
ALL SUPPORT LARGE SCALE WALK
WASTE WATER RECYCLING PROJECTS
LIKE INTO THE EAST REGIONAL
RECYCLED WATER PROGRAM. WE WOULD
ALSO- WE'RE ALSO THRILLED TO SEE
THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR SAFE DRINKING WATER
AND WENT AFTER THE COMMON UNITY
WATER CENTER FOR ENTHUSIASM FOR
THOSE COMPONENTS. AND WE ALSO
WOULD ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM
OUR- ALLIES THAT RTC AND
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL AND ARE.
DISHING OFF SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES FOR CLIMATE RESILIENCE
CENTERS AND FOR SCHOOLS AND
LIBRARIES SUCH AS BOTH MY GREAT
AND FOR DIRECTING THAT. ENERGY
AND WATER EFFICIENCY UPGRADES
HOPE TO SEE. IS INVESTED COVERED
BY LABOR STANDARDS AS WELL.
THANK YOU AGAINST THESE MAJOR
COMMITMENTS TO THE MORE
RESILIENT ADAPTABLE FEATURE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU TO ENSURE IT
EITHER IN THE FINAL BUDGET
THANKS AGAIN. THANK YOU SO. MUCH
YOUR PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I.
FORTY. THREE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND
YOUR ON BEHALF OF THE CESSATION
OF ALCUIN WATER EIGHT IS. JUST
WANT TO THANK THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
IN YOUR CHAIR AND THE PRETENDS
OPTED FOR THE LEADERSHIP ON
DEVELOPING B. CLIMATE BUDGET
PLAN- UNITED TO. UNLOCK WITH
VERY ENCOURAGED TO SEE THE PHOTO
OR SEVEN POINT FIVE BILLION
WATER DROUGHT ISSUES THAT BUILDS
ON THE INVESTMENTS FROM LAST
YEAR THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE PASSED. A PARTICULAR
ONE EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THE
ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR DAMS AT
AND T'S WHAT PROTECTION THIS IS
THE ISSUE THAT MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS AND OTHERS ADVOCATING
FOR I'M SO AGAIN WE APPRECIATE
THE SENATE CONSIDERATION OF THIS
ITEM. ALSO VERY ENCOURAGED YOU
TO PROPOSE FUNDING FOR WATER USE-EFFICIENCY OF RECYCLED WATER
PROJECT GROUNDWATER YOU KNOW AT
THE END OF IT THANK YOU WATER.
I'M JUST A COMMENT AT THE SENATE
MAY WISH TO CONSIDER INCLUDING
WATER USE EFFICIENCY PROJECTS
I'M ACCURATE KITCHEN DISTRICTS
AND WATER AGENCIES THAT SERVE
ADD WATER ISSUES- WE KNOW THAT
THAT IS AN ISSUE THAT THE NUMBER
OF OUR MEMBERS ARE INTERESTED IN
AND SEEING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR AG. WATER USE EFFICIENCY- WE
ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING
MORE ABOUT THE DETAILS OF THE
PROPOSAL I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE SENATE TO
FAMILY AND ADMINISTRATION TO
ADDRESS WATER IN DROUGHT ISSUES
AS A RESULT OF THE CHANGE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU I FIVE YOUR
OPEN. YES HI MORNING. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YOU'RE COMING IN LOUD
AND CLEAR GOOD MORNING. OKAY
GOOD MORNING I AM JUST LEARNED
AND I'M NOT SAYING I'M IN ORDER
FOR IT BUT I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
WHAT THE PROPOSITION ONE IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN CENTS WHEN WE
THE PEOPLE VOTED YES. ISSUING A
SEVEN POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
WHICH IN ACTUALITY WAS. LOW ONE
WHERE DID ALL THIS MONEY GO TO
AND WHY WASN'T USED FOR THE LAST
EIGHT YEARS AND NOW EIGHT YEARS
LATER WE'RE CONCERNED BUT
EVERYDAY WE'RE LETTING WATER OUT
TO THE PACIFIC OCEAN TO TRY TO
STAY BUT NOT FOR SOME SPECIAL
ENTRANCE. I'M VERY CONCERNED
THAT YOU GUYS ARE DRUMMING UP
MORE MONEY WHEN WE HAD A LOT OF
SEVEN POINT ONE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR BY
CAL. THERE'S RIGHT NOW. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY
YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO CHAIR
NUMBERS AND THEN TO HAVE THE
TRANSCRIPTS CONSULTING ON BEHALF
OF ASIAN PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL
NETWORK THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
IN THE ENTIRE TWO PAGE REPORT
ABOUT CCS THERE'S ONLY ONE LINE
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL PITFALLS AND
DROP BACK TO THIS TECHNOLOGY.
REFERENCING AT THE TECHNOLOGY
ITSELF AND CONTRIBUTE TO
EMITTING AIR POLLUTANTS SUMMARY
ISSUE WE ARE TRYING TO SOLVE.
AND HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES WHEN THERE ARE SO
MANY UNKNOWNS ABOUT THE
ECONOMICS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
RISKS THAT THE MANY FORMS OF PCS
WE BELIEVE IT IS A MISTAKE TO
FOCUS ON THE FAMILY CHEMICAL
POLLUTION. RATHER THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
SHOULD PRIORITIZE EQUITABLE
RENEWABLE ENERGY SOLUTION. TO
REPAIRS AND CONTRIBUTE TO
RELIABILITY AND PROMOTE LIVABLE
WAGES. ON BEHALF OF WATER
FOUNDATION AND WATER CONDITIONS
BECAUSE THE FUND INVESTS IN
WATER ESPECIALLY THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION FOR DRINKING WATER
AND SUPPORT FOR FIRST IN THE
NATION THE CENTRAL INCOME WATER
USERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
I'VE BEEN TOLD WE HAVE QUITE A
LIST OF PEOPLE THAT ARE WAITING
TO GET ON LINE AND WE. HAVE TO
GET OUT OF THIS ROOM. I BEFORE I
CARE TO SO IF THE REMAINING ON
THE LINE IF YOU COULD YOUR COM.
TO A MINUTE AND A OBVIOUSLY YOU
CAN. ADD YOUR COMMENTS GONNA BE
TALKING ABOUT THIS THESE
PROPOSALS FOR AWHILE WILL ADD
HIM TO OUR WEBSITE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. GOOGLE LINE FIFTY TWO
YOU ARE OPEN. AMBER MY NAME'S
LEVO KEITH CONNECTING YOUR
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC AFFAIRS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY WE'RE VERY HAPPY THE
SENATE BUDGET PLAN TO PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
TO THIRTY BY THIRTY THREE
BILLION PROPOSED RESILIENCY. WE
BELIEVE THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
IF YOU DIRECTED TOWARD EXISTING
PROGRAMS AT W. C. B. AND OTHER
CONSERVANCIES AND PROVIDE A
HUNDRED MILLION TOWARD THE
ADMINISTRATION TRAVEL PROGRAMS
WE ASK YOU TO CONSIDER INCLUDING
FUNDING FOR CAPACITY BUILDING
FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LAND TRUSTS OUR
TV'S AND OTHER NGOS. HELP CARRY
OUT THE STATE THIRTY BY THIRTY
INCH HIGH RESILIENCY GOALS
ALLOWED THREE EARNED YOU CAN
PROVIDE FORTY MILLION TO
COMPLETE THE STATE'S FINE SCALE
VEGETATION MAPPING COULD
DIRECTLY ADDRESS CENTER BY CAL
CONCERNS ABOUT BEST PLACES TO
PROTECT BIODIVERSITY AND PROVIDE
VALUABLE INFORMATION THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE THANKS. SO MUCH.
NECKS ANNEX WE'RE GONNA TO OF
FORTY YOU ARE. GOOD MORNING
SHARE AND CO MEMBERS A TIME
MEDARY KERR ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
RESPECT REGIONAL CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY AND SUPPORTERS OF THE
SENATE CLIMATE BUDGET PLANS AND
THE NRA'S NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS
BUT YOU CAN'T PUZZLE WHICH
INCLUDES THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. A P. D. F. W. BUT THE
APPLICATION OF HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLAN AND NATIONAL
COMMITTEE CONSERVATION PLANS.
ARE STATE CREATURE AT THE
CLINTON ADMINISTRATION'S
ATTENTION CHAMPIONSHIP OUR
NATIONAL RESOURCE THE CRIME
RESILIENCY AND OUR AND IT'S H.
C. P. AND IS A READY PARTNER. TO
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ZACKS THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD ALL. THANK YOU
MISS CHAIR MEMBERS AND J. YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE LOCAL PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION THE RANCHO
CALIFORNIA WATER DISTRICT. VERY
BRIEFLY JUST WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION FOR THE SENATE YOU
KNOW CONTINUED LEADERSHIP AND
PUTTING FORWARD THEIR CLIMATE
BUDGET PLAN. AND EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT IN PARTICULAR FOR
THE BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSED
INVESTMENT IN DAM SAFETY I THINK
THERE'S BEEN BIG ENOUGH YOU KNOW
CONVERSATION TODAY BUT BUT JUST
TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE POINTS.
YOU KNOW GIVEN THE CHANGES AND
PRECIPITATION DUE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE IN THE NEXT SEVERAL
DECADES YEAH THIS INVESTMENT IS
IMPERATIVE IT IS IT IS
DEFINITELY ONE OF THE BEST
ADAPTATION MEASURES THAT COULD
BE ADOPTED. AND WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THAT THE EXISTING
DAM- BE ABLE TO OPERATE AT
CAPACITY GOING FORWARD AND SO
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
ON THE RIGHT TRACK AND VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED THANK YOU. THE EX.
NEXT WE WERE LINE FORTY TWO IN
YOUR OPEN. GOOD MORNING MISTER
TURNER MEMBERS CAN ROBINSON ON
BEHALF OF THE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION COALITION
CENTRAL COAST ENERGY SERVICES
AND SUPPORT OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE BUDGET PLAN TO FUND
THE NINE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
MILLION PACKAGE FOR EQUITABLE
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION AT
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. THE
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
COLLISION IS ALSO REQUESTING
ADDITIONAL ONE BILLION TO
CONSTRUCT AN UPGRADE COMMUNITY
RELEASE CENTER THANK YOU. X. ONE
THIRTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN BURNS BUT DID
NOT INCLUDE ONE WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY CALLING TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE SENATE
BUDGET PLAN. BUDGET PROPOSAL IS
A STRONG RESPONSE TO THE
MAGNITUDE OF CLIMATE RELATED
PRICING THAT WE'RE FACING
ALREADY CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
CONCERT THE PHONE SUPPORTTHE
SENATE CLIMATE BUDGET ACTIONS TO
ADDRESS OUR ONGOING DROUGHT
CONDITIONS EXTREME WILDFIRES THE
LEVEL RIGHT AND THE URGENT NEED.
TO SAVE OUR STATE UNIQUE
BIODIVERSITY. EVERYDAY THAT WE
WAIT TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE
ONLY INCREASES THE COST AND
IMPACT OF THE CRISIS. ONE MAJOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SIX HI NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY TWO YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING NATALIE
NOT COMING UP WITH THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING ASSOCIATION-
I'LL MAKE THIS SHORT AND SWEET
ANYBODY SUPPOSED TO PUT FORTH BY
THE LEGISLATURE MUST INVESTED
THEIR MACHINE VEHICLE. THERE'S A
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S CURRENT
THAT PROPOSAL AND OCCURRED TO
LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT. AND MOVE
FORWARD WITH INVESTMENTS THAT
ARE CONSISTENT WITH WHAT HAS
BEEN PUT FORTH ALREADY INITIAL
ONE BILLION FROM THE STRONG
MARKET SIGNAL THAT CALIFORNIA
COMMITTED TO REVOLUTIONIZING THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR- I'D ALSO
WANT TO GIVE COMMENTS ON BEHALF
OF POP STAR. WE APPRECIATE THE
SENATE'S RECOGNITION NOT
TRANSPORTATION POLICY SHOULD BE
A TOP PRIORITY IN THE BUDGET
THIS IS WHY WE OFFER FOR THE
GOVERNORS- THAT'S THE POSTAL AND
ENCOURAGE A LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT
A PROPOSAL THAT IS ALIGNED WITH
WHAT IS. ALREADY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WIH SENATORS AND STAFF-
ON THE POLITY POLICY TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA. NEEDS A CLEAR
MISSION GOALS. ZACKS THANK YOU
SO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING- CHAIR STAFF COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU EVERYONE
WORKING SO HARD ON THE BOLD
INVESTMENTS IN THIS INSPIRING
AND AMBITIOUS SCIENCE DRIVEN
PROPOSAL- WE ESPECIALLY SUPPORT
AT THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE
PROVIDE ESPECIALLY SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL TO. WITH AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR THIRTY
BY THIRTY THREE BILLION FOR
COASTAL RESILIENCE AND I DO WANT
TO SAY YOU KNOW SURE WHAT COUNTY
ARE YOU ASKED WHETHER THESE
PROPOSALS CAN DO IT ALL AND THEY
CAN THEY REALLY OVERLAP AND THEY
FIGHT DROUGHT FIRE THE ADVANCE
ACCESS AND EQUITY. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY HEY PROTECT
BIODIVERSITY THAT KIND OF
FUNDAMENTAL ELEMENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S- THAT PROSPERITY.
AND ALL THAT WE ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE CONSIDER BUT ON THE
GROUND SCIENTISTS ARE SAYING IN
DOCUMENTS LIKE THE THIRTY BY
THIRTY SIGNS REPORT WHERE THEY
CALLED FOR AN INVESTMENT IN
VEGETATION MAPPING FOR THE
STATE. FOR ALL TAXABLE ADVERSITY
INVENTORY SO THAT WE HAVE THE
FUNDAMENTAL INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE GOOD PLANS BY
REPOSITORIES AND DNA BARCODING
AND OTHER ELEMENTS. TO ADVANCE
THE CONCEPT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SIX ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR OPEN.
GOOD MORNING JAMIE MINOR I'LL BE
HAPPY EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT OF MONTEREY ONE WATER
IN THE IN A MARGARITA WATER
DISTRICT- WE JUST WANT TO START
BY SAYING WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE SENATE LEADERSHIP ONCE AGAIN
ON THESE CRITICAL INVESTMENTS IN
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE. IN
PARTICULAR THE FUNDING FOR WATER
RECYCLING GIVEN A LONG LIST OF
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS- WE HAVE
TO DROP TOO FAR Q. U. WATER
SUPPLIES IN ADDITION ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STORM WATER
QUALITY ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT
THE FUNDING FOR STORMWATER
CAPTURE AND MANAGEMENT IN THAT
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL- WALL URBAN STORM WATER
MANAGEMENT IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT WAYS WE CAN PROTECT
OUR PRECIOUS WATERWAYS- ALSO
INCREASING VALUABLE WATER
SUPPLIES THAT ACTUALLY REMAIN
FOR THE MOST CHRONICALLY
UNDERFUNDED INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
FACING LOCAL GOVERNMENT. TODAY I
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK ONE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR OPEN. GOOD
MORNING YOU KNOW I'D BE HAPPY
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA HELLO MY LAN TRUCK NO
ONE A LINE ARE COMMON WITH THAT
MADE BY YOU DON'T SPEAK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
AND WE BURIED THE PORT WANT TO
THANK THE SENATE FOR A CLIENT
BUT YOUR PLAN AND WE ARE
PHYSICALLY SUPPORTING THE
BILLION DOLLARS PROVIDE BREAKING
OUT TOWARDS THE ALL IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE. TO PUT
THE DIVISIONAL BUT GOOD AT FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS BEFORE I GO BACK
TO TAKE A NAP AND IT REALLY IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL WE FINISH IN
1940% OF OUR STATE WHICH IS OFF
CENTRAL COAST. THAT I. AM NOT A
PRODUCT THAT. AND LASTLY- I. I'M
THEY HAVE TO DEPEND UPON WELL
YEAH SUPPORTING THE SEVEN POINT
FIVE BILLION FOR THE AND PACKED
HOWEVER WE WOULD LIKE THE FLAG
FOR THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
FOR WATER TO BY THAT- DEFINITELY
OUT MORE IN PARTICULAR WE TO
MAKE SURE THE ONE THAT IS IN
FACT IS GONE COMING UP WITH PRO
. AND WE BOTH WE'LL FRAME HELLO
- AND NOT CHANGE WITH HIGHER
WATER BY WHICH IS- ONLY AT SIGN
BUT AGAIN WE APPRECIATE THE OF
BECAUSE THEY- AND BY THAT THAT
IS. AND CLEARLY THANK YOU. THE
EX. ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORE THAN OF THE
COMMITTEE STAGE THAT THE WORLD
WERE OF. RC RC THE HARD WORK ON
THE PROPOSAL AND IN PARTICULAR
THE WILDFIRE PACKAGE RT RT THAT
THIRTY NINE MEMBER COUNTIES HAVE
LONG SUPPORTED MULTI YEAR
INVESTMENTS IN WILDFIRE
MITIGATION AND FOREST RESILIENCE
AND NOW IT'S ON GOING DROUGHT
CONTRIBUTING TO THE DEGRADATION
OF OUR FOREST LANDS AS WELL AS
THE INCREASE OF TREE MORTALITY
FROM BARBIE DOLLS THAT WE'RE
ONCE AGAIN SEEING. IN OUR COUNTY
IS IN THE SIERRAS AND OUT
TOWARDS THE COAST A LONG TERM
INVESTMENT PLAN AND THE HELP OF
OUR FORESTS AND WILDLANDS AND
WATERSHEDS. IS TIMELIER THAN
EVER. FOR THE SIX POINT SIX
BILLION PACKAGE- OVER FIVE YEARS
OF LONG TERM INVESTMENT IN OUR
FORESTS. AND WE APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF IT IN THIS PLAN
THANK YOU. BY SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE SIXTY YOUR ALTERNATE
DOLLARS. SORRY DANNY OFFER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PORT AUTHORITY IS IN SUPPORT OF
ALL THE RESILIENCE DOLLARS AND
BUT IT'S QUITE. LINE FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THINK YOU ARE
ME GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
RETURNING RETURNING EVEN IF ONE
OF MY RARE ORANGE COUNTY I'M
CALLING A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
WATER AND DROP PACKAGE WITH THE
KILLER LEE THE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION PROJECT RETURNING A LOT
OF MY GRANDKIDS ARE QUITE CLEAN
FROM A CAPTURED A GUN ON THE
MAP- ARE ALSO IN. FAVOR OF ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION OR SAFE
DRINKING WATER- INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO OTHER POINT. SHOT
AND CLEAN WATER. BUT THE WATER-
YOU LOW INCOME RIGHT PROGRAM
OKAY FREE TIME. NEXT ONE SIX
YOUR OPEN. A PLEASE GIVE ME
LIGHT SIXTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN.
MORNING CHAIR MARTIN DAWSON
WHICH HALF OF SANTA CLARA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT FOR
THE PROPOSAL TO APPROPRIATE
SEVEN POINT FIVE BILLION OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS TO BUILD
CLIMATE RESILIENT WATER SYSTEM
WHICH INCLUDES DAM SAFETY FLOOD
PROTECTION AND RECYCLED WATER.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR WATER CONSERVATION
THE COASTAL WATERSHED MANAGEMENT
FUNDING AND THE FUNDING GROUP
DELTA ECOSYSTEM RESTORATION
THANK YOU. THE EX SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR
TAKING MY CALL I'M CALLING FROM
SUSSEX COUNTY I'M A LITTLE
CONCERNED BUT THERE ARE OTHER
SPENDING THAT'S GOING ON. IN THE
PAST WE HAVE ALWAYS SAID OKAY
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A DANCE NUMBER
EXPORT ANYTHING NOTHING HAPPENS
HOW CAN I HAVE FAITH. IN MY
YOUTH YOU FOR SAYING WHEN IT.
HADN'T BEEN DONE AND IT WAS
PROMISED BEFORE. WELL BLACKROCK
KNOW YOUR WE HEARD YOU ANYTHING
ELSE YOU WANNA ADD. NO WAY I CAN
I THANK THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE SPENDING SPENDING AND
SPENDING IS GETTING RIDICULOUS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. ONE
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS DENNIS OUT BEYOND
THE ON BEHALF OF SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER AGENCY AND SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY M. W. D. AS WELLS
MESA WATER DISTRICT AND THEN I'M
GONNA HAVE SECONDARY COMMENTS
FOR NON AGRICULTURE FROM ALLMAN
ALLIANCE THE GRAIN FEED AND SEED
ASSOCIATES SO FROM ALL OF THEM
COMPLIMENT THE SENATE ON THE
VISION. AND THE AGGRESSIVE
FUNDING PACKAGE YOU PUT
TOGETHER- FOR- SET THE FOR THE
WATER AGENCIES THEY'D LIKE TO
SEE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR P.
FOSS AND CHEMICALS OF CONCERN
THAT- IN GROUNDWATER AND SURFACE
WATER I WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
INVASIVE SPECIES SUCH AS A
RHONDA YOU HAVE A LOT OF GUSH
ABOUT BIODIVERSITY BUT INVASIVE
SPECIES AND PLANTS. ARE AFFECTED
OUR WATER AND- AND THEN WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE- SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR- INFRASTRUCTURE AND
HARD INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH AS-
DROP FUNDING IN GROUNDWATER
CLEANUP AND THEN- FOR THE
AGRICULTURAL PLANTS WE'D LIKE TO
SUPPORT- SEES A BUNNY FOR
ENTITIES LIKE SITES RESERVOIR.
AND- APPRECIATE. THAT YOU HAVE
INCLUDING. IN UP AT. FUNNY
MATTER WE DO TO EXPRESSION
CONCERNS SOME OF THE- AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO LEARNING MORE
ABOUT THE DETAILS ON THE SOME OF
THE BIO DIVERSITY FUNDING. FROM
THE LAND PROTECTION RE PURPOSING
AREAS. AND SOME OF THE COASTAL
WATER PROTECTIONS ON HOW THAT
WILL IMPACT AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTION HELLO IMPACT FOOD
SECURITY. AND GOING FORWARD TO
LOOK AT THE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
THIS PROGRAM. WILL COORDINATE
AND POTENTIALLY COMPLEMENT
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT THAT IT
DOESN'T SEEM THAT. THE DEBT IS
ADDRESSED IN THIS- PACKAGE AND
THEN AGAIN WE'D LIKE TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR DROUGHT
RELIEF DRAGON PACKS FARM WORKERS
IN THE COMMUNITIES. THAT THAT WE
LIVE AND WORK IN SO WITH THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE EX.
FIVE SIXTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
NINE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES HE
CAN GO AHEAD. GREAT THINGS ABOUT
. AND FIND A JOB ON CALIFORNIA'S
DRUG AND PROPOSAL I CAN CREATE
FUNDING DEPARTMENT CONSERVATION
EXISTING MULTI BENEFIT WHEN WE
TOOK THE PROGRAM BY FIVE HUNDRED
BILLION DIFFERENT GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY. PROJECTS THAT
REDUCE GROUNDWATER USE- GATE
ATLAN BYE BYE LIKE HABITAT THE
CURRENT PROGRAM THE RESULTS
ABOUT STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
IMMEDIATELY TO SEE SUCH STRONG
DEMAND FOR IT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR INCLUDING THE FUNDING. SPECS
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS CONSISTENT
ACROSS THE SOUTH BECAUSE THEY
CAN BE THE SOUTH COAST FACES
ENORMOUS CHALLENGES REDUCING AIR
POLLUTION AND TOXIC TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH ESPECIALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND WE
APPRECIATE THE EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN AND PLANTATION FUNDING
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR AIR
DISTRICTS HELLO THE PROGRAM IS
SEVERELY UNDERFUNDED WE ASK THAT
YOU PROVIDE INCREASED AS A
STABLE FUNDING TO COVER ACTUAL
PROGRAM COSTS. AND A NUMBER OF
COMMUNITIES IN THE PROGRAM HAS
GROWN AN ERROR TO START WORKING
AT A DEFICIT TO IMPLEMENT IT WE
ALSO APPRECIATE A B. SIX
SEVENTEEN INCENTIVE FUNDING
BEING INCLUDED HOWEVER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS REDUCED IT
AND WE ASK THAT YOU INSTEAD
PROVIDE INCREASED AND
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING TO
PRIORITIZE EMISSION REDUCTIONS
THAT PROTECT THE HEALTH OF THE
CITIZENS COMMUNITIES.
SIGNIFICANT SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
IS CRITICAL FOR MEETING HELD
BASE ON OUR QUALITY STANDARDS
EXHILARATING SORELY NEEDED NEAR
TERM EMISSION REDUCTIONS WE
SUPPORT FUNDING HEAVY DUTY ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGY BEING
DEVELOPED FOR MASTER PLAN IN THE
FUTURE HOWEVER GIVEN OUR NEED TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH NOW WE
SUPPORT FUNDING TO REPLACE HEAVY
DUTY DIESEL TRUCKS WITH NEAR
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS THAT ARE
LOWER COSTS MORE COST EFFECTIVE
TO PROVIDE MORE IMMEDIATE AIR
POLLUTION AND GHG. EMISSION
REDUCTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YEAH WE HAVE SOME DOES AND
SO HE CAN HELP COURTNEY SLIGHTLY
A BIT LATE TEENS- STRAP BUT
MAYBE BUT YEAH PROBABLY A
STRETCH. YEAH IT SIXTY EIGHT
YEAR OLD. EIGHTY EIGHT GO
WORRYING NO MATTER HOW MUCH
ONLINE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
NAME IS CODY ON THE WALL STREET
BECAUSE RELIANCE SPEAKING THE
CORNER TWO ASPECTS OF THE WATER
AND DROUGHT PACKAGE- WE ARE IN
MORE OF THE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS TO INSURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND SACRED WATER.
THE GIVEN RIGHT AND DUTY TO
BOARD THE NIGHT THIS BASED THEIR
ACT STAND AND WE'RE- FINDING
THAT WILL HELP LOWER.
COMMUNITIES INCREASE THE WATER
EFFICIENCY AVOID WATER SHUT OFFS
AND ENJOYED A DRINKING WATER-
SECOND WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR DRIVERS TO CLEAN WATER
SUPPLY GRANT. WHICH IS ABOUT
RECYCLING STORMWATER. CAPTURE
GROUNDWATER CLEANUP. YEAH IN
SOUTHERN CAL IT. PERCENT OF
THEIR WATER YOU DID ONCE THAT IS
BOTH A BIT LIKE WASTE. THAT
CAPTURES THE ORDER BY
RESEARCHERS IS A LOT TO SIMPLY
WASH- BY FUNDING YOU'RE FOR
WHATEVER SIDE AND GROUNDWATER
CAPTURE. WHAT IT COULD DO
BOURBON USE 32408% AND IN BUT
CLEANING SO THIS FUNDING WILL
ALLOW NEEDS ACCESS TO STORE
WATER WHAT WE PRESSURE ON. I'M
THIS ALL THE TIME TESTED IN
TENSION OF REDUCE REUSE AND
RECYCLE I WANT TO END MY COMMON
BY HIGHLIGHTING THAT WHILE WE
ARE FULLY FOUR OF THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR WATER SUPPLY
GRANT. WATER RESEARCH STRONG
BENEFIT FOCUS ON LARGE SCALE
PURPLE. WATER REUSE PROJECTS.
POLLUTION WASTE WATER JUST AND
REDUCE. THE ON IMPORTED WATER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT.
THANK YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING
TURN SAID DAVID STAND TO GAIN
ANY LINE WITH SAM FARMERS OR CAN
. WE'RE ALL FOR BUILDING DRY
RESERVE. BUT WE ARE TO NOT THE
TEAM FOCUS. ON THE CURRENT
IMPACT OF THE DROUGHT THESE
PROPOSALS. I KNOW WE'RE WAITING
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON
THE DROUGHT IN THE MAY REVISE.
BUT THE GAP IS WORSE THIS YEAR
AND IT'S A REAL CRISIS THAT
NEEDS MORE ATTENTION. WE EXPECT
THOUSANDS OF SHALLOW
AGRICULTURAL WELLS TO GO DRY
ITCHY EARS SIMILAR TO THE
DRINKING WATER WELL. MOSTLY
BELONGING TO SMALL FARMERS
INCLUDING MANY FARMERS OF COLOR.
APPLICANTS ASTRID FIFTY MILLION.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA- UNDERSERVED
AND SMALL PRODUCER PROGRAM AT T.
D. F. A. HELP THESE FARMERS
SURVIVE THE DROUGHT KICKS THEIR
WEALTH AND KEEP OPERATING.
OTHERWISE MANY WILL BE DRIVEN
OUT OF BUSINESS AND THERE WILL
BE NO LOCAL FOOD NO FARMERS
MARKET THAT WILL BE ONE OF MORE
BLOW TO THE QUALITY OF LIFE IN
THIS STATE. THANK YOU. THANKS
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BOB
GREEN WITH THREE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS WE WANT TO ON BEHALF
OF OUR CLIENT SAYS THEY ARE
APPRECIATION OF THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS FOR PUTTING IN SOME
PROPOSALS ON THE TABLE FOR US
ALL TO REVIEW AND PROVIDE MORE
SPECIFIC COMMENTS HERE IN THE
COMING WEEKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CENTER VALLEY FLOOD
CONTROL ASSOCIATION WE- REALLY
REQUEST CONSIDERATION OF
INCLUDING THE SCHEDULE FOR THE
ONE BILLION DOLLAR FLOOD CONTROL
DAM SAFETY. PROPOSAL WE WANT TO
ENSURE THE LEGISLATURES OF FULL
PARTNER WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO IDENTIFY PRIORITIES LIKE- THE
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST- THAT WE'VE PROVIDED TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR SMALL
COMMUNITIES FLOOD RISK REDUCTION
PROGRAM. ON BEHALF OF THE WATER
REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT ANNOUNCER
VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
THAT ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MR
ALBION EIGHT PREVIOUSLY
REGARDING SUPPORT FOR SAFE
DRINKING WATER ALLOCATION TO
ADDRESS PEOPLE'S CONTAMINATION
CERTAINLY FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OVER FIVE YEARS WOULD GO
A LONG WAY TO HELPING. REDUCE
INTRIGUE THAT CONTAMINATION BUT
THEY ALSO SUPPORT THE WATER
RECYCLING FOR- PROVISIONS- THAT
WOULD COME WITH THIS PACKAGE ON
BEHALF OF THE VALUE ADD WATER
COALITION- WE SUPPORT THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST
FOR THE MULTI MULTI BENEFIT LAND
RE PURPOSING PROGRAM WOULD LIKE
TO SEE BUDGET CONTROL LANGUAGE
TO MODIFY THE F. B. ONE SEVENTY
LANGUAGE FROM LAST YEAR TO
ENSURE THAT RECHARGE PROJECTS
CONTRIBUTE TO- THIS ACHIEVEMENT
OF THE SUSTAINABILITY GOAL FOR A
PARTICULAR BASIN- PURSUANT TO
THE GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLAN. FINALLY WE SUPPORT- THE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT PROCESS- WE
THINK THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
WORKED ON WITH RESPECT TO THE
SENATE PROPOSAL- THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT PROCESS WOULD RESULT
IN A PERMANENT PERMANENT WATER-
PURCHASES ABOUT SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND ACRE FEET. BUT IT'S NOT
A ONE AND A HALF BILLION OUR
PROGRAM- WITH A THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT PROCESS PROVIDES A
BETTER PATH TO PROVIDING WATER
FLOWS IN THE SACRAMENTO SAN
JOAQUIN- DRAINAGE AREA. AND WE
THINK WE CAN ACHIEVE THAT
WITHOUT THE PERMANENT PURCHASES
SENIOR WATER RIGHTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT. NINE TWENTY NINE
YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS IN
PARTICULAR WITH CLIMBING RESULTS
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION IN LOS
ANGELES WORKING TO MAKING OUR
COMMUNITIES MORE CLIMATE
RESILIENT IN THE FACE OF EXTREME
HEAT. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
SUBSTANTIAL AND ONGOING FUNDING
FOR THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH FOR THE COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE AND EXTREME HEAT
PROGRAM ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR M.
S. P. ONE FIVE FIVE. HERE'S WHY
FIRST THE PROPOSED BUDGET DOES
NOT ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE MOST
PRESSING VULNERABILITY AFFECTING
THE ENTIRE STATE THE TRAFFIC
STREAM HEAT FOR THE PAST THIRTY
YEARS EXTREME HEAT HAS KILLED
MORE PEOPLE THAN CALIFORNIA. ALL
OTHER CLIMATE HAZARDS COMBINED.
ADDITIONAL IS ME TO PROVE DEATHS
AND PREPARE FOR THE PREDICTED
INCREASE IN HEAT WAVES AND POWER
OUTAGES. LAST WEEK THERE'S A
BETTER NEED TO FRONT UP TEACHING
STRATEGIES THAT REDUCE THE URBAN
HEAT ISLAND EFFECT. WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE RECOGNITION THAT
EXTREME HEAT IS EXACERBATING THE
IMPACTS ON VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. COURAGE IS THE
PLANET TO CONSIDER INVESTMENTS
THAT WILL DELIVER IMMEDIATE
RELIEF TO COMMUNITIES. OKAY I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST SUBSTANTIAL
AND ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
FOR THE COMMUNITY RESILIENCE AND
EXTREME HEAT PROGRAM.
ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR IN THAT
SPEECH. ONE FIVE FIVE THANK YOU
NEXT. ONE SIXTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN
. HELLO TURN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MIKEL HIGHLINE RESIDENT OF LOS
ANGELES- I'M CALLING TODAY LIKE
SO MANY OTHERS TO SUPPORT THE
WATER DROP PACKAGE IN
PARTICULAR- I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE LEADERSHIP IN THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION FOR DROUGHT
RESILIENT WATER SUPPLY GRANTS
FOR WATER INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION FOR THE
SAFE DRINKING WATER AND THE-
ESTABLISHMENT FUNDING OF THE
STATE OF THE ART PROGRAMS I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IF THE
LEADERS THE FUTURE THINKING AND
TO PREPARE FOR THE CALIFORNIA TO
BE RESILIENT AGAINST WORSENING
DROUGHT ANDCLIMATE CHANGE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THE EX.
I'M THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING SURE NUMBERS L. TURNER
WITH NEW ENGLAND PAT BUSINESSES
HERE ON BEHALF OF TURLOCK
IRRIGATION DISTRICT CALLING TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
INCLUSION OF ONE BILLION FOR
FLOOD MANAGEMENT DAM SAFETY IN
THE SENATE ON A BUDGET PLAN. DAM
SAFETY IS CRITICAL TO ENSURING
WATER SUPPLY ROUTE THE LIABILITY
GRID STABILITY AND PROTECTING
PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE ECONOMY IN
ADDITION ON THE INCLUSION OF A
HUNDRED MILLION TO IMPROVE WATER
MANAGEMENT SCIENCE WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THE IMPORTANCE OF UTILIZING
GAME CHANGING TECHNOLOGIES LIKE
ATMOSPHERIC RIVER RESEARCH AND-
AERIAL- SURVEYS TO IMPROVE
FORECASTING OPERATIONS TO
CAPTURE CRUCIAL WATER SUPPLIES
AND IMPROVE FLOOD SAFETY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THESE
ISSUES WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THESE EFFORTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. ONE THIRD EIGHT
EUROPE. EACH MORNING WHICH
REMEMBERED THEIR BLOOD ON BEHALF
OF RETHINK WASTE AND WE ARE IN
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES
SUPPORT AND ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR BOTH NEW AND EXPANDING
EXISTING ORGANIC WASTE
PROCESSING INFRASTRUCTURE WELL
WE APPRECIATE THAT ONE THE A
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE MILLION IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET FOR AGAIN
EQUATES INFRASTRUCTURE AND
IMPLICATE IPLICATIONS OF A
LAST. OVER TWO YEARS AT THE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE IS
ESTIMATED TO COST BETWEEN TWENTY
AND FORTY BILLION DOLLARS TO
IMPLEMENT WE NEED A ROBUST LONG
TERM FUNDING STRATEGY TO ENSURE
WE CAN MEET THE STATE'S ORGANIC
WASTE DIVERSION AND CLIMATE
TARGETS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ZACKS. FIVE SEVEN EIGHT YOU'RE
OPEN. YES THIS IS ERICA
DESJARDINS AND A DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA WATER RESEARCH-
ABBOTT FIFTY OUR HEALTH SCIENCE
AND CLIMATE ADAPTATION- WE WANT
TO STRONGLY SUPPORT- THE-
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
IMPROVE WATER MANAGEMENT PLANS.
ARE IN THE BUDGET BEING ON-
FRANKLY DOING ADULT INDEPENDENT
SCIENCE BOARD IN THE ALLOCATION
AS WELL AS FOR- OPTING FOR THE
DOLPHIN THE KIND OF SCIENCE
BOARD MANDATE AT THE REVIEWS.
ARE HOW RESTORATION INVESTMENTS
IN THE DOW- I THINK THIS IS
ESSENTIAL TO ENSURE. THAT
HABITAT MASTER PROJECTS WILL
FUNCTION WHERE ITS CLIMATE
CHANGE PARTICULARLY LEVELIZED
FAMILY LOOK FORWARD. TO WORKING
WITH OUR- IT ALLEGES ON THE PUMP
. THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING SURE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TONY ON BEHALF OF DOCTOR COUNTY
WATER AGENCY. WE'RE JUST CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF THIS HISTORIC
LEVEL OF INVESTMENT THAT REALLY
BUILDS UPON PRIOR INVESTMENTS IN
DROUGHT RESILIENCY AND JUST
INCREASING THE RESILIENCY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA- SO WE APPLAUD YOUR
GREAT WORK- AND THANK YOU FOR
LEADING IN THE SPACE. THANK YOU
THE EX. EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EIGHTY ONE YOU'RE OPEN
PLEASE ON MUTE. MY SHOT EIGHTY
ONE REJECTED TESTIFY. OKAY I
THINK THAT MIGHT BE ME I THINK I
THINK THAT'S THE RIGHT NUMBER
BUT THERE ARE LAWS IN CALIFORNIA
POLICY MANAGER FOR THE SURFRIDER
FOUDATION WE PROTECT CALIFORNIA
COASTLINE AND BEACHES. AFTER THE
COMMENT THAT I WAS PUTTING A
DROUGHT AND WATER REPELLENCY
PACKAGE- LET LET OTHERS INSTEAD
BECOME BENEFITS I REALLY CAN'T
BE OVERSOLD YOU KNOW ON THE ONE
YOU THINK ABOUT FOR WATER
RECYCLING FIRM ARE CAPTURED THE
BENEFITS WATER QUALITY. BE THE
REALLY THE ONLY DROP PROOF
SOLUTIONS WE THINK THAT'LL I
JUST WANT A. COURT APPOINTED
PREACHING YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU NEXT. EIGHTY EUROPA.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS BEEN
SWEATING EITHER WITH THE CLIENT
CENTER- HERE TO REINFORCE THE
COMMENTS WITH THE- NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY BUT THE ADDITIONAL FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE THIRTY
BY THIRTY FIVE AND THREE BILLION
FOR THE FULL AMOUNT THEY- WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO PUT IN A PLUG FOR.
NINE DOLLARS FOR MANAGER. ALONG
ONCE WHAT'S BEFORE AND AT THE
VERY VERY BEST ENTERED ALL THIS
YEAR. AS WELL AS A HUNDRED
MILLION TO IMPLEMENT THOSE.
PROJECTS THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT. ONE THIRTY ONE YEAR OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
PEOPLE ARE UNDERTAKING TONIC
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE IRVINE
RANCH WATER DISTRICT AND YOU GO
WATER AGENCY TO EXPRESS
PARTICULAR THANKS FOR THE SENATE
RECOGNITION OF THE NEED FOR
FIRST EVER SUBSTANTIAL FUNDING
FOR DAM SAFETY PURPOSES. AND TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE AQUA IN
ANYWAY COALITIONS APPROACH TO
DAM SAFETY FUNDING FOR EXISTING
DAMS AND ALSO WANT YOU KNOW
IRVINE RANCH'S SUPPORT FOR
RECYCLED WATER FUNDING AS WELL
IN PARTICULAR THANK YOU. THE EX
ONE SEVENTY YEAR OPEN. NO FOR
MALL WITH CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE SENATE CLIMATE BUDGET
PLAN PACKAGES TO INCLUDE
DRINKING WATER AND TO COMBAT
CLIMATE CHANGES DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY FARM WORKERS THEIR
FAMILIES AND THESE COMMITTEES
HAVE BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
SUFFERING FROM THE IMPACT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AFFECTING THEIR
INDIVIDUAL FAMILY HEALTH INCOMES
ACCESS TO THE SAFE DRINKING
WATER SUPPLY AND COMMUNITY
ECONOMIC VIABILITY. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE TO
ADDRESS FARMWORKER COMMUNITIES
CLIMATE RESILIENCE AND
ADAPTATION PROPOSALS YOUR
CONSIDERATION IS APPRECIATED.
NEXT EIGHTY TWO YOUR YOUR OPEN.
GOOD MORNING GERRY WYSOCKI AND
MEMBERS THAT'S A TREAT TO PLAY
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL NONPROFIT
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENT- SHIFTERS
ARE PASSING HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS IN
TERMS OF THEIR NON COMMISSIONED
BY NEXT YEAR AND SO WE ARE
URGING THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCLUDE TWO HUNDRED MILLION TO
FUND TO HELP URGENTLY REDUCE
CLIMATE AIR POLLUTION FOR THE
MURDER MARINE SECTOR AND
ACCELERATE THE GERMISTON SOUTH
OF MARKET- THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD JUST ADOPTED THE
NATION'S STRONG COMMERCIAL
HARBOR CRAFT TOOL WHICH WILL
HELP SAVE LIVES- HARBOR CRAFT
ARE. DENTURES BURIED AND HAVE
BOTH OR ONE OF THE TOP THREE
CANCER CAUSING EMISSIONS AT
PORTS AND SO AGAIN WE'RE URGING
THE LEGISLATURE TO ALLOCATE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION TO HELP ADVANCE
THEIR MISSION TECHNOLOGY AND I'M
BUILDING OUT A DEDICATED FUNDING
PROGRAM WILL HELP ADVANCE THE
STATE REGULATIONS THANK YOU. FOR
LISTENING. YOU'RE WELCOME NEXT.
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS NATALIE
CALLING AREN'T IN ON BEHALF OF
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL AREN'T ISSUE
NUMBER ONE- DEFEAT MY YOU MORE
THAN MERELY INCREASE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS FROM LARGE INDUSTRY
SOURCES IT MUST REQUIRE AN
UNPRECEDENTED COORDINATED
TRANSITION FROM POLLUTING FUELS
TO ZERO EMISSION ENERGY.
LISTENING TO SPARK INVESTMENT
INTO ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES
THAT DO NOT CONTINUE TO
SACRIFICE A BUNCH MINNITI WE
SHOULD NOT BE INVESTING IN ANY
TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGICAL CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL BEFORE FULLY
COMMITTING TO NATURAL CYCLE
STATIONS SO THAT OPTION OF ZERO
EMISSION ENERGY. DESPITE A
GROWING BODY OF EVIDENCE THAT
THE US PROJECTS DO NOT WORK TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS AND IN SOME
CASES MAKE THEIR POLLUTION AND
CARBON EMISSIONS WORTH KEEPING
YOU UP FOR BOTH OF THEM MOVING
FORWARD. ASIDE FROM HEALTH
IMPACT THE TECHNOLOGY IS CLAIMED
CRY MADE BENEFITS HAVE NOT BEEN
PROVEN AND WE HAVE YET TO SEE A
PATHWAY PERCEIVE U. S. THAT IS
COST EFFECTIVE FULLY COMMITTING
TO RENEWAL RENEWABLE ENERGY AND
NUCLEAR AFTER HE ELECTRIFICATION
WILL MAKE ENERGY MORE
AFFORDABLE. FOR YOU ASK WHAT THE
SIGN TO SAFEGUARD FOSSIL FUELS
BOTH OF YOUR PROFITS NOT TO STOP
CLIMATE CHANGE OR PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE EVALUATE THE
EMERGING SCIENCE AND ENSURE THAT
IN OUR URGENCY. TO ACT ON
CLIMATE CHANGE WE ARE NOT
COMMITTING FURTHER BY MIDLAND
JUST- IN EVERY LEAGUE FAILING TO
MAKE MEANINGFUL. PROGRESS QUITE
A BIT THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SEVENTY NINE YEAR OLD ARE
YOU MUTED. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
GAIL YES I WAS THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING THIS IS GAIL
TELEHANDLERS WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AND I DO WANT TO
THANK- BUT THE SENATE FOR THE
DRINKING WATER FUN. AND FURTHER
COMMENT AND- CONDITIONS ON THE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS. I DO
THOUGH WANT TO ECHO BILLY
BROWN'S CONCERNS REGARDING-
IT'S- VOLUNTARY PLANS TO
PURCHASE WATER RIGHTS FROM
FARMERS. THE FOOD SECURITY ISSUE
ISRAEL AND IT'S ESTIMATED AT ONE
MILLION ACRES GOING OUT OF
PRODUCTION. IN CALIFORNIA DUE TO
THE LACK OF WATER AND SIGMA
IMPLEMENTATION- GET THE LOAN
EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND JOBS IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY ARE GOING TO
BE A LOT AND SO A LOT MORE
DISCUSSION REALLY NEEDS TO
HAPPEN- IN THIS AREA. I DO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT AND- SHE ATE- ANY TYPE
OF INPUT WE CAN HAVE ON THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AS IT'S
BEING DRAFTED- THESE ARE BIG
CONCERNS FOR US AND- WE DO
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT WE
PROVIDING COMMENTS THIS MORNING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NECKS. ONE
EIGHTY YOUR OPEN. GOOD MORNING A
PRODUCT AVAILABLE CRUISE WITH
CHRISTIANITY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD ACTION PUNCH
WE'RE CALLING TODAY TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT INCREASE YOU
SHOULDN'T FOR THE PROPOSED SIX
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS OVER
FIVE YEARS TO FIND A
COMPREHENSIVE WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE PACKAGE- AND JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU YOU'RE
WELCOME. THANKS SIX OF THE LINE
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS THOMAS MCMAHON CALLING
ON BEHALF OF WILD LANDS AND THE
SAN DIEGO ZOO IN SUPPORT OF THE
SENATE'S CLIMATE BUDGET PLAN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THE SPACE. NEXT WHY NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING-
CHAIR AND- MEMBERS DAVID GRAB
SPEAKING FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CENTER OF SAN DIEGO- PROVIDING
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
SENATE PACKAGE IN PARTICULAR THE
UP FUNDING FOR THIRTY BY THIRTY
AND COASTAL RESILIENCE WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THAT- INCREASED EVEN
MORE. AND INCLUDE FUNDING FOR
CAPACITY BUILDING OF NGOS TO
SUPPORT THE- CLIMATE WORK ON
THIRTY BY THIRTY THANK YOU. NEXT. SIX TWO NINE NINE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
ME. YES GO AHEAD WE HEAR YOU.
EXCELLENT EXCELLENT EXCELLENT
CALIFORNIANSARE MIDDLE VOTERS
I'M VERY GLAD YOU PUT THE-
BEHIND A PARTNER DAVID CROSBY
ENVIRONMENTAL CENTER SAN DIEGO
WOULD LIKE TO COME SITE HIS
COMMENTS- DEFINITELY APPRECIATE
A LOT OF BOOKS COMING OUT OF THE
SENATE BUDGET ON THE SENATE
BUDGET PLAN AND MY COMPLIMENTS
TO A LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR ALSO
EMPHASIZING THAT- C. C. S. C. C.
U. S. IS A- AS OF YET UNPROVEN
AND- TAKE. OUT THREATENS TO.
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF PURCHASE
CANNOT HELP- A COUPLE THINGS- WE
STILL CONDUCTED CHEVROLET CASKEY
A TO YOUR STAFF- IT WILL BE
PRESENTING THIS LETTER BROADLY
TO THE REST OF THE COMMITTEE
YOUR STAFF CONSULTANTS WE
APPRECIATE THE INCREASES WITH A
CLIENT BUDGET WE ARE SUGGESTING
THAT OVER THE COURSE OF FIVE
YEARS CALIFORNIA SHOOT FOR
SEVENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT THAT'S A DOUBLING
DOWN ON THE GOVERNOR'S INITIAL
INVESTMENT- IT CLIMATE. CLIMATE
CRISIS SOLUTIONS- A COUPLE
THINGS THAT HAVE COME UP- THAT
WE NOTICED WE APPRECIATE THE TWO
HUNDRED BILLION TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR- WATER EFFICIENCY-
ASKING FOR SIX HUNDRED MILLION
BOTH WATER EFFICIENCY AND WE RAN
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT TWO
YEARS- REALLY EXCITED TO SEE THE
MATRIX CLIMATE SOLUTIONS WE'RE
LOOKING FOR A TOTAL OF SEVEN
POINT SEVEN BILLION. HI CAN YOU
SHARE THAT LETTER WITH YOU LET'S
KEEP TALKING AND DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR HEART
WHAT'S GOING ON. MAKING
CALIFORNIA'S. WATERWORKS AQUA
CRISIS. THANK YOU THE- MY NAME
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THIS IS
ASHLEY GONZALEZ I- COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER WITH LANE AND LACKING
AND LISTEN I JUST WANTED TO GIVE
MY SUPPORT TO THE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR DROUGHT
RESILIENT WATER SUPPLY GRANTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT NEXT
DEADLINE APR SKEWS ME NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR KAREN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS READY CONTENT WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA METROPOLITAN
WISHES TO EXPRESS ITS
APPRECIATION TO THE SENATE FOR
PROPOSING THE ALLOCATION OF MUCH
NEEDED FUNDING SUCH AS THE ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION FOR DROUGHT
RESILIENCE THAT INCLUDES FUNDING
FOR WATER RECYCLING GROUNDWATER
CLEANUP AND STORMWATER CAPTURE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
DISCUSSION. THE EX. FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M CALLING
TO COMMENT ABOUT WATER AND
DROUGHT BUDGET PACKAGE MY IN THE
RIGHT PLACE YOU'RE IN THE RIGHT
PLACE GO AHEAD YOU'RE- IN FRONT
OF THE COMMITTEE. GREAT ALL THE
COMEDIC SEEMS TO BE ONE PERSON
BUT I GUESS THAT'S A DIFFERENT
TOPIC FOR A DIFFERENT TIME
ALTHOUGH I DO WONDER WHERE THE
LAWMAKERS ARE- BUT THAT BEING
SAID THE BUDGET- IS OF
PARTICULAR INTEREST TO ME. AS IT
RELATES TO FIRES BECAUSE I'M A
DISPLACED PERSON FROM SONOMA
COUNTY DUE TO THE TUBBS FIRE.
AND AS A RESULT OF TUBS ME AND
MY FAMILY OF SIX. INCLUDING MY
FOUR CHILDREN WERE WERE
DISPLACED THROUGH THAT HORRIFIC.
EVENT SO I JUST WANTED TO
MENTION A COUPLE THINGS IN TERMS
OF WATER AND IN TERMS OF THE
FIRES. SO READING FROM A
CALIFORNIA GLOBE ARTICLE FROM
PRIL TWENTY SEVENTH SINCE YOUR
TWO THOUSAND CALIFORNIA VOTERS
HAVE APPROVED EIGHT WATER BONDS
TOTALING MORE THAN THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS. AND THAT'S
ACCORDING TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND APPROVED
THE CONSTRUCTION OF TWO MORE.
THE ARTICLE GOES ON TO SAY
DROUGHTS ARE NATURE'S FAULT THEY
ARE NATURALLY OCCURRING WATER
SHORTAGES ARE THE FAULT OF
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS. CALIFORNIA
WATER SHORTAGES FALLS SQUARELY
ON FORMER GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
AND NOW ON GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM. RATHER THAN BUILD THE
DESPERATELY NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS TO
COLLECT AND STORE WATER DURING
WET YEARS GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
SIGNED INTO LAW IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN A NEW WATER
CONSERVATION ACT THAT WILL LIMIT
EACH CITIZEN TO JUST FIFTY OR
FIFTY FIVE GALLONS OF WATER PER
PERSON PER DAY. BY THE YEAR
TWENTY FIFTY. FOUR TERMS OF
WILDFIRES I WANTED TO READ A
LITTLE BIT- FROM AN ARTICLE FROM
JULY TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN BY
BRANDON REGIMEN FROM ABC TEN.
NINETY EIGHT SITTING MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AM
PAYING MONEY FROM. THE GAS
ELECTRIC COMPANY AFTER THE
COMPANY WAS CONVICTED OF SIX
FEDERAL FELONIES AND PLACED ON
PROBATION WITH A MANDATORY COURT
MONITOR. EIGHT OUT OF EVERY TEN
SITTING LAWMAKERS SO IN TERMS OF
THE SPECIFICS OF THIS BUDGET AS
IT RELATES TO BOTH WILD FIRES
AND WATER AT THIS HEARING IN MY
PERSPECTIVE. NOT ONLY DID IT
WALK LIKE AN INFOMERCIAL FOR
SPECIAL INTERESTS. IT SEEMS TO
BE YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE
SMOKE AND MIRRORS NO PUN
INTENDED OF THIS LEGISLATURE I
HEARING TAKING PLACE AT THE END
OF A DOMINO EFFECT OF
CATASTROPHIC POLICIES. THAT HAVE
CAUSED CALIFORNIA TO BE IN THE
BEST BUT IT IS WITH RESPECT TO
THESE FIRES AND WATER. THE BLAME
WHICH BUT I THE LADY CITIZEN
PAYING THE MOST BASIC ATTENTION
TO THIS. TRIBUTE TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR THE
CALL ME SKEPTICAL WHEN I ASK
WHAT YOU WILL DO THE LEGISLATOR
WE DID SET UP ANOTHER TASK FORCE
ANOTHER COMMITTEE AT THE
CALIFORNIA CARBON PLANS. HIRE
MORE EXPERTS WITH OUR MONEY WHEN
HAVE SO. FAILED US WITH YOUR
CALL UP UNTIL NOW. AND WHAT DO
TO SIT BACK TRUST I SORRY AS IT
IS PERSON FROM A WILD FOR WHO'S
ALL I'VE SCALE FOR. I DON'T
TRUST YOU FOR ONE MINUTE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. OF THE TOTAL AND OTHER
APPLICATION OF YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO CALIFORNIANS I
CAN'T BELIEVE I WASTED MY TIME
LISTENING TO YOUR EXPERTS AND
INCLUSION ONE QUOTE. WE KNOW
THEY ARE LYING THEY KNOW THEY
ARE LYING WE KNOW THEY KNOW THEY
ARE LYING BUT THEY ARE STILL
LYING. ALEXANDER IS INFINITE
NEEDS VEGETABLES AND EGGS AND
AUTHOR OF THE- LIKE A CAPPELLA
GO YOU'LL HAVE A GOOD DAY AND
PLEASE STOP BURNING DOWN
CALIFORNIA AND LETTING THE WATER
RUN OUT TO SEA. BECAUSE WE
EXPECT BETTER. MODERATOR NEXT.
I'M FIFTY YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MICHAEL PIMENTEL CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION I HEAR TO
THE VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
CATEGORIES OF INVESTMENT IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED MULTI
YEARS YOUR MISSION VEHICLE
PACKAGE BUT IF THE LEGISLATURE
REFUSE THAT PACKAGE WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU GO FURTHER TO
INCREASE THE FUNDING FOR
INTERMISSION TRANSIT BUSES. IN
THE SENATE SIDE THAT IS
IDENTIFIED WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AS WELL AS FOR EMERGING
OPPORTUNITIES IN RELATED
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PUT SOME
CONTEXT TWENTY AGENCIES ARE
REQUIRED BY CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
BOARD REGULATIONS TO. TRANSITION
TO COMPLETELY THERE A MISSION
LEADS BY TWENTY FORTY. THE
FUNDING ALL COMPLETELY CRITICAL
TO REDUCE THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THESE TECHNOLOGIES AND
ULTIMATELY HELP AVOID AGENCY
GLOBAL TRADE OFFS. FINALLY JUST
THAT SOONER STATE'S RAIL AND
FERRY AGENCIES WILL ALSO BE
SUBJECT TO THEIR MISSION
TRANSITION REQUIREMENTS AND YOUR
CARD REGULATIONS THAT WILL ALSO
CREATE NEW COST PRESSURES FOR
THEM. I. APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY THANK YOU.
NEXT ONE NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ACTUALLY MENTIONED
BLOGGERS ARE FROM LOS ANGELES
AND I'M JUST CALLING TO SUPPORT
THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR DROUGHT RESISTANT
WATER PROJECTS AND ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS FOR SAFE
DRINKING WATER AS WELL THANKS SO
MUCH BYE. NEXT MY MODEL TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT- TO YOUR
OPEN. WELL I WANTED TO HEAR YOU
. WOULD YOU LIKE TO TEST BOOK.
WHAT DO I OWE THEY'RE NOT
RESPONDING- WE HAVE ADJUSTED THE
Q. MESSENGER. OKAY NOBODY ELSE
IN THE QUEUE. WE'RE GOING THIS
TIME SIR ALL RIGHT WE'LL
CONCLUDE- THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD I WANT TO THANK THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE- OR VISIT OUR WEBSITES
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US. AND ONE
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION FOR A
CALENDAR- CONCERNS THE-
ANTICIPATION IS THAT ON FRIDAY
THE GOVERNOR WILL REDUCE OR
INTRODUCE HIS- MAY REVISE WHICH
IS- HE MIGHT INCORPORATE SOME OF
THE SENATE IDEAS OR MIGHT NOT
AND THEN- WE WILL HAVE A
HEARING. NEXT WEEK ON DEAD THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO GO
THROUGH THE AT LEAST A SECTION
SET UP AFFECT A SUBCOMMITTEE TO
AND THEN THE FOLLOWING WEEK ON
MAY EIGHT TWENTY THIRD. THE
SENATE WILL TAKE THIS. PROPOSAL
TO- THAT WEEK TO BEGIN THE
CONFERENCE. COMMITTEE WITH THE
ASSEMBLY I THINK OR- THE WEEK
AFTER. SO THOSE ARE THAT I WANT
TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
PATIENCE AND CORPORATIONS WE
WILL CONCLUDE TODAY'S HEARING
THE SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE TUESDAY
TURNED.